oh
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
sh
h
[Music]
he
B
[Music]
he
it's Friday I hope you guys at home are
having that Good Friday feeling we
actually warmed up here in the studio
with a pizza party and something smells
really good in the kitchen come join me
in here see what's uh happening in here
David what's up Ka it's the Grand Final
it's Magnus against Maxim so we're
getting the popcorn ready it's going to
be exciting oo I like it it's going to
be so much fun we're ready for the block
pasta ah oh I wish you guys at home
could just smell what I'm smelling right
now popcorn lean back everyone get your
popcorn going it's going to be so much
entertainment today welcome to the Grand
final of the AI
cup all his pieces after right s execute
and attack and finish the game this is
the chaos button that he's just pressed
what has this kid got in store he's so
good he's so good at thinking on the fly
checkm on the board Eduardo Daga reacts
he cele
oh
hello he is so stressed out sh he knows
he's so close in this one this is a Game
ending
move it is the very final day of the AI
Cup today either Magnus Carlson or Maxim
vajra will be crowned the winner of this
great tournament the last tournament in
the Champions chess tour before the tour
finals that will be played in in Toronto
still three players fighting for that
one ticket to get to Toronto and here
today to guide you through the Grand
Final the grinder the great The
Grandmaster David Howell and my fellow
lady in red The Marvelous former Asian
Champion Tanya satv and Tanya is this a
day where it's basically about getting
the popcorn out leaning back enjoying
some fantastic chess absolutely Kaa The
popcorn's ready we're all ready uh what
we witnessed between these two was
perhaps the most thrilling match of the
season so far both clearly the players
who played their best chest throughout
the AI cup and we get a dream final yeah
and I'm almost halfway through this bowl
of popcorn already yeah been enjoying
that and we want to see how you guys are
following the grand final today so share
your picture a selfie on Twitter using
the hash chess champs for a chance to
win an air things wave Mini we really
want to see how you guys are watching
this and enjoying this great great grand
final together with us and David it's an
uphill task for maxim V but what speaks
in the favor of him beating Magnus in
two matches today that's right it's not
going to be easy on paper it looks
almost impossible having to beat Magnus
first in a 4 game match and then a two
game match but he should take
inspiration from the way he's been
playing not just in the in this
tournament but over the last few months
Maxim's accuracy has been one of the
highest of the whole event he's nearly
never a blund in and his Killer Instinct
is on point he can do it but he needs to
strike first he cannot allow Magnus to
get the first win okay let's look back
to yesterday it was all about the losers
bracket yesterday with uh three players
fighting for that final spot here in the
Grand
Final Yan doing Yan things or not seems
to be the answer there wow that's an
aggressive move 5 seconds it's not much
time and the pawns are rolling and it's
just so much easier easier to play with
white right your moves are so much
easier just keep pushing the pawn
meanwhile black not do anything oh I
think he's just losing white can
continue pushing the pawns white has got
this in the bag it's going to be game
over any moment Yan is bobbing his head
here Anish knows it Anish knows this is
these are his last few moves in the AI
cup and it's
over bash de gra he's got this in the
bank if he can stay calm control his
nerves he's so close
wa wow why why wow what a move this is
uh a really strange one normally a
knight Never Lands on this Square it
looks like a fian ketto uh a knight on
B7 but I think he's about to win the
piece I think npom she's going to resign
there's a sneaky night check involved
also the black H porn that sorry porn
that we've been talking about for ages
it's about to finally drop off Yan is
going to click that resign button Queen
takes Queen the only move otherwise
white is winning wa the drama is not
over in this game and he makes the blund
off oh the bar jumps up for y piai oh
and Yan frowns suddenly a new lease of
life for him whoa I'm
surprised another blunder it's keeps
going that bar this is crazy the black
king is hiding Behind Enemy Lines it's
even taking pawns and black is actually
going to be the one delivering Checkmate
the checks are going to dry up and white
king is at the enemy's Mercy checks dry
up it's game over and Yan loses on time
Maxine
progresses and uh Maxine he started out
in the quarterfinals winning against Ali
Resa fua then he won against shakri
mamaro he did lose that Winner's final
against Magnus two days ago but in the
losers final yesterday mvl did knock out
y Pachi and Magnus Carlson he started
out with a match win against Hikaru
Nakamura then he knocked nomachi down to
losers bracket he won the winners final
against MV yesterday was a rest day for
Magnus and here he is ready for his his
third consecutive Grand Final it's going
to be an exciting day it's not only
about winning the Grand Final you guys
this is the final day after six events
before the tour finals and still one
ticket is up for grabs in the tour
finals for Toronto seven players are
ready but who will grab that final
ticket we have to go through the
scenarios David what can happen who can
make it how can they make it yeah this
is a big day for that final spot three
players are still in contention two of
them will be involved in today's play of
course Maxi Vash lra we've mentioned it
he'll take on Magnus Carlson he needs to
win he needs to defeat Magnus if he
wants to qualify for Toronto in December
fed is also in action he's playing the
division 2 Grand Final right now if Maxi
vasra doesn't win then fed has a shot
but he needs to win his match and there
is also Yan pesi watching from home
maybe with some popcorn as well but he's
going to be hoping that both mvl and fed
have lose if they both lose NPI will be
the one to steal that final ticket can
you believe itanya that it went through
all the way to the final day in the
sixth event and we still don't know
who's going to be that eighth player in
Toronto how cool is that right it just
shows us the kind of close fight that
this has been and three players fighting
it out uh for maxim VRA in one way the
path is the easiest but also the most
difficult he wins the tournament he
makes it through to Toronto but he is
playing against Magnus Carlson he has to
not beat him once but has to do it twice
meanwhile Yan Naish is the one who's
just sitting back at home and probably
enjoying with a bit of pocor himself
yeah and fedos he has to work hard he
needs to win division two he is playing
the Grand Final in division 2 right now
actually the first game against uh
vladislav artv has finished with a draw
so game two will start there and we will
of course update you on the action in
division 2 it is uh all about for these
three players now to bank that final
ticket to go to the tour finals in
Toronto six
events eight
players we are nearing the end of the
2023 season and the fight to secure a
spot at the 2023 tour finals is on
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and nbec
abdusattorov have already qualified
through winning individual events Wesley
so Fabiano caruana alera fua and Dennis
lazic punched their tickets with tour
points and now only one spot Remains the
tour finale will be played from December
9th to 16th in Toronto
Canada follow to see who will get the
chance to fight for the 2023 Champions
chess tour
title and you also have a chance to go
to Toronto because you can bid for a
chance uh for the uh AI Cup trophy uh
which is an nft trophy and owning this
AI generated trophy comes with a ticket
to the 2023 tour finals in Toronto in
Canada in December so go to chess
champs. and make your bid and we did see
those seven players that are already
ready for Toronto what do you expect for
that big final that will be played in
December Tanya it's going to be awesome
uh just the stage is set only one more
seat remaining we've seen the players
who've made it through uh it's such a
cool chance for everyone watching to
actually see these players live in
action in Toronto fighting it at the
whole tour this season is designed Kaa
to Crown the ultimate King in online
speed chess and we're going to find that
out when it happens in Toronto yep and
later in the show today there's actually
another Trophy up for grabs because uh
it's going to be in mini golf David
challenged Magnus Carlson in a sport he
has newly found interest for golfing
okay this one is
hard oh that's a terrible Miss I can get
it there and then
[Music]
through oh wow oh no
no I did not realize it could even go
off the edge there yeah that's pretty
bad oh that's not one yeah that's one
that's another
one
okay let's say you're on like I'm on
like five five yeah that was my fourth
day yeah fourth
[Music]
okay well we've seen on magnus's
Instagram that he's uh started to play
golf what's your golf skills like d that
was the first time I've played in years
and uh it wasn't an easy course let's
just say that but it was a lot of fun if
this makes you feel better David yeah
thank you T don't take it away from me
you're going to see my hand today all
this all day long all right all right
anyways that's coming later today we're
going to see what happened when David
and Magnus played mini golf but now
we're looking forward to the Grand Final
and only two days ago Magnus Carlson and
Maxim vajra played the winners finally
here in the AI cup and it has been
described as maybe the best match so far
in the Champions chestor season yeah
there we go it's on the board Magnus
will he Retreat his
queen as we're expecting the fact paused
Queen sacrifice Magnus surprising us not
retreating to a passive Square gives up
his Queen and then Maxine gives the
queen straight back that was crazy
suddenly magnus's queenside pawns will
run black is too slow in this race and
Maxim knows it he looks away and Magnus
takes the win Maxim resigns wow we have
the first descided
game what a rook sacrifice instantly for
Maxi Vash
gra this is crazy this is genius there's
checkmating ideas all over the place one
move now for Magnus Carlson and he finds
it wow and he finds it in less than a
minute Maxi meanwhile going forward with
his King wow look at this if he pushes
his Pawn will he get M Magnus Carlson on
the edge of the board we all know queen
versus Rook how hopeless that is Magnus
allows a Checkmate on the board and we
have
om it is a dead drawn position we should
clarify the departure of knights Magnus
gave up his extra paorn to get the
knights off the board means it's a dead
draw and Maxim doesn't try to
he offers the draw and Magnus progresses
today I mean I made mistakes he made
mistakes we both found resources it was
was a lot of lot of fun today great
match and uh I thought
Maxim um played the way he plays when he
plays well like uh giving it a really
really good fight I think I can play
even better but I'm I'm fairly happy
considering the complexity of the
positions even Magnus Carlson happy with
his play these are the stats from that
match in five games overall the accuracy
almost 94 for Magnus and over 94% for
maim vajra David how incredible is that
accuracy these are simply two worldclass
players these stats are incredible
because Magnus himself in that interview
described the games the positions as
complex and in complex positions you
expect the accuracy to drop you expect
there to be blunders in accuracies but
these guys they were playing the best
moves consistently and in the end it was
just a tiny margin just the Armageddon
uh was the only way to separate them
yeah Antonio what can you say about
magnus's play in this tournament has he
impressed you more than he even usually
does it's been amazing uh he's in the
Grand Final and I think the most
exciting match that he had in the whole
event was against Maxim vasher lra but
it's not just been this tournament this
entire year for Magnus Carlson to me
it's reminiscent of his performance in
the 2019 and I think we spoke about this
earlier in the broadcast as well 2019
was the year of Magnus Carlson he was
winning every single tournament that he
played uh and 23 as well he this is his
uh potentially his fourth title in the
Champions chto he's won three already
the World Cup performance the grest
performance uh the guy looks Unstoppable
right now yeah it's going to be a tough
one for
maxim he played fantastic two days ago
got so close to beating Magnus what is
that
little inch that he needs today to be
able to beat Magnus what can he do
differently oh it's going to be tough K
imagine playing your best playing such
an incredible high accuracy and still
not uh pulling off the victory it's
going to be tough he needs to maintain
that level and hope Magnus drops off
slightly and if he gets even the
slightest even a half chance he has to
jump he has to pounce I think striking
first getting the first win will be the
key and then just clinging on taking it
game by game uh move by move I actually
think if Maxim is able to take this
first set and go into the Grand Final
reset he would become a favorite it's
only a best of two in that uh and uh I
agree with David it's about trying to
get that first win we spoke about this
when they played against each other two
days ago try to get Magnus into those
tricky complicated chaotic positions it
worked really well for maxim the first
time around when he succeeded in doing
that uh today will he be able to get
that coffee house chest going on the
board at a superficial level it looks
crazy there we see Magnus Carlson he's
ready to go but crazy is the only way
you can beat this guy yeah he did uh
over sleep actually two days ago even if
it's uh 6 o 6:00 in Norway but Magnus
cson is now ready by the computer with
the white pieces in game one against
Maxim vajra what should we expect
opening wise in this match for Magnus
he's been really ambitious in the
opening both with both colors usually
kind of with most top players with white
they'll push they'll press for an
advantage with black they'll be solid
but Magnus has been going for it going
at his opponents and it's given his
opponents chances uh Maxim was able to
get one of those games Magnus giving us
a tour of his room I spotted some food
but there was some takeaway a lot of
takeaway and the big takeway I think
from Maxim from the other day was that
he needs to get those wild positions as
tan mentions he cannot go for anything
too slow too grindy uh against Magnus it
won't pay off he just needs that chaos
two very different setups Max very clean
everything around him uh Magnus it's
just a
mess mess on the board but in his head
things seems to be uh seem to be Crystal
Clear yeah yeah it is about to start you
guys this is the Grand Final in the AI
cup Maxim vajra is not only fighting to
win this match he is fighting to get
that final ticket to Toronto it will be
best out of four rapid games here in the
Grand Final with a potential armagedon
to decide the winner if if the winner is
Maxim vajra then there will be a grand
final reset because Magna still hasn't
lost a match he has been on the winners
bracket this whole tournament and in uh
the Grand Final reset it its best out of
two rapid games and here we go this is
game one it has started this is game one
and David we already have a switch up
from what we saw in their first Clash
already a switch up uh we did not see
the Queen's Gambit in their first Clash
now it's the Queen's Gambit accepted and
Magnus will have to hope that his
opening is better than his air quality
which is pretty poor right now Magnus is
the first one to pause Maxim switched up
his opening repertoire we talked about
it throughout this week no more grunfeld
defense which was his habitual go-to uh
weapon Now Queens Gambit accepted and uh
Tanya is it strange to see Magnus pause
already I think it's strange to see
Maxim as well go ahead with this uh qga
the accepted Pawn sacrifice in this
Queen's Pawn opening this is definitely
something that Magnus was not expecting
probably he was hoping for more of a
grinfield the traditional Maxim approach
uh but Maxim spoken about this that he's
actually worked on making his opening
repertoire more versatile harder to
predict and it's been paying off so
really interesting because their first
match it always started with the King
spawn opening went completely wild but
Magnus perhaps trying to keep things
more in control get more of those
strategic battles yeah and the reason
I'm surprised Magnus paused at all there
is because Maxim's been reling on the
Queen's Gambit accepted throughout this
event and throughout recent tournaments
and had a lot of success with it so uh
Magnus he had a day off yesterday I
would have expected him to do some
homework here again he's kind of
fidgeting around here not yet settled
into the game uh he's burned around one
minute despite this being a very
well-known position uh White having one
back the Gambit at Pawn the Queen's
Gambit not a real Gambit uh whisper it
quietly everyone you win the PN back
usually with white and here okay white
is the first to Castle but black is
going to strike in the center now now
often we see a symmetrical Pawn
structure after a few trades here and
there and uh very level play but okay
Magnus now expanding stopping actually
the black pawns from pushing on the
queen side and for the first time it's
mvl in the tank yeah he's still ahead on
the clock though and with that last move
by Magnus it takes away certain
possibilities for black but in contrast
gives away a key Square in the position
longterm which is that B4 post often
used by black uh for the KN to jump in
eventually from B8 to C6 to uh the spot
which has been left behind by magnus's
last move I'm also expecting a trade in
the center to create some long-term
weaknesses and uh Maxim he's thinking
about it the question here for maxim is
does he immediately trade in the center
or delay it with developing the night
because you want to and he does go for
the night development you want to delay
the development of the bishop on the
king side uh to save some tempos yeah
still a wellknown position actually this
is is also a known position from a slav
defense with Black's Pawn on as6 being
back one square so uh the players they
use all these patterns and Magnus I know
has had experience there he brings this
Rook across now again a temporary Gambit
temporary sacrifice but he'll win it
back uh due to the Rook staring down at
the black queen there's a pin he'll take
back the pawn next move and now Vash
grav should most likely just hurry get
developed get that black king to safety
he's going to move the black Dart Square
bishop and there we go after white
recaptures in the center safety for the
black King still well-known territory
the players thinking a little bit though
maybe some nerves at these early stages
settling in into the big Grand Final and
once again with that last move that
Magnus played it's an option it's in
it's a choice for white in these
positions what do you recapture with in
the center and Magnus eventually decides
to take with the pawn so we see these
Dynamics with an isolated Queen's pawn
and there we have it the Knight jumps to
the square that I was pointing out
earlier to actually eventually land on
that uh D5 spot in front of the Central
Pawn it's going to be about whether
white is able to create attack on the
king side peace activity in return for
this uh Pawn weakness out of the opening
yeah and Magnus is the type of player
who doesn't really like taking on the
responsibility of por weaknesses unless
he knows what his compensation is unless
he knows there's a kind of specific plan
uh to activate his pieces to go for the
attack and the fact again that he's
pausing is slightly concerning right now
white has this isolated porn in Center
it will be blockaded by a black knight
in the near future and therefore it's
time to bring pieces into the action
White's d square Bishop most likely
about to come out White's Knight on the
king side can jump into E5 lots of uh
potential plans here but this is the
type of position he could have predicted
Maxine plays the Queen's Gambit accepted
this is a position you can get almost by
force it's really strange to see Magnus
thinking um we're used to these top
players in the world just bashing out
the moves to move 10 15 20 instantly if
they know what their opponents are going
to do it's going to be interesting to
find out what was the mindset for maxim
uh for Magnus going into this position
and then uh taking his time in the
opening wonder if he was maybe more
expecting the grunfeld setups but as you
say that Maxim has been playing this so
it should have been something that
Magnus expected in any case these kind
of positions are not something that
Magnus is not familiar with he I mean
every position he's familiar with but
the plans are so clear for white in this
one uh bring that Knight to The Outpost
on E5 bring that Bishop to G5 eventually
uh get the A1 Rook to the C1 open Line
develop your pieces and try and look for
play against the black's King side
meanwhile for black for maxim also uh
the next few moves are pretty automatic
to make you want to develop the light
Squad bishop and C8 so ideas like B6
Bishop B7 I actually play these
positions with white David and I kind of
really enjoy the Dynamics of uh keeping
the pieces on the board yeah it's uh
interesting T most of the time these
days I play this opening from the black
side uh I used to my whole opening
rep on these isolated Queens pawns I
love them in all sorts of openings
Sicilians carakan as white French
defenses just pushing them forward
trying to break trying to get active and
then I decided nah it's too much fun for
me and I prefer the long positional
grind where black often tries to park a
piece in front of the isolated porn
blockades and goes for a slower game and
okay the most natural move I think the
most popular move at least in the
position White's kn jumping into the
center and now I'm expecting Maxim to go
for one of those two plans you mentioned
either uh pushing the pawn and trying to
bring the bishop to the long diagonal or
doing it this way with his Bishop still
a well-known position I've had this
actually many times myself this exact
position but with the black pawn back on
A7 from a different uh branch of a
different opening and there uh yeah the
plans are basically identical and you
move on the board Tanya he's getting
ready to fetto his Bishop he's ready to
finish that development meanwhile now
for white uh can you be the one who
takes takes control of that diagonal
with the queen move it can be tempting
to a lot of people watching a lot of the
chess audience there move like Queen to
F3 but David then black just s side
steps with the rook and the bishop
eventually will come out in fact hitting
that Queen so uh it's a double double Ed
sword to move uh the queen there and I
think for many you know it's hard to
imagine that how do you beat Magnus in a
mat situation right uh Maxim has done
everything in this tournament to get
this far and then he's playing against
Magnus has to beat him twice how does he
do it but let's let's just remember that
actually Maxim has done this before in
2020 in the speed Chess Championship he
actually knocked out Magnus Carlson in
the semi-finals with a 1311 score but
Magnus didn't have to wait too long to
get revenge for that one yeah he he does
have the upper hand Magnus in general
historically in the head-to-head here
but Maxim has won that big match in the
past so can take hope inspiration from
that meanwhile I don't really like
magnus's last move I've got to admit
unless uh he's got something up his
sleeve here because trading pieces in
this exact porn structure will only
accentuate only highlight the weakness
of White's isolated Central porn uh if
all the knights disappear if all the
Bishops disappear only black can ever
win uh because the more pieces disappear
the weaker that porn becomes we have a
question David uh from a viewer uh just
wondering but uh why do players take so
long in opening prep uh that's a good
question I mean there's there's kind of
two schools of thought here um there's
certain players Yan pomi for example
usually Maxim Vash gra and others who
just if they know what they're doing
they play instantly they make moves bang
bang bang um then there's players like
me who if even if we know what we're
doing we'll take a bit of time we'll
pretend that we don't know lull our
opponents into a full sense of security
and then uh kind of up the speed a bit
later in the game and then there's also
the situation where you simply don't
know what's going on and you're
freestyling making it up as you go and
uh that often costs a lot of time too U
but yeah slightly surprising Magnus
knows these types of positions as Tanya
mentioned he knows all the ideas maybe
he's just uh trying to get Maxim out of
his preparation he's trying to get his
opponent guessing uh and thinking for
himself and this is an interesting
maneuver he's uh found a rare idea here
lifting his Rook it really is and it's
uh as I was saying that I've played
these position studed them but this is
not an idea that I am familiar with as
well but it really shows magnus's
understanding in this we were a little
critical about the decision to trade off
a pair of knights because when you have
this isolated weakness in the center of
the board you want to keep as many
pieces on the board for those attacking
chances but Magnus has that attacking
chance in his head but in a different
way he wants to get the queen side Rook
all the way across to the king side with
this Rook lift Rook from A3 super
flexible can go to that G3 Square lining
itself up with the king or even to that
H file eventually lining up with the
queen to hit that pawn on H7 I think
this could be a a very new idea on how
to handle this queen Gambit accepted
position trade off one pair of knights
in the queen side and then get the Rook
into to the attack okay yeah he needed
to get his Knight out the way uh White
previously had a night sitting on the C3
Square so he has cleared this third rank
for his Rook but I'm skeptical once uh
you have traded a set of pieces you have
fewer attacking pieces left uh for
yourself and black for example at some
point will just push a pawn to G6 and uh
okay I don't think you'll do it now but
this structure in general is known to be
Rock Solid it's extremely hard to break
down and okay Maxim going for the tricky
tactics already uh the tricky Frenchman
has he has been called by some of his
Rivals sacrificing a pawn here and what
is the idea after Rook takes rook in the
corner black will recapture with the
queen and hit this Pawn he's also
hitting the white Bishop so I don't
think Magnus wants to do this he takes
the pawn immediately and I guess Maxim
wants to threaten Checkmate wants to
threaten it in one move look at the
battery now along this diagonal Queen
and Bishop attacking just a pawn this
would be Checkmate if the queen can
capture but he's allowing The Rook to
come across and defend really surprising
I don't see what the pawn has been given
up for here tan yeah and The Rook was
headed there to start with with the Rook
CT Magnus had it in mind to get it to
the G3 square and the good news for
white is that the bishop on B5 is
defended with the queen on E2 so it's
not really a double attack and I think
we're going to see this being played out
Rook G3 feels like the most natural
response in this position uh and I
wonder if Black's compensation here is
based on one of the Rooks taking on the
open a line and the other coming on to
the Open Sea line trying to infiltrate
from that C2 Square yeah could control
over these two open files looks really
really nice here for black so your
guaranteed compensation White's extra
Pawn is going to be isolated two
isolated pawns here uh mean that
longterm actually in an end game white
is far from guaranteed to win even with
a material advantage uh but still
slightly curious didn't feel that
necessary uh he just wants to distract
magnus's Army on one side of the board
no more attack um interesting Maxim he's
known for his Pawn sacrifices uh these
kind of intuitive uh initiative based
Pawn sacrifices but yeah he he could
have maybe played a safer way uh safer
approach there but safe never works with
Magnus and I think this is exactly what
we've been talking about from the start
of the show right it's about trying to
get this these chaotic complicated
positions on the board where sure the
evaluation bar or an engine it just
grabs the pawn and then defends
perfectly but from a more human
perspective uh you can expect more
mistakes on the board you can expect
your opponent to go wrong uh playing
against Magnus I think you have to have
that grave that guts approach that if
you see an opportunity to create the
chaos you just go for it what do we
think is Magnus going to spot that Maxim
is threatening Checkmate in one move
question just sit back with the popcorn
and wait wait for that to be
answered do we already have that match
that we uh kind of wanted just these two
going all out feels like it's starting
it feels like it's simmering slowly at
the moment Maxim he's the first one to
sacrifice he's given up a porn we saw
some crazy sacrifices the other day ma
Magnus throwing away his his Queen then
Matt Vash giving it back um so I think
this is the beginning still a long day
of Chess ahead of course but Mt Magnus
is the one to start on the back foot
he's a pornup but defending reacting
it's never where the top players want to
be they want to be dictating the pace of
the game and is he out of the opening
now with Maxim sort of playing that a
little bit surprising move yeah I think
uh we're well and truly out of the
opening usually uh historically we said
once both sides of castle that's the end
of the opening phase but with the dawn
of computers I think now we're a bit
more flexible with that it tends to be
when uh the kind of last player is out
of their homework their preparation now
for sure both players are on their own
okay and that's what makes it so
exciting right out of opening
preparation but you still come up with
this really creative idea to build this
initiative with the black pieces to give
up upon PA right out of the opening
against the world number one uh it
requires a lot of guts and it was so
nice to talk to Maxim yesterday after he
won his match against y pach he was
almost a little bit emotional we could
definitely uh see that this means a
whole lot to him after a few years with
uh not the results he wants basically
and I I understand he's been struggling
a little bit but now he he is here
showing that he he really is one of the
best in the world he really is and uh uh
yeah I think Maxim has been pretty vocal
about uh his struggles over the last few
years not getting the kind of
performances that he was looking for or
what his strength really is and it had a
lot to do with his decision to get new
openings into his repertoire to try to
just become a more versatile player out
of the opening he's been one of the best
using these night offs and these
grinfield but over the last couple of
years we've seen a big shift in his
opening repertoire and I think it takes
a little time to uh kind of just uh find
your balance in that and all that hard
work and that prep I think eventually
it's kind of the puzzle is coming
together for maxim Sher gra it's not
just this tornament in the last few
months we've seen just just incredible
chest from him once again starting from
the steel chess India rapid with the
best players he won that field
convincingly his performance in the
speed Chess Championship uh yeah it's uh
it's been awesome to watch Maxim back at
his best yeah yeah learning new openings
it's like starting a new job or it's
like learning to walk again in a way
sometimes it's a bit slow at first but
now he's well and truly kind of
remembered how to walk and he's running
at high speed now with these new
openings uh these new openings they seem
to suit his strengths really well I
think he's picked uh really wisely he
had these Dynamic openings in the past
and look at the position he's got Now
Queens gamb be accepted known for being
solid but it's got Dynamic potential and
uh all of Black's pie really active I
think he's loving his position bashra
it's a very Maxim position and what I
also really loved hearing from him
yesterday was that how this year and his
performance has actually motivated him
for the candidates the tournament in
Toronto which the players really want to
get to and uh he's got the grand Swiss
coming up where you can make it to the
candidates if you finish in top two uh
so this has given him a lot lot of Hope
and motivation to fight for that and
yeah that's awesome to hear because he's
been playing fantastic chess yeah and uh
we enjoy that when we can watch MBL and
Magnus at their very best fighting it
out today this is only the first game
out of uh at least uh four games or
maybe even just three uh in the Grand
Final and we want to see how you guys
are watching the grand final today so
share your picture or a selfie on
Twitter orx using the hash chess champs
for a chance to
win this tiny little air things wave
mini to monitor your air quality at home
uh we will choose a winner and we really
want to see how you guys are watching
this and enjoying this Friday with the
best chess players in the world and the
best chess commentary in the world thank
you K while the air things device is a
mini one I think this match is not going
to be a mini match because uh I really
like what we're seeing on the board
right now and the clock Max seem twice
the amount of time almost compar to
Magnus so he's forced him to think quite
early on and it's again all about the
initiative that Rook on the SE line uh
looking to infiltrate into White's Camp
the last move by Magnus developing the
bishop does hit the Knight on B4 so you
need to be just a little careful about
whether you have the opportunity right
now David to actually come in with the
Rook to pin that Bishop do you think
that might work out I think it's
definitely something to calculate here
and Vash gra is so good calculation he
on his radar of course if he brings the
rook in he pins this bishop he doesn't
win it of course uh but he's actually
attacking this Pawn that's the secondary
uh Motif the one downside I think
instinctively in Rapid chest Blitz chess
is you don't really want to leave a king
on the back rank uh exposed here white
cannot deliver a check a check would be
deadly at this point uh so it looks fine
it looks acceptable here but somehow
alarm Bells might be ringing in his head
and there are safe options as well uh he
could for example just move this KN this
KN could go back he could maybe defend
the Knight with his Queen I like that
yeah just going active feels right here
uh I mean this was the first move that
was I that I was drawn to as well Tanya
I've got to agree I would love to see
that on the board really trying to
invade wh's Camp here but this one might
be tempting uh for vley gra as well just
hitting a pawn and if white tries to
defend it with his Bishop then the Black
Knight simply tries to remove the
defender it feels really loose for white
actually and Black's pieces are creeping
in uh don't be surprised as well if in
the near future both sides take a
timeout with a porn push just to clear
uh the back ground to give their kings
some breathing space really tense
position but Max's definitely cooking up
something he's trying to find something
creative uh he doesn't just want to
retreat this night it's not a maxi move
even if it's a good one a safe one uh to
drop back right
now okay oh he does I was thinking that
you know your night is hanging loose
pieces drop off and as you said just
intuitively you want to keep things more
in control especially with less than 8
minutes on the clock a back rank
weakness than light hanging I loved your
suggest gestion of actually jumping in
with the queen felt a lot more
attractive once you pointed it out David
but this one Maxim isn't backing down he
goes for the most direct approach
attacking the B2 Pawn pinning that D2
Bishop uh wow this is once again quite a
brave decision by Maxim and now the big
question is can white actually take
advantage of that weakness that you
pointed out the back rank weakness I was
thinking offer a trade on C1 but Magnus
just simply sidest steps with the pin
saying that actually black can recapture
that pawn on B2 and restore material
balance yeah I think Magnus is setting a
really sneaky trap here a really cunning
trap in this position there was a pin
the White Queen was slightly vulnerable
so she's dropped back she's also
defending G2 note that now the White
Knight is free it's no longer pinned on
this diagonal to the G2 pawn and if Vash
gra gets greedy here and recaptures his
Pawn look at the evaluation bar it would
shoot up because white can suddenly
initiate a double attack hitting the
rook and the Knight the black Rooker
only one square to keep defending uh its
Knight and suddenly a second double
attack look at the Bishops hitting the
queen hitting the rook and it's this
queen hiding away in the on the back
rank defending the bishop that plays the
star role and black would lose material
next turn so he cannot get greedy Vash
the grv of course he should spot this uh
it's a two3 move tactic here but taking
the pawn would lose it would backfire
immediately but do you think he missed
this do you think he missed that Max
Magnus could actually just side step
with the pin and keep all the threats on
the board I think that's an easy move to
miss backward Moves In general are hard
to spot and uh especially backward
Knight moves backward Queen moves uh I
noticed they catch out a lot of top
players Maxim is lucky here that he has
options uh but he has to worry about how
to defend this Knight the one thing he
probably doesn't want to do either is to
drop his Knight back because suddenly we
would see the black Rook trapped Behind
Enemy Lines suddenly there's no way home
no way to safety and White's Bishop will
simply come and capture you in the next
few turns uh actually V gra we might
need a clue here we might need a hint
from the computer how narrow is his path
oh uh this Rook dive into the position
into C2 it was Brave but oh okay he has
a few moves to keep the balance none of
them are obvious though bringing the
Black Knight to A2 uh looks bizarre
that's the second best move the computer
maybe the best move okay he finds it it
was the most natural of those
suggestions just defending the Knight
and at least now you are also opening up
your Bishop to strike and ruin the white
Pawn structure if black gets time to
capture on the F3 Square next suddenly
the tactics it's in the back of your
mind as soon as tactics work for your
opponent you get a bit worried you get a
bit scared uh so Vash gra retreating as
well not a good sign Magnus will be
slightly happier with that little uh
kind of transition of moves what's a
good sign is that Maxim finds the best
move in the position because there was a
big threat of actually trapping that
black rook and now I think uh those
moves just don't work out for Magnus
because if white was to step up with the
bishop and we need to do a deep dive
into it because it's such a critical
moment for this game one if white was to
step up with the the bishop to C3 Maxim
has the time to First destroy the pawn
structure on the king side and now step
back with the Knight to that square that
we were pointing out in the opening and
white doesn't have uh enough momentum to
trap the bishop you can come back Bishop
to D3 but Black's the one to White's
Rook first just simply take on C3 hit
that Rook on D1 that's an intereso and
everything uh is solved in Black's favor
yeah the very end I mean this is a lot
of tactics a lot of moves but we would
just do a quick count it's level pawns
but it's the quality of Pawns here all
of White's pawns shattered
uh doubled isolated and despite the
opposite color Bishops black is in full
control uh so I don't think Magnus will
find that to appealing but then again
how to deal with this threat on the
White Knight it's not easy this Knight
is tied down defending some key pawns
and if black ever captures wrecks the
structure then it can only be Maxim who
can ever win with a safer King uh so
yeah suddenly Stakes are high I said
retreating not positive for fash gra but
actually Magnus still has to be careful
has to be accurate here and I'm I'm not
sure what he will try actually Magnus
Carson 3 minutes against almost six yeah
it's getting dramatic on the clock ooh
dramatic on the board and dramatic on
the clock and I'm just wondering if it's
time for Magnus to neutralize that
really active Rook of blacks on the
second Rank by offering the trade with
his own Rook to see one uh David taking
advantage of a point that you made
earlier that black does have a back rank
weakness to deal with yeah I think we
might see that Tanya just an offer of a
rook trade there we go on the board and
Maxim has to be slightly careful don't
move this Rook out the way White will
infiltrate White's Rook will be ready to
to jump in and okay who would you hold
as a favorite here Tanya black still a
pawn down but good compensation who
would you pick really good activity and
tough to call a result I think this is a
game for all three results uh I'm going
to predict a draw in this one okay what
how about you David oh still my answer
T um I think a draw is still the
favorite because neither side has made
any clear blunders any clear mistakes
it's still very very balanced black will
likely win back the pawn sooner or later
um but I'll say okay I'll say Maxim just
because of the clock situation and uh we
saw a message from the twitch chat a
moment ago saying Magnus maybe not quite
warmed up yet I have the same feeling
and he did have a rest it yesterday I
heard you guys talk about uh previously
in in the tour that you know that can
sort of ruin your routine a little bit
maybe it's all about momentum right when
you're in the flow of things when you're
playing well very often you don't want
that rest day you don't want to pull in
those break uh but on the other hand
when you're having a tough tournament
you always want to take that day off and
get back into it so I think it could go
either way H but the thing with Magnus
is this is just so uh so typical where
he does start slow any kind of event any
kind of match situation we've often seen
Magnus have a slow start and then just
go full speed so if you're able to
really catch him early on in the match
uh that's where your best uh chances lie
and I think Ma Maxim knows that better
than any one else which is why he's gone
for this kind of an sharp tactical
approach in the game and even this last
move he just keeps the tension on and
really giving Magnus some problems
ticking down now to two and a half
minutes left on the clock Magnus could
that be eventually a big problem for him
it definitely could especially if it
remains this tense and I love Maxim's
last move the bishop in the corner not
doing anything it comes to defend its
Rook just as Tanya says keeping the
tension and that's the key when you want
to trick your opponent especially if
you've got half an eye on the clock the
biggest mistake is actually to rush to
clarify things to trade off pieces
because then it makes your opponent's
position simpler but by keeping pieces
on not necessarily trading look at this
Magnus is the one actually panicking and
trying to force the issue uh he's really
trying to kick out that black Rook from
his camp and uh yeah Maxim's done
everything right every time I think
there's a mistake that could trip him up
he finds the best reply and okay as Rook
trade was eventually forced now watch
out for the White Queen coming to C8 to
the the top of the board checking that
black king the black king has no Escape
squares that would be a deadly check
therefore he blocks the file again Maxim
just spotting everything uh keeping
control and look at the Black Knight The
Black Queen the black dark squared
Bishop they're all pointed towards
White's Central Pawn and I think the
material balance will be restored
shortly still a level position but all
three results possible yeah and what's
so impressive is that Maxim is finding
these best moves in the position with
the speed with which he's doing I mean
he is a 2021 world BL champion and we're
clearly seeing why that's the case uh
but this is not an easy position to play
just every move is a high responsibility
move in these kind of situations where
you're down upon and you're fighting for
the initiative but Maxim just on his
aame plays on equal ground even against
the world's best player this last move
Knight to C6 it takes care of White's
Queen not jumping into not infiltrating
uh Black's Camp blocks up the sea file
now and it's never a happy option for
white to trade this night uh David I'm
just wondering Magnus up a pawn you
don't want to take that knight uh I
think that's something that would give
black more than enough compensation and
it's hard to imagine this extra Pawn
really coming to anything because B4 is
always met with this F3 Knight hanging
in so many situations and the D4 Pawn
coming under Fire as well yeah this
would be simply disastrous as you point
out Tanya uh note how this check now on
the back rank is not Checkmate anymore
because Black's Bishop can actually drop
back and block defended by the queen and
suddenly Black's attentions would turn
towards the white king and uh Magnus
does play a move he hits the black queen
and the black queen doesn't have too
many squares uh actually she has to
defend her Knight so you might have to
be a bit careful here and play Queen to
the center and now Magnus if he is
feeling scared he's only got one minute
on the clock if he wants to bail out and
play safe and probably head for a draw
then he can actually Force the Queens
off he can take this Knight forcing a
queen trade and here it should
eventually fizzle out white has an extra
Pawn still but the two Bishops should
compensate and uh eventually this Pawn
will most likely fall off or we'll see
an opposite color Bishop position and uh
yeah safety for both
sides is Knight Tak spawn completely
crazy here wow giving up the black queen
we've seen Queen sacrifices between
these two before and of course the black
queen is actually hit right now and you
don't care you want to ignore this I
care and you know exactly why I care
yeah but you can get away with it the
bar doesn't react night Pawn is a queen
sacrifice because if the black queen is
captured suddenly a fork and you regain
the material and at the very end still
Level pawns but actually black is very
active and he doesn't go for it this was
a lot to calculate maybe the one thing
that scared him was that a check could
have been given but now Black's Queen
could drop back and block uh I think
this was an opportunity to force the
issue but we go for that other variation
we mentioned now it's level material
black is threatening this night if we
see actually it's Black's move right now
if we see Maxim Vash the graph take this
night I think we'll see a draw very
shortly level pawns now and despite what
White's fractured pawns on the king side
not enough material left he shouldn't do
that right he's so much up on the clock
you guys said it he needs to take his
chances if he's going to beat Magnus but
he did Ka the kind of position that he
got out of the opening and this is Maxim
going for the draw on his terms he's up
on the clock absolutely no problem out
of the opening with the black pieces is
the one who fought for the initiative uh
so in some ways as we like to call it in
the studio some kind of a moral victory
in game one okay yeah moral Victory and
I think the longer he thinks he kind of
spends mulling over this position the
more tempted he'll be to bail out there
we go the problem is there were no
active ideas left and he was just
calculating there Maxi V gra that the
black king is quick enough to actually
make a dart for White's B Pawn if anyone
I would still take black I think it's
because of the healthy Pawn structure uh
we talk about Pawn Islands uh an easy
way to see who's got the healthier
position Maxim vasher lra four pawns on
the King side no weaknesses at all while
each of magnus's Pawn is a target for
black the only thing you need to watch
out for is this B passer so Maxim very
rightly just quickly rushes with the
King to stop any activity on the queen
side or that pawn becoming dangerous mhm
think he can get ambitious in this
position with black yeah look at the bar
I'm a bit surprised it looks like a dead
draw as soon as the black king tries to
make its way over towards the white B
Pawn uh White will give a check and
block its advance but actually it's
sneaking around the side maybe Magnus
has missed something he doesn't look too
happy this is where the clock really
will come into play uh no matter how
good you are in games no matter how
genius you are like Magnus Carson uh you
do start to get nervous when the
momentum turns and maybe this is what he
missed the king did his bit of a zigzag
it tried to go one way it was blocked by
the white Bishop then it went the other
way and it's coming towards that white
Pawn Magnus will go down a pawn this
might not end in a draw okay wow Magnus
is the one who has to be really careful
right now he's under a minute on the
clock and equal pawns so far but with a
with every single Pawn in White's
position being a weakness the king stuck
to defending that F2 Pawn can't really
get active meanwhile black you can
actually just Advance with your king
closer to that White Pond force it to
push up the board one more Square uh and
David yeah we I think we're going to see
this being played out B6 is the only way
now to fight losing a pawn but it
doesn't last long because black can then
come back one step with the King and
eventually win that pawn anyway yeah I
think we'll see this on the board Magnus
has nothing else to do you have to just
keep your porn alive one more turn at
least but under 30 seconds now about to
drop a por oh my gosh oh he's given up
second Pawn Magnus is just going all in
two pawns but he's going to be two pawns
down yeah what is this he's just I think
he's lost his head here a bit and pawn
takes porn here is as the computer says
a winning move there's actually two
winning moves they're both to do with
reacting to this Pawn push you either
take it or you bypass it pawn to E5 also
winning what's Magnus doing I don't
understand and both these moves are so
natural I would be so tempted to just go
E5 to create a passer but you can also
trade that F5 pawn and these are really
the only two moves you have in the
position so Maxim is just going to
choose one of the two and keep his big
Advantage who will it be enough to win
and those extra seconds on the clock so
critical for maxim right now yeah I've
got to say I think the second move might
be more natural pushing the pawn forward
uh just because you keep more pawns on
the board the one downside with taking
is that white king might zigzag in and
behind and start munching on some of
these black pawns so you have to
calculate here the computer says it's
winning after for example black just
takes the pawn hits the bishop and uh I
think you can just come back and defend
everything but okay it's on the board
he's going for the win here at F gra
he's got to be careful though he's got
to be careful because also watch out for
that H Pawn being the wrong color on H1
that's a light Square color Maxim has a
dark Square Bishop if white gives up the
bishop for two of Black's pawns and is
able to get his own King to that H1
Square it's a theoretical draw even if
black has an extra Bishop on the board
yeah and that's why he's found this
really clever move maybe the Clincher
Maxim VRA maybe what Magnus missed he's
defending this Pawn meaning the white
Bishop cannot give its life for two
black pawns uh as long as you keep one
of these two alive that issue never
exists and white has to go in simply has
to go behind and try to win right now
but Black's King is coming with gain of
time and as soon as the king moves the
black pawn will be free to run this is
going to be game over very
quickly what a start to the Grand Final
Maxim vajra with more time on the clock
it's looking so good for him and you can
see it on Magnus he looks a little bit
frustrated and he's going to have N9
seconds when it's time for him to
move what a start to the Grand Final you
guys what a crazy start with the black
pieces so close to a victory but Maxim
just has to keep his cool and his
composure I love what he's doing he
keeps the pawns defended and then just
slowly he's marching the king towards
not only White's H2 Pawn but assisting
this F Pawn he doesn't even care about
giving up that H Pawn because David uh I
think this F Pawn will decide the game
Maxi uh Magnus has to stop it from
advancing but now the king moves forward
and eventually Black's Bishop will block
out this diagonal King to E2 transfer
that Bishop to this diagonal and then
just start pushing well he does it
immediately Bishop e3 coming next this
is game over I think Magnus will just
resign yeah three seconds for Magnus
Carson he does make another move but his
Bishop will soon be kicked away off the
diagonal uh and the black pawn will
March through to Glory you can do this
in a few ways right now you can just
challenge this white Bishop there we go
it could not take the black Bishop the
black pawn would have promoted and now
just one or two more accurate moves
should sort this game out you can even
just take the white Pawn right now this
is just going to be game over you can
take the white Pawn you can also slide
all the way to D2 and he does it David I
think this is game over on the spot
because the bishop comes over to that E1
square and that's it Magnus resigns wow
Maxim vaj he takes makes the first point
in the Grand Final here in the AI cup no
reaction from the cool
Frenchmen but look at him oh wow what a
start to the Grand Final you guys he
takes the lead mvl he puts pressure on
Magnus to make a comeback I mean we were
talking about this is what MV has to do
he needs to strike in the beginning and
that's what he's just done Tanya what
can you say about his performance here
we were talking about it Maxim knows it
better than anyone that you have to
start early with Magnus you got to take
those opportunities when they come and
for me the Highlight was just
sacrificing that pawn out of the opening
for the initiative it was incremental
pressure after that David uh uh all the
whole game just an excellent play what
stood out to you yeah so many moments I
just want to highlight where Magnus
actually let things slip Maxim had been
turning things in his favor for a long
time first from an active opening middle
game into a slightly better end game and
remember remember not many people beat
Magnus Carson in the end game and it was
here that Magnus eventually went astray
this Pawn is dropping Magnus should have
just let it fall just retreated his
pieces and actually uh with just pawns
on one side of the board it is a draw
it's unpleasant to defend but it should
be holding instead Magnus went all in he
gambled giving up a second pawn and here
Maxim clinched it with this classy move
Bishop back to H4 holding on to this
pawn and uh if we fast forward the final
position Magnus resigned because next
move Bishop to E1 is simply coming and
this porn will push just beautiful
endgame technique play through it again
at home oh yeah definitely and this is
the action you get if you subscribe to
chess.com on Twitch you guys and don't
miss out on September through the end of
this month claim up to 30% off on all
new Subs on Twitch subscribers gain
access to exclusive Breaktime content
during broadcasts and score an adree
experience on chess.com so don't miss
out on the deals you guys on September
and uh wow game two in the the Grand
Final we'll start in a few minutes Maxim
vajra in the lead with the white pieces
we will be right back with
[Music]
that it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things anyone who has played even a
small amount of Chess especially online
is familiar with the concept of an
opening trap we've all fallen for one at
some point or another in many cases a
failed opening trap will leave you with
a terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number two legal mate this opening trap
if your opponent cooperates can lead to
one of the most beautiful and famous
checkmates in chess named after s deal
it dates back all the way to the 18th
century it occurs in an Italian game and
in this position we play Knight C3 black
might play Bishop G4 pinning the Knight
to White's Queen and we can play H3
forcing black to make a decision about
the light squared Bishop if they retreat
with Bishop H5 this allows the brilliant
Knight takes E5 where a free Queen is
offered if black takes the bait and
grabs the queen can you spot the famous
mate in
two that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the
[Music]
opening eating popcorn it's impossible
when the bowl is here right in front of
you and it smells so good as well and
okay you guys this is the AI cup and uh
we are teaming up with h for this
tournament chess.com is and we're super
excited about this partnership with the
browser maker Opera it is something for
chess lovers this uh browser chess
specified you can have chess basically
at your fingertips no matter where where
you are so download this uh new browser
by Oprah we need to talk some more about
what just happened what we have just
witnessed MBL taking the lead in The
Grand Final against the amazing Magnus
Carlson that means right the mvl must
have played some amazing chess in this
first game what what happened here
T I'm still thinking about it I've never
seen this happen before where Magnus
Carlson in any match format has lost the
first game with the white pieces uh
Maxim has done what I think many would
consider just impossible at the very
start of the game get this momentum
going take the early lead in the match
and the thing is right now it feels like
we have a real match on our hands cuz at
the start you think think okay how do
you beat Magnus not once but you have to
do it twice how do you do it when you
get this win in with the black pieces
you know that it's possible it's within
your reach and uh Maxim not only
tactically very sharp but taking some
really key strategic decisions and
showing extremely good technique in the
end game so an overall excellently
played game I would love to see the
accuracy of this one ooh yeah do we know
that actually um we can check that but I
just want to mention we me we kind of
discussed before the show Magnus does
start slow sometimes you have to catch
him cold and that's exactly what he did
when Magnus is happy to play for a draw
he's nearly impossible to beat so you
have to take the lead in a match that's
the only way pretty much to beat him and
now Magnus will have to take risks to
strike back but uh Magnus was
uncharacteristic in that game he could
have actually forced a draw I was just
playing through he could have pretty
much forced a draw in a very simple way
at the beginning of the end game but he
took a risk and Maxim immediately
punished him um it was just a bit of a
strange one definitely feels like Maxim
has started hotter here he started
faster fresher sharper and uh he
deserves the lead so so what's going
through magnus's head now he didn't seem
very happy obviously with losing but
just throughout that game didn't seem
that comfortable maybe I think it's
about getting into the Rhythm and again
we keep saying this right even
throughout the tour the first game is
always a little shaky but you never see
him actually losing and we are getting
an update on the accuracy of the players
almost 92% from Magnus gson and 98% for
Max
incredible 98% you have to play a
perfect chess to take down Magnus and
that's what Maxim did but coming to the
point that David was making about this
uncharacteristic play in the end game I
also think that it's a lot to do with
how Maxim handled the opening and the
mid game because at this level it's
never a one move mistake or a one move
blunder right it's always incremental
it's always incremental pressure and
Magnus for the most part was forced to
find good moves pretty much out of the
opening once he did grabb the pawn uh
and you you know you know you can
sometimes do it once you can do it twice
but to do it to find 10 15 good moves in
a row can be difficult even for the
world number one yeah definitely wow he
has taken the lead Maxim Vash and he did
it with the black pieces in game two
starting in a few minutes he's going to
have the white pieces so let's get to
know mbl's uh opening
[Music]
strategies and mvl Maxim bash lra or as
his fans call him the Frenchman with
three names mvl is one of the best
players in the world he has been for the
past decade a former World Blitz
Champion mvl is especially known for
playing quick tricky and precise chess
mvl has a degree in mathematics and this
really shines through when it comes to
calculation in chess you do not want to
get him in a forcing sequence where he
can work it out till the very end the
following position
really demonstrates the strength of
Maxim Vash lra in this position as Black
coming this way he found a killer
sequence actually Checkmate in five
moves this began with a night sacrifice
the most accurate way the most precise
way first taking a pawn checking the
white king and forcing white
recapture to show off his calculation
skills he had now worked out that Queen
takes Pawn was the final blow with a key
fact being that if the white king moves
forward to any Square then the queen
drops back with a
Checkmate instead the white Bishop threw
itself in the way to block black took
this pawn and after the king moved
forward he spotted this check here
Jeffrey Jong resigned because no matter
what white does black gives Checkmate on
the next move the white king is trapped
Maxim calculated this five move
variation and won a really impressive
game bashra is quick tricky and has a
rock solid opening repertoire his
opponents better watch out out and if
they want to have any chance of beating
him they have to avoid these
strengths so that's what Magnus Carlson
can expect when he now plays with the
black pieces fighting for a comeback MV
with the white pieces he's had some
great results in his career but this
would mean a whole lot to Maxim vajra if
he wins the AI cup after a few years
with uh some trouble he's not only
fighting to win the grand final he he's
also fighting to qualify for Toronto
Maxim bajra he has to win the Grand
Final to do that and if he doesn't
there's a chance for fedos to make it to
Toronto he will have to win division 2
and he has taken the lead in that Grand
Final against EMV We are following that
as well but now we are getting ready for
game two Magnus Carlson now with the
black pieces he is down by a p Point mvl
took uh game one and now with the white
pieces always seem so calm the Frenchman
but uh you think he's feeling excited
now Tanya I think he believes now that
it is possible to do it today to make
this happen uh but Magnus Carlson just
gets so much more dangerous when his
back is against the wall uh it's uh not
it's still far far from over uh and we
see Magnus with an opening approach
where it implies that he wants to just
stop the bleeding he's gone for the
Berlin yeah the most solid opening in
chess Rock Solid here known for it
drawish Tendencies and we do see a very
very level uh position here with
symmetrical Pawn structure white
slightly ahead in development so white
has a small Edge often especially if you
can keep pieces on the board but uh
definitely feels like a case of Magnus
just trying to get on the scoreboard
trying to stop the bleeding trying to
get a result with black and vas gra not
taking too much risk here in the early
stages with white Vash gra I will
mention has been known throughout his
career as the Berlin Slayer uh he's
often gone into the Berlin game and won
countless victories against the world's
top players but here going for something
slightly more uh full of life Tanya uh
do you like the fact he's kept pieces on
the board rather than uh go into that
end game I do I like the fact that the
Queens are on the board in this Berlin
and we have none of that Berlin
repetition stuff that we see uh quite
often actually in the past in the
Champions Chester which actually means
that Maxim with the white pieces wants
to keep the game alive I don't expect
him to take very risky decisions in this
one but if the opportunity was to come
uh we might just see his intuition and
his natural style of play coming in so I
do like that we don't have the end game
yet but still a very solid position and
why is Magnus uh thinking after this
small pawn move on the king side it is
very strange I must say Magnus again
could and should have predicted this
exact position uh still very well-known
Theory and uh especially with Vash de
gra who is quite predictable in the
opening uh you could have pinpointed
this and you could have said okay I know
where I'm going to put my pieces I know
how I'm going to develop I know how I'm
going to uh end all of White's potential
pressure but Magnus feels like that rest
day it's really caught him cold and okay
he just needs to unravel his pieces here
the more pieces you take off as black
the safer you get due to the symmetrical
Pawn structure due to uh the safe nature
uh of this type of position but feels
like he's trying to Freestyle Maxim I
would recommend trying to keep going try
to build the momentum strike while the
iron I do feel if the next game is drawn
I mean this game maybe the next one
nerves will kick in the stakes will be
so high and if it's just a one game
shoot out that's when uh you start to
get affected I think he needs to
continue trying to catch Magnus while
clearly he's uh not in the flow right
now that's really interesting because
you're up a point against Magnus uh and
many would just think okay take a solid
approach take a safe approach but David
I think you're absolutely right that
when you're playing against Magnus
Carlson any opportunity you get you have
to take it the next game Magnus will be
white and he will come out all guns
blazing uh so in this one to not let
Magnus just feel safe to get into that
safety zone that safety net uh I think
it's it's quite key so for maxim if he
gets the chance in a burlin but where do
you get your chances in this kind of a
position is just a symmetrical Pawn
structure on the king's side on the
Queen's side it's just about a fight for
the e-line usually in this uh opening
the only file that's open and uh it's
about the side that's able to get full
control of that yeah right now that is
white White's Rook nicely placed on that
open E file and uh there's other small
advantages that you can hope for um just
to show a quick outline of the ideas
here for both sides white does have a
small edge here traditionally
symbolically at least uh due to this
Pawn dominating the Black Knight the
Black Knight here is actually very
misplaced uh it's in the way of a black
pawn which wants to use this square and
uh therefore this Pawn in the center
slightly vulnerable uh meanwhile we see
Maxim Vash gra bring his Bishop to the
center Magnus going for exactly what you
said Tanya fighting for this e line here
trying to trade Rooks off the board uh
trying to take pieces off I'm expecting
them to disappear these Rooks I'm not
sure on Whose terms for example uh let's
say they go and then white will activate
these pieces there's two ways to do this
either White's Knight takes the long way
round goes up back and into the center
or you can push a pawn and bring the
Knight round and try to creep it up
around the side of the board uh either
way these are still well-known plans and
both players just taking a bit of time
trying to make maybe think what's most
testing for their opponents still no
forcing Lines no big tactics uh but it's
all about maneuvering right now mhm do
you think it's important for Magnus to
make an immediate comeback after that
first loss or do you think he's able to
keep his calm maybe wait for game three
with a white pieces again I think you're
right Ka that's his strategy his
strategy with the Berlin and not going
for a sicilian a more Dynamic opening is
that uh I just want this one to stop get
your mind get your flow going and then
with the white pieces uh to strike so
that's what I would say that he's hoping
for yeah I think his opening Choice has
revealed his strategy uh sometimes you
want to keep your opponent guessing you
play a flexible opening and then keep
retain some chances of a Counterattack
but no he's just saying let's get out
this game let's move on and that's not
very Magnus Carlson esque but that's the
way he's chosen to play this one and I
understand it because he is facing an
inform opponent and Vash de gra is his
kind of uh he's famous for his white
wins just his white repertoire I think
uh almost uh incomparable uh in World
Chess right now yeah we have seen I mean
when you play too much for a draw it
does give the other player some
opportunities does just give mvl some
chances to to go all out in this game
maybe later yeah yeah still early days
uh but it will be a sign of weakness uh
well I say weakness it's a sign of what
you want and once your opponent knows as
you say k once you know your opponent's
playing for a draw you take a bit more
risk you you kind of bully them in
they'll take passive decisions I'm not
sure you can do that against Magnus
because he's very in the moment he's
very spontaneous on the chard uh he can
react if your if your opponent attacks
you you can he will find ways to kind of
Slither out and uh he always has a win
uh in his mind and that's a great point
you make uh and it will come down to
this inner game right because you're up
in the match you've got this extra point
uh how much risk are you willing to take
against a player like Magnus uh knowing
that you can play safe and keep
everything under control and going one
game closer to that Finish Line without
things going too wrong so for maxim
again uh it will be a psychological
battle but it does look like uh he still
wants to keep the game going uh you know
what I just again saying what I did
earlier that I don't expect him to go
extra aggressive in this one to take
unnecessary action and I think it's
really hard in these kind of positions
and in these kind of openings but he's
going to keep the game going
and again the moral Victory will come in
if he can end this on his terms or even
if it's a draw that let Magnus fight and
earn that draw yeah Magnus is currently
trying to fight to earn that draw he's
traded off the light squared Bishops
that tends to favor Black uh because if
you compare the remaining Bishops on the
board White's Bishop potentially will be
stuck behind his own Central Pawn Mass
Black's Bishop looks pretty nice
controlling both flanks now magna's also
offering a queen trade I think if Maxim
takes the Queens off it's going to be
close to zero chance of grinding that
one out to a victory I think we will see
a draw uh and look at Maxim he's not
even calculating right now he's going
for it's a moral debate do you play for
the draw or do you keep Queens on and
try to win oh Mind Games I I think he's
going to trade it I I think he's going
to trade the queens and I that's just
looking at Maxim oh it's on the board he
goes for it but I was going to say
imagine going two Z up against Magnus
that would be incredible for maxim and I
bet he was saying that to himself as
well but then well
yeah too much focused on the result it's
natural it's a very human trait we've
all been there when uh we know a draw is
enough or you're playing a higher rated
player or if you're in the lead in the
tournament and you think okay let's just
take it easy this once U but will that
come back to Haun him I don't like that
decision I think he could have kept the
Queens on still with minimal risk and
still with the very very decent chances
of pushing for an advantage now we will
see most likely both Rooks enter the E
file the E Line and trade off for each
other we'll see kn disappear off the
board there's just no porn breaks no
open Lines no weaknesses in each sides
camps dead level this is uh the epitome
of an equal position mhm yeah we might
even see a draw off really soon or all
pieces will trade off into a p King Pawn
ending symmetrical Pawn structure really
nothing to fight for that last decision
by Maxim definitely implies that he's
getting ready for game three yeah and
his task in game three with the black
pieces will again be to make sure that
Magnus doesn't get his chances with
white Magnus Carlson has given even one
chance that it's pretty much game over
for you and if if they do sort of decide
that they want to go for a draw now
quite soon how will that actually work
with many pieces left on the board what
will they actually do to will someone
offer that draw or will they do some
repetition yeah I just thinking about it
this season on the Champions chest T
draw offers have been few and far
between they've been very rare actually
I think again it's just neither player
wants to show weakness uh or kind of
blink first they never want to be the
one offering a draw uh here I think K it
would happen for example let's say the
white king moves and the line it's
standing on right now the E file White's
Rook will occupy that and because it's
such a nice line Black's Rook will
challenge we'll see the Rooks disappear
once Rooks disappear if it's just minor
pieces on the board just Knights and
Bishops there's really no weaknesses to
look at and I think we'll see a few
Knight trades maybe the Bishops are the
hardest pieces to trade off right now uh
but if it's just Bishops and pawns left
at the end then it will be deadlocked
we'll see the players just go back and
forth and repeat so that's what I'm
expecting uh but then again I would
maybe choose black I would maybe choose
magnus's position okay uh just because
it's easier to push pawns on the king
side uh around the black king you can
throw those pawns forward gain a bit of
space there I've seen stranger things
happen I've seen Magnus he quite enjoys
these positions that's another reason I
would have kept the Queens on the board
uh just because you know the opponents
Magnus lost the last end game but this
one's a very different one it's a very
slow maneuvering grind type of position
and we know who the best player in the
world is there who knows how to grind
like a
grandmas he does
but David I you know the more I look at
it I I think I think you're right uh
Magnus might actually be the one who
might be thinking are there ways that he
can create some chances because he's got
easier play with his Knight and the
pawns on the king side also notice how
that F4 Square can become a Target the
F5 Square for the Knight to jump on with
a check uh I wonder if he's at all
getting ambitious here but the moment I
say that I also feel where where you
actually end up hitting a White's
position here he does start pushing the
pawn so maybe Magnus is looking at a
long game and it might be Maximo might
have to earn that draw now we call it
the tickle when you're not really doing
much you're just kind of teasing your
opponent you're saying okay I'm going to
push my pawns you decide how to react
you decide how to fix the structure and
then your opponent Burns a bit of time
there if they fix the pawn structure in
a bad way sometimes you can take
advantage if they find the right way
okay then it's a draw and the tickle
ends but you just uh yeah you just
maneuver it around keep the game going
forever frustrate your opponent and also
when you have the white pieces you have
this moral obligation to play for a win
as soon as you take the Queens off and
start playing for a draw which Vash gra
is clearly trying to do right now
suddenly the mentality switches and uh
kind of you can assert your dominance
slightly over your opponent I don't
expect this one to be anything dramatic
but already Maxim's playing some
slightly strange moves yeah putting his
Rook on its starting Square the starting
square of the other Rook kind of going
all the way across the board uh but it's
on a locked up file right now he's just
hoping Magnus continues advancing I
don't think Magnus was intending to do
that anyway so I would say a bit of a
wasted move there from Vash grav now
Magnus will start improving the Black
Knight maybe the black Rook but is that
tickling then by MV or even like a
little bit like flirting no you show me
what you want no you show me what you
want exactly that's pieces right now
that's pretty much what they're doing
yeah and uh I would say Magnus is the
one doing the tickling and mag Maxim is
not reacting in the best way uh he's
kind of sitting there just letting his
opponent to do this right now H there's
no way to force the issue there's no way
to force the draw and that's a bit
uncomfortable psychologically strange
moment in this match then we're just
waiting for something to happen or to
get inside their heads then I guess
right now it's not really easy I guess
to to understand especially what's going
on in magnus's head yeah Magnus he's
going to be feeling ambitious and this
last move is provocation uh I was a bit
surprised by this it looks like he's
trying to ask Maxim to come forward now
with some of his porns and
the most obvious move in the position to
me would be to attack this Knight Magnus
is saying please come forward this is
the tickle he's like tickling he's like
please react strike me back and uh right
now what would happen if the pawn
pushes I think the point is that you
don't want to take on G4 because then
suddenly the H1 Rook makes a lot of
sense you're on exactly the square that
you want to be uh what Magnus has done
is exactly that it's a provocation you
go G4 you provoke the weaknesses and
then you simply come back with the
knight uh the point is yes you can go to
G7 but maybe even to E7 and I was eyeing
the F4 square at some Far Away distant
future to land my knight on and I'm also
hoping that you actually grab on H5 so
that then my Rook can slide all the way
to h8 and this one's a far more active
move than the one that Maxim made once I
take on H5 H3 is weak as well uh so
Knight to F5 I think G4 is EXA is
exactly what Magnus is hoping for and
maxim of course doesn't go for it yeah
and retreating the night you mentioned
passive uh it's really really not a
pleasant move to play the idea is to
come round and then into the center to
challenge the Black Knight very logical
plan if the knights both disappear then
it will be a dead draw but white white
is really really kind of crawling right
now really not pleasant and black at the
moment has the better Knight has the
better Pawn structure and Magnus does
have the luxury of two moves before
black uh before his opponent finishes
that plan these last few moves that
Maxim has made it almost feels like the
the path to draw is just getting
narrower and narrower he needs to be
more and more precise and more concrete
with his defense in a position where it
felt like concreteness would not be the
name of the game but now he has to find
ways of exactly neutralizing Black's
pressure of trading pieces as quickly as
possible uh Rook to H1 Knight to E1
these strange looking moves gets you the
feeling that something's gone wrong do
you think Maxim's feeling that as well
or or for him everything's still under
control and he's confident of it yeah he
doesn't as energetic or as optimistic as
focused as he was in the past game uh in
the previous game Maxim barely even
blinked he was just sitting there stoic
and uh he took advantage of his chances
as soon as soon as they came here it
feels like he's a bit uncomfortable he's
been moving back and forth in his chair
changing his posture a bit and these
small giveaways they're not much but
they do really signore his mindset um I
think he would just love to get out of
this game with a draw if Magnus answered
Maxim would click yes please draw
immediately and uh yeah it's it's just
really tense but uh Magnus enjoying the
tension a bit more yeah everyone is
tickled by the tension in this game I
completely agree with you there it's h
it really feels tense right now it feels
like I mean this could potentially be
very decisive right in the match Magnus
making a comeback or not making a
comeback and I I think Maxim is perhaps
regretting that Queen trade decision
that he took because that's the moment
that he really gave the chances to
Magnus to feel safe and to be the one
who starts pushing and in any end game
where Magnus feels he even has the
slightest opportunity the slightest
chance which many can't even see can't
even fathom but for Magnus it's about
playing it out then and this is that
kind of position right now he's gone
into a bit of think uh and I think that
has something to do with him deciding
whether how does he improve this
position whether he pushes those pawns
further clamping down on White's King
side but those are committal decisions
do you go without H Pawn to H4 uh and
then maybe even at some point go Rook to
G8 and open up the G line to create some
weaknesses or do you keep things more
flexible in this position and improve
your Rook already he takes another Pawn
decision he first makes sure that
everything is defended on uh the queen
side because it's just harder as white
to make moves than it is for black hair
yeah it's much harder for white right
now we're expecting wow Maxim Vash
yawning maybe that reflects his views on
the position and uh the move Knight to
C2 coming round is indeed played part of
the plan initiated by his previous move
and Magnus now instantly reacts again
provocation forcing a reaction from
these pawns and maybe forcing a weakness
now which way will Magnus drop uh back
his Knight or will he come into the
position there is a bit of a hole right
now and if you jump in maybe the one
issue is this Knight will get traded uh
either White's Knight will come back or
uh maybe first moving the bishop next
he'll trade off these Knights by four so
the Knight drops back from Magnus and
this offer of a trade allowed but on his
terms this is really instructive note
how a knight trade offered here black
does not take because this would only
give white time first he says okay you
can take me but look how active the
black king is going to be and still I
feel this should be a draw but uh
Black's King now clearly Superior than
the white king more active at least
Black's Bishop can look at both sides of
the board White's Bishop stuck behind
its own Pawns in the center and Black's
Rook potentially much more flexible to
come to any of these squares that you
mentioned earlier Tanya still a small
Advantage but I think The Disappearance
of the knights will give Maxim a bit of
Hope s of relief there how often is it
when Magnus is playing and we say this
should be a draw but it isn't in the end
so he does make that magic happen and it
does feel as if black has made a lot of
progress in the position in the last few
moves the King has become more active
the black pawns have moved forward
gaining more space uh threatening
further pawn moves ahead meanwhile white
has been struggling to get pieces off
the board and has managed to to do it
but then again David as you said on
Black's terms making sure that the black
king gets to activity on F5 uh and
knowing Magnus Carlson he sees that as
progress he sees that as something to
fight for Beyond but how do you what are
the plans in which he can look at
actually improving this position further
let's say the knights were to come off
and your king does land on F5 and we see
that being played out what because if
Rooks come off David I think it would be
easier for white to hold this position
then yeah dead draw if the Rooks ever
come off if the bishops come off
likewise should be a dead draw I like
what Maxine's done he's taking the open
file he's saying okay if the black Rook
ever goes away I'll come in if the black
king ever moves back I'll come in uh
Magnus meanwhile shifts his Rook to the
other side of the board uh again the
tickle continues will he push this Pawn
will he push this Pawn uh just teasing
and now Maxim saying okay I'm not going
to commit but I might push this Pawn
they're kind of playing a guessing game
right now white might push on the queen
side black might push on the king side I
think ultimately none of these plans are
too scary if black pushes right now
white will have happily lock up this
side of the board notice how you never
ever want to trade here and allow your
opponent's pieces activity uh so you
just block the structure lock the
structure and end the opponent's winning
chances Magnus meanwhile trying to lock
the other side of the board trying to
clamp down and uh at least deter white
from pushing I'm slightly surprised it
looks like white can push anyway but at
least asking questions H
yeah yeah go on K I was just going to
say that I'd love to push C4 right now
uh try to create some weakness is on the
king side uh if you trade everything on
C4 white king gets Super
Active but yeah we'll see what M Maxim
decides I was going to say that they're
definitely keeping the tension and uh
while they do uh you guys remember to
take a picture of how you are watching
the Grand Final maybe it's a selfie and
share it on Twitter using the hash chess
champs for a chance to win this air
things wave mini we are enjoying this
day so much here in the studio watching
the best chess players in the world and
we hope you guys are as well we are
enjoying watching it with you guys and
we want to see your pictures so please
share them for a chance to win that air
things okay so moves is that tension
going away anytime soon slightly less
tense now after this trade of Pawns any
trade any pieces pawns disappearing uh
means that the tension is abating
slightly but I'm very very surprised
Tanya that Vash gra has allowed blacks
Rook an open file you did not need to do
this you didn't need to rush to do this
you could have done it in maybe uh more
favorable ways and now maybe Invasion
From the Black grp threatened I agree
with you and whoa what oh my gosh I love
it David but I was just going to say
before we Deep dive into this last move
that A4 it just reminds me of their last
match where A4 turned out to be a big
mistake by Maxim vasher lra you're right
gives the B file but the actions moved
over to the king side it looks like a
pawn sacrifice but it's a temporary one
uh if Magnus was to take on G4 and I
think we're seeing this line being play
play that The Rook can jump to E6 now
hitting the bishop and eventually
winning one of the two uh one of the
pawns back here and uh it's all about
the point you made the more pawns that
come off the easier it gets for white to
hold this position so G4 a very concrete
direct way to do that yeah now Maxim has
to be a bit careful though I'm really
shocked he rushed into this because look
how active the black king is there's a
clear Target now black is temporarily
upon por up and I think the one thing
you maybe shouldn't rush to do is trade
off these Bishops he doesn't go for this
because now the black king has somewhere
nice and safe to hide in front of its
own pawn and this one is ripe for
picking off next move instead he keeps
the tension between the Bishops this one
despite the evaluation baring level I
think we might see some twists and turns
ahead suddenly because Black's King is
coming in the black Rook is coming in
white meanwhile has some counterplay
against this Pawn all three results
possible Magnus quickly defending and uh
he might even go after this loose Pawn
on the flank
here I would not like like to be Maxi
Vash gra right now it feels like it's
all about the activity of Black's pieces
this is classic Magnus Carson I've seen
him win countless games in this type of
scenario oh wow and Maxim's got to be
feeling the pressure now because again
he needs to be really precise because of
all these dynamics that uh David just
pointed out but I do like what Maxim's
done he's forced Black's Rook into the
corner of the board and to activate that
there will be more Pawn trades what
Maxim is relying on is that once uh
black does take that pawn on A5 you'll
pick up that pawn on C6 eventually a C4
break and create your own counter
chances with a dwn being the passer up
the board uh and uh all of that might
very well happen because Magnus needs to
activate that Rook by capturing on A5
yeah but uh how does white wait it's
pretty much white waiting for black to
move and maybe we can pull up the
computer suggestions just before we uh
uh drop the board here to see how narrow
is the margin is white keeping the
balance with lots of different moves yes
is the answer still a draw but uh okay
dropping back with the king I would say
not 100% obvious the idea is to stop the
black king coming in actually the more I
look at it the more I like that one very
human sto the opponent's plan but
trading off also fine maybe then follow
by the king dropping back and the last
move I would say that this is never ever
going to happen Pawn to C4 it looks like
it simply blinds as a pawn pawn takes
Pawn you cannot take back because then
your Bishop would fall so the third move
on that list never ever but it's
interesting you say that because for me
that is the most natural idea but after
trading on F4 so that I don't end up
losing the pawn but I want to get as
many pawns off the board as possible so
what I'm looking at is the possibility
to actually get the Bishops off the
board first and then go C4 David does
that work this makes a lot more sense
from a human point of view uh not
allowing any nastiness uh now after Pawn
takes Pawn you can happily capture back
with your king and this game should
fizzle out all the pawns will disappear
black can take a pawn white can take a
pawn black can come in uh White will
start pushing and eventually both sides
will have pass pawns I think it just
will end up with King versus King uh if
this happens so Maxim he's doing the
right thing finally he's calculating and
and I think he's going to go okay he
drops back and slightly more passive
than your approach Tanya but probably
just as effective black is a bit
stalemated with his Rook pretty much
have to take a pawn to get the black
Rook active and that will lead to
similar lines that we just showed the
only reason that I was hesitant about
this was because it gives black the
opportunity to come in with the Rook
with a check you take on A5 and then you
drop down with your Rook to the second
rank driving the king away but I think
this is key this is really important
first you do into Mezo driving Black's
King away so that the white King has
another more active spot when Magnus
does give a check on A2 so Rook G6 was
precise there yeah and uh the previous
comment here on the twitch chat Maxim is
a genius I agree the way he's played
this I mean only he can play chess like
this where he forces the issue so
violently yet it still always works out
uh often kind of sensing that moment
when you initiate the play especially
against the top players in the world
it's so so tough but he does it so
naturally calculation is such a big
strength for all these players who are
the very best in the world but it all
comes down to the small difference of
speed how quickly are you able to
calculate precisely and Maxim is just
really up there when it comes to the
combination of these two yeah when he
pushed that a pawn forward you mentioned
a really committal decision uh what was
that move uh that was about 10 moves ago
I pretty sure he had a position like
this in his mind just he saw that he
would force the pawns off the board
maybe Bishops off the board
and he knew the end game was likely
holdable likely drawn Magnus now
threatening a check not sure how much of
a threat that is but yeah the game of
tickle continues a few checks here and
there eventually all the pawns will
disappear and I think you can see on Max
magnus's body language right now he's
resigned to the fact that this is likely
going to fizzle out yeah he pushed he
tried his best in this one when he got
the chances uh he kept the game alive
but Maxim not only really good today on
converting a better position but also
holding a difficult one and he must be
very happy if this ends with a draw
because actually that means game three
could be decisive if he wins that game
we're going to head straight into the
Grand Final reset Magnus Carlson he
cannot lose game three if this one ends
in a draw that's going to be intense
yeah it's going to be intense it's a
very different type of match so far
though uh Tanya compared to two days ago
when they first faced where it was just
fire on the board opposite side castling
Mutual attacks Mutual races here it
feels like the first game was decided in
that end game here it's another grindy
position uh do you think that's a
conscious decision from the players or
just because it is such high stakes I I
completely agree with you the first one
was so felt so much more random on the
board just 10 moves into the game and
we'd never seen a position like that in
every game in their first match but this
one feels like a more strategic fight uh
yeah I think you're right that it's more
controlled by Magnus but David I'm just
wondering if in the next one given the
matth situation we might just see
another I think Magnus might just decide
to start with the King spawn opening we
would love that another wild battle just
like we saw two days ago it might be
incoming this might be the Cal before
the storm uh we might need that bowl of
popcorn yet again in the next game it's
not going to stay there for very long
David I'm constantly eating can't blame
you yeah and uh meanwhile a porn drops
second porn can fall though white can go
hunting uh right now it's level material
but that f porn looks ripe just go for
it why not attack that I think Magnus is
basing all of his counterplay ideas on
running with his a pawn forward the P
Pawn Yeah the move that you're talking
about with the Rook you could either do
a sideway attack or go to E4 and just
win the F4 Pawn he goes with a rook to
F5 Magnus can start with some checks
along the second and the first Rank and
the a pawn is pushing that is the
counter play it does feel like it should
be enough against these separated bonds
uh if they were connected it would be a
totally different game yeah and if
White's King were more centralized more
active it would be a totally different
game the white king is cut off on the
back rank okay I think Maxim with this
last move indicates he's going to be
happy with the draw here white king
slowly inching its way towards that
black poror the only dangerous uh factor
in the position this will neutralize
that White's King will blockade the
black pawn Black's King will blockade
the white pawns and uh Black's Rook
eventually will help to uh trade
everything off yeah and so so how will
this game end will this be move
repetition King versus King I what
happened draw offer okay fash gra offers
a draw Magnus accepts and just like that
we have a result maim was like I'm done
with this tickling this is a draw Magnus
let's just finish it and look at him so
calm he is still in the lead Maxim vaj
after two games here in the grand final
game three he will have the black pieces
again and if he wins that game we are
heading straight to the Grand Final
reset to the side the winner Magnus
cannot lose the next game but this game
I mean you guys you guys were saying the
Berlin you guys were saying it was Jo
from the start Magnus did seem to have
some ambition though yeah Magnus was
working his magic doing Magnus things
just grinding away looking for Avenues
into the white position and actually
here as black I would have been getting
ambitious I would have been getting a
bit excited I think Magnus in his mind
thinking okay I can come in the black
King's really active but this is where
Maxim Vash gra is so strong is so genius
he out of the blue he sacrificed a porn
just like he did in the first game
giving up this Pawn luring the black
king away from the defense of this E6
square and suddenly for the first time
in this game white got active White's
Rook started munching on pawns and as we
saw later The Disappearance of Bishops
marked a drawn end
game all right uh it's heating up you
guys game three is uh coming up uh
shortly we want to remind you guys there
is something else very cool going on the
very cool Chief CHF chess officer Danny
rench is taking on the entire world
actually in a chess game and you can
join our team to take him down Danny has
made his first move that was one E4 and
how should we respond you can head over
to go chess.com playay Danny or use play
Danny here in the chat to make your Mo
what move would you make Tanya I was
just thinking uh I think ad Dan's gone
with the King spawn opening E4 David my
pick is C5 what about you okay I rarely
play C5 but I'll I'll say C6 just to
spice things up K break the tie I'll
I'll go with I like your C6 I like it I
like it and you guys make your move uh
as well now what moves will be made in
game three it's uh going to be Magnus
Carlson with the white pieces and he
cannot lose it that game is coming up
shortly after a
[Music]
break
to
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved chess.com
game review is just a click away game
review is a fast fun and instructive
guided review of your games see your
accuracy and your opponent's accuracy
check out the eval graph for an instant
overview and scroll down to see how many
great moves best moves blunders and yes
brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play with
retry mistakes you can get another shot
at finding missed opportunities try game
review today on web iOS or
Android ah we need popcorn today because
uh it's entertainment in the Champions
chest St Grand Final in the AI cup and I
want to challenge you guys first one to
be able to throw up the popcorn and grab
it with
oh two times in a row can he
keep oh my gosh oh close T close oh
yeah ah it's a day for popcorn you guys
and uh you're going to need the popcorn
right now because we have something fun
coming up we're going to see what went
down when David and Magnus played mini
golf did you enjoy that dat David I did
more than I thought I would I'm a less
exper experien golfer Magnus is a bit of
a pro uh relatively and yeah it was uh
memorable as people will find out all
right we we just have to go there let's
see what happened when David challenged
Magnus who is now a golf player recently
started playing the game uh but what
happened when David challenged him in
mini golf we all know Magnus can beat me
at chess but can he beat me at golf
we're going to find out who the better
putter
us wait a sec I okay H cheating cheating
oh that was horrible now this is very
hard
oh that's terrible hit it as hard as I
can oh wow that was bad no that's okay I
think oh my
God okay wo hole in three yeah boys all
level so
far really what the am I doing here
oh
wow look at this
amateur a I'm going to channel that
famous golfer David Howell he's actually
a real person
[Music]
okay if I don't get this I should retire
oh that was okay this one is
hard oh that's a terrible Miss I can get
it there and then
through
four
okay oh
dear oh wow no
no I did not realize it could even go
off the edge there yeah that's pretty
bad oh that's not one yeah that's one
that's another
one okay let's say you're on like I'm on
like five five that was my fourth day
yeah fourth okay now it's
five oh yes
boys oh it's gone somewhere down there
where on Earth is this
one there the ball it came down this
thing so it's where's the bottom of
this I think it's supposed to come down
here actually
through yeah okay but that's that
just let's get it
yes
[Music]
woo
nice that was not
[Music]
great didn't prepare my
shot okay so now it's even we're level
oh my God I just have to
try Oh
that's oh is this the right that's not I
no that's
not three you're two ahead yeah so this
is just one yeah it's all in one or
nothing so basically if you make it and
I don't you win otherwise I win oh my
God good luck how on Earth am I going to
there just a massive red light down this
is pretty T I think I have to hit it a
little bit to the right no that's the
wrong way okay for all the glory David
okay one shot it's all been leading up
to this moment my career it's my one
shot my one opportunity to seize nothing
I Ever Wanted okay which way round is
the golf club going how am I supposed to
do this though but there's a massive
thing in the way so we have to go round
ready let's do
this yes
wow
oh my god wow crowning
[Applause]
Glory it's all in the name David H
famous golfer I think I've played this
course twice before really none of the
guys have ever made this
one I can't believe it the grinder he
always makes the come back David Howell
wins the match never underestimate a
grinder we always pull it out when we
really need to but H I don't think it
can get better than that how do I top
that thing and the thing is the thing is
so this is only mini golf but you you
mean it when you celebrate there you
just I don't know anyone who loves
winning more than you do it's a chess
player thing Winning is Everything no
matter how sneak you are dirty about it
like uh winning it's all about the
result we've seen it with the go-karting
the mini golf we all want to win don't
we T So competitive yeah I've seen it
even it was in this mini golf when you
guys were racing at some point Magness
just get so competitive with each other
yeah yeah all right well it's all about
becoming competitive now for Magnus
Carlson he needs to make a comeback in
the match against Maxim vaj if he loses
this game three it's going to be over we
are going to head to the Grand Final
reset MBL will win this first match in
the grand final if he wins this game
three Magnus KY needs at least a draw
and he has to make a comeback at some
point here uh this could be the game he
will have the white pieces snacking on
something right now Magnus to get his
energy levels up and to get that win he
needs what should we expect then Tanya
for oh 1 D4 he goes for the same recipe
the first game it was exactly the
Queen's gamb but accepted but it's
Magnus who switches it up with a more
attacking approach uh with the move that
we just saw on the board yeah much more
ambitious approach here Magnus Carson he
seizes the center black is still a porn
up but look at all of that tension we
talked about tickling in the last game
this is not tickling this is just brute
force in the middle of the board and uh
it is Maxim to think first this is still
well known I'm expecting Black's
kingside Knight to develop right now um
but there are solid ways to play this
depending on how Maxim is feeling
depending on his mood his preparation of
course uh Magnus with going with the
golf analogy this is more a hole in one
attempt you're going really direct uh
straight for Glory none of this kind of
slow maneuvering none of the end games
that we've seen in the previous battle
for example um this is much more
aggressive chess and Tanya shaping up
nicely but he needs to at least get on
par because a bogey would mean that
Maxim V lra can potentially take this in
game three and this kind of an opening
is one for all three results oh this has
gone crazy from the start yeah this has
gone crazy from the start and this was
popularized by uh madjarov with the with
the black pieces yordan van forest with
the black pieces and very aggressive
players and that's why I think Magnus
has chose this uh it's now level
material he's won his Pawn back in the
center White's porn structure is
beautiful strategically long-term white
is just winning but white is also behind
the development giving black some
chances Maxim leaning back looking
confident um this last move Magnus just
trying to solidify his Pawn Center and
black has to strike quick remember white
doing well longterm therefore Dynamics
shortterm energy required from black
yeah I'm expecting uh that c Pawn to
move up the board at some point I'm not
really sure how you actually set that up
but like you said that black needs to
strike quick uh to neutralize this Pawn
Center that Magnus has managed to get
out of the opening C5 would be a break
that I would be looking for with the
black pieces in this one it also seems
like the kind of opening where you
really need to know what you're doing
mhm because uh it's just s such an
attacking position in watch the first 10
moves yeah and uh for Maxi Vash legra
slightly concerning that he doesn't
immediately recall what he should be
doing here as far as I remember this
last move for white maybe not the most
popular um so it did take him a little
time to adjust and eventually Retreats
this Knight makes a lot of sense
eliminating White's powerful piece in
the center of the board we'll see a
trade of knights in the next turn and uh
okay Magnus is the first to pause looks
logical to me notice how Maxim just for
a few seconds he of had his head in s
looking down away from the board away
from the screen no distraction just pure
uh kind of delve into the uh the Mind
Palace the memory banks and Knight back
to D7 I believe is his preparation yeah
I think he knows what he's doing but
it's just about recalling exactly how
you want to continue in this kind of a
really Dynamic approach by white uh
because again it's the kind of opening
where you if you make All the Right
Moves you get out of uh trouble really
quickly but one inaccuracy can mean you
want the the defense for a really long
time and we see a bit of a pawn chain
being formed there by Maxim again I feel
at some point you have to get that C5
break in to get the pawns rolling on the
queen side yeah and uh let's do a bit of
a deep dive here Tanya I want your
opinion first of all uh we're going to
look at moves but also Pawn structure
who's do you prefer White's uh nice
Center here in the middle or do you
prefer this Pawn chain clamping down on
the queen side for black usually this
kind of Pawn structure happens when
white has an extra Pawn in the position
and it took me a while to realize that
actually it is materially balanced white
has uh sorry black has an extra Pawn
usually in these positions but it is
materially balanced I do like the center
I like that uh White has got full
control of the center and for maxim he's
got that double Pawn weakness it's not
it's not the typical four versus two
it's the three and a half versus two
yeah three and a half versus two a nice
way of looking at it because it will be
difficult for black to actually push
those pawns long term whereas it's quite
straightforward for white to push these
pawns later um you don't want to rush of
course you want to get your pieces into
the game maybe move the White Queen just
connect the white Rooks bring them
towards the center but uh yeah it's
looking very balanced right now and the
big question is how does white kind of
Advance later do you ever break this
structure do you ever try and break uh
Black's Pride enjoy you have to prepare
this last move of course maybe Queen C2
and then Pawn to B3 or do you push the
pawn to A4 um for me I would love to
break down this strong point uh starting
with the head of the pawn chain but I
don't know whether you
rush that's a big question um when do
you exactly strike and speaking of
striking do you think on Maxim's radar
is also a strike in the center on the
other side of the board this last move
of fan cattering the bishop to B7 is F5
something that he's thinking about makes
a lot of sense uh especially now you
have a piece it's staring at a concrete
wall of Pawns right now you need to
break the concrete erod it in order to
give this piece life uh so yeah Pawn to
F5 is Black Agenda basically right now
and maybe Pawn to A4 on White's radar
I'm expecting Magnus though to take a
timeout just move his Queen uh at least
kind of improving your pieces before the
action begins but Magnus looking down
now he's kind of replicating uh kind of
copying the post that Maxim showed a few
minutes ago because he was trying to
remember something I have no doubt that
both players are familiar with the types
of plans the types of ideas we did see a
pawn push and black he's locked in his
Bishop Tanya slightly surprising but it
was more important to keep that pawn
train intact yes absolutely because if
you did push the pawn it might be
tempting to go ahead with that B Pawn
that white knight but you create so many
weaknesses on the king side so really
important to keep things solid on the
queen side so it's temporary that you've
put this bishop behind your pawn it does
look a bit of a big Pawn right now
rather than a bishop but black always
has the option to open it up at the
right time with the c Pawn moving
forward and this last move to me seems
to imply that that other break that
we're talking about with the F Pawn
moving forward targeting magnus's Center
we might see that at some point in the
game I think it's very likely and wow
it's Magnus to step forward first uh not
the type of move you would usually see
it looks a bit Hasty here looks a bit
premature uh because you're kind of
losing lots of flexibility now your Pawn
structure is fixed you won't step
forward much further in the center but
he's clearing a nice Square for his
night Tanya he is clearing a really nice
Square for the night and there's a nice
Square cleared for Maxim's night as well
I'm looking at ways of actually forcing
white to take a decision on the queen
side and especially this last move that
Magnus has made really invites Maxim's
knight from D7 to jump to B6 I'm now
targeting your A4 Pawn so first you need
to take a decision around that and then
I'm also eyeing that D5 square that your
last move has left behind yeah and
outposts are the name of the game when
it comes to Knights this is a beautiful
Outpost for Black's Knight it can never
be challenged by a pawn and uh this is a
nice post it can be challenged by a porn
for white but you will jump in it's kind
of a launch pad uh for even stronger
squares so it's really unclear who this
favors it's committ by Magnus Carlson
maybe he's just trying to cut the board
in half here he's only playing on the
king side and he's thinking okay I'm
going to start pushing pawns towards the
black king I think in this kind of
almost mus situation for Magnus he's
just got aggression on his mind nothing
else and I think this must be his plan
it looks like cave manchest just push
borns go for checkmate but sometimes it
can be effective especially with this
type of structure okay the bar slightly
going up for Magnus here with this Rook
move is it uh dramatic in any way I
wouldn't say dramatic it just feels slow
from Vash gra this last move he played
it very kind of quickly he Le leans back
he looks very comfortable but it doesn't
really threaten anything it's kind of a
move you play when you don't really want
to calculate and I think this is the
type of position you have to be a bit
more direct a bit more active all right
well this is uh the Grand Final in
division one I'm going to give you guys
an update on division two and three now
there's uh some drama going on in
division three first of all Sam Sean
coming from the losers bracket has just
won the Grand Final against Ralph
mamadov and that means that is going to
a grand final re set to decide the
winner and if the winner is Sam Sean
that's actually going to be his third
division 3 win this season uh incredible
stuff from The Young American so that's
going on now the Grand Final reset in
division three in division 2 we have
fedos of course keeping a close eye on
him because if MV does not win this uh
Grand Final in division one fedos has a
chance if he wins division two to be the
one to grab that final ticket to Toronto
and uh last time I checked he was in the
lead in The Grand Final there against
artv is he still he's still in the lead
they're playing their fourth and final
game of the Grand Final if he draws that
one he looks like he's in a good
position as well if he draws that one
he's one division two and that means all
hope is out for Yan Pachi sitting at
home uh if fedoseev wins division 2 and
ml does not win division one then then
it's fed going to Toronto then if NBL
wins division one it is NBL going to
Toronto we are keeping a close eye on
all the action happening mvl he is in
the lead in this Grand Final against
Magnus and he has to win this match to
take it to a grand final reset what do
you think will happen in this game three
will we have this match decided MBL win
it we will have the reset or do you
think Magnus will make a comeback it
feels like a decisive result is Brewing
it's incoming Magnus okay going pure
aggression now throwing all the pawns
forward it's just so hard to imagine any
scenario where this is a draw unless
both players somehow come up with
counterplay unless it heads down to an
end game but we're miles away from that
Tanya really I I agree with everything
that you just said I think decisive
result is what's going to happen here
and that last move by maxim of getting
the Rook out I just wonder if we saw the
evalar shoot up because it's just a tiny
bit slow the position just demands so
much action from black immediately
trying to create counter play cuz
magnus's idea is clearly f is clear F4
F5 F6 go for Checkmate on the king side
uh and he started he's on that path
already meanwhile the big question is
what did Maxim achieve with moving that
Rook from f8 to uh to the Central Square
and that could be the critical moment
because it feels as if Maxim had to get
his counter play going on the queen side
before Magnus starts with the spawn roll
yeah I remember when I was a young
player and I used to play moves like
Rook to E8 because they look nice they
improv the piece but one of my coaches
said that's just a lazy move what are
you doing you're not calculating you're
not actually uh kind of reacting to your
opponent's threats and here it's as if
this Rook is on a nice file but it's
staring against the wall of Pawns maybe
it will come in handy later it is on a
better Square than it previously stood
but black could have been using that
time to break in the center to improve
this Knight to an outpost and uh now the
problem for maxim is if he does continue
moving his Knight then uh firstly this
Knight is jumping into the center into
some holes and actually this black Rook
is a target if anything exactly L that's
the other drawback of the move Rook to
E8 and you also have the option of just
advancing the F Pawn but Maxim takes a
huge decision I think he's he realized
all these dangers that exist with the
Knight jumping to E4 the F Pawn
advancing and we see him do that himself
so F5 on the board it's a break that we
were talking about early on well this
time it's more of a defensive move than
an aggressive move stopping White's play
on pan is not an option because notice
how the bishop on E3 is tender so things
have to be kept kept locked up in the
center and for now at least magnus's
Pawn storm has been stalled it has been
stalled but now any end game will be
favorable for white due to this
protected pass Pawn in the center uh you
can never ever trade it away and it will
be ready to run if all the pieces
disappear it will tie down Black's
pieces forever so end games will now
favor white Maxim he's banking on the
fact that he can get his Knight to D5
and just blockade in this middle game
just set up a wall and uh yeah it's all
on the light squares it just depends
whether Magnus can break through if he
can't capture onas one I'm wondering in
a must-win situation whether he starts
throwing other pawns forward uh Pawn to
G4 for example just get rid of this one
and just throw everything towards the
black king risky but it's uh a very kind
of typical thing to do when the center
is locked to start switching your
attention to the flanks and risk is the
name of the game for Magnus right he has
to create his chances uh David we are
going to see G4 I think at some point in
this game because it's really the path
to open up your pawns moving forward I I
wouldn't be surprised if we see it on
this very move G4 it does look very
scary because you're potentially opening
up that Bishop on B7 for black as well
once that c pawn moves forward you've
got to watch out for any ideas on this
long diagonal but with all the squares
under control the central squares
White's Bishop coming to defense on F3
it doesn't feel like it will be enough
to actually create a checkmating attack
for Magnus the big question does he make
a slower move like perhaps Queen coming
to C2 targeting that F5 Pawn which has
been just pushed forward provoke Maxim
to make some more weaknesses is on the
king side provoke him to play a move
like G6 before he does strike with G4 or
does he play it on this move yeah I like
your idea a bit better might as well
just improve the Queen H get this Rook
closer to joining the action for later
and then you push and like you said
you've slightly loosened slightly uh
eroded the white uh the black King's
position as well evaluation Bar says
very strong for Magnus Carson it's far
from obvious for any human that it's
this good for white but uh those plans
we mentioned pushing the pawn it would
uh mean that things get really spicy and
it looks like the structure does favor
white so Vash gra he's kind of gambled
on this blockade and it should be broken
by Magnus Carson right now I think
Magnus due to the fact he's one point
down will go for this idea if it was
level scores he might play a slower more
strategic uh kind of slow uh kind of
approach here but go for it G4 for the
score G4 for the score and Maxim is
definitely on the back foot in this one
and he's got to be feeling the pressure
because he he's got his Pawn majority on
the other side of the board on the queen
side but he hasn't really managed to
make any progress no pawn move is
actually possible on that side of the
board meanwhile Magnus is the one with
all the flexibility on the king side and
that's the side where Maxim's King is on
so this is looking very dangerous for
black it might just be the game that
Magnus Strikes Back yeah enjoy that
message from Hello Kitty CIT when you
got a shower before work but Magnus is
about to play for a win with the white
pieces and remember we want to see your
pictures of how you are watching the
Grand Final share them on Twitter or X
using the hash chess champs for a chance
to win this everything's wave mini we
want to see how you guys are enjoying
this Friday with some great chess so
please share Magnus uh has spent again
more time than MBL in this uh game I
feel I remember from uh the winners
final that it was nvl playing slower
today it seems like Magnus is the one
playing slower yeah it definitely feels
like Magnus is uncharacteristically slow
at this point uh often he's playing
quite instinctively and keeps a Time
Advantage into the end game pressures
his opponents there but I think he's
spending time because this position is
really reminiscent of two days ago in
the fact it's just wild imbalanced it's
a bit crazy you rarely see this type of
horn structure and Tanya we were both a
bit surprised I saw your reaction uh
just after white pushed in the center D5
yeah one thing's for sure this is the
wildest game that we've had uh so far in
uh today's matches both games have been
strategic fights before this one and
this is blowing up it's got everything
to do with the mat situation David D5
did take me by surprise you were looking
at the other break with the gon moving
forward and the first thing that crossed
my mind here was that isn't white just
losing that Central Pawn uh because
notice how two pieces defend it and
black has got two pieces attacking the
D5 square but you can actually trade the
bishop on A5 for the Knight on C3 and I
see the Evar disapproves but the point
was that if white was to recapture on C3
black picks up the D5 pawn and wow the
Valar seems to say that this is really
bad where is the compensation here yeah
I mean you have control you have nice
Dart Square control this bishop has a
nice home in the center Tanya I think
we're going to find out I think we're
going to see this exact variation Maxim
did capture the alternative I will just
mention was to drop back and actually
start trading pieces off uh I would have
loved to trade off this bishop but Maxim
he's going for the material here and
Magnus has paused because after Bishop
takes Knight it's not obligatory to
recapture um the top players in the
world they always look for options in
every position they don't automatically
play the most obvious move sometimes
there's a hidden resource and he could
take on C6 making sure that he doesn't
lose a pawn now this is a double attack
I think black should just take back and
it's the same position essentially T but
without Black's D Pawn on the board but
that's a decision that black would be
really happy with because your Bishop is
suddenly Super Active so Magnus can't
have that in his mind at the back of his
mind uh that seems to work in Maxim's
favor and I think we're getting moves in
that Magnus actually intent on
sacrificing that Central Pawn it has
been captured and now Magnus has to
prove his compensation here he has to
prove his compensation is that going for
the Central Pawn is that again going for
this idea we mentioned earlier going for
the black king uh Magnus has to be
really quick he's just a pawn down there
are some tricky double attack ideas such
as this move maybe uh just the queen to
B1 hitting this Pawn putting some
pressure here the evaluation Bar says no
and maybe these pawns aren't the most
relevant factor in the position the one
thing Magnus has to watch out for is the
Black Knight routing to f8 and then to
sit on this Square uh any passed Pawn
should be blockaded by Knight and if
black gets his Knight round I think
black is doing extremely extremely well
so Magnus only has one or two moves to
strike uh the evaluation bar otherwise
will drop back down maybe even in
Black's favor Big Stuff happening in
this game and I have big news division 2
is finished fed has won the Grand Final
and that means if mvl does not win the
Grand Final it is fed going to Toronto
all hope is now out for Yan Pachi fed
will now sit down and follow this match
so closely he needs Magnus Carlson to
win the grand final he is probably
liking what he is seeing right now the
bar is way up for Magnus at this point
100% I I think if he would have joined
the match a little earlier he wouldn't
have been too happy but it's too soon
for fosf to start celebrating he's done
his job what needed to be done and now
it all comes down to this one so Maxim
Vash lra his fate is on is in his own
hands uh but the position seems like
it's completely out of control right now
uh Maxim up upon Magnus with the bishop
a with the initiative but time is of the
asense here he needs to make sure that
Maxim doesn't manage to reroute his
Knight to the center of the board David
is it time for Magnus now to go ahead
with that break that we're talking about
is my first question and second would
you rather be white or black here o I
think I would need all of magnus's
remaining time to correctly assess this
one if I were playing if I didn't see
the evaluation bar um the thing is I
would take white now with full knowledge
of what the plans are with a bit of time
but if I were playing this over theboard
I'm not sure I would think that black
has a very very safe healthy position
here it looks like the black king is not
going to come under Fire it looks like
you simply have an extra Pawn Black's
Knight is coming around to some good
squares as we pointed out and there we
go already the bar starting to drop down
Magnus maybe should have taken that one
opportunity to start throwing his pawns
forward against the black king because
now black will be reacting and uh okay a
very natural move at least a hit on the
black F5 Pawn do we expect black to
defend it you've got to defend it if you
lose that pawn then you just allow a
Magnus to storm through on the king side
G6 would be the first move that comes to
my mind just join the party defend your
piece your pawns on the board I think G4
the other idea that we've been talking
about hoping to be played on the board
we're going to see it at some point but
Magnus delays that decision for now the
other advantage of this last move move
is that it connects to Rook so now you
can also look at The Rook coming on to
the dline uh if Magnus wants a slower
approach and start targeting that D5
Pawn but it just looks like a slower
approach won't cut it in this one once
Black's Knight lands on that E6 Square I
would really start liking Maxim's
position so it really boils down to the
next three moves yeah this is the
critical moment I think everything will
be decided in the next few turns at
least two holds the advantage and just
to show what Magnus could and should
have done he should have thrown the pawn
forward first I can understand why he
was scared here because the white king
looks like it's really open this
diagonal about to explode the black
queen may be coming in but after a trade
of Pawns here white simply is too quick
I think he he would have been able to
force his pawns through maybe with the
help of his Bishop in the center uh but
he didn't go for this and now the key
question okay he does he does now
finally go for it Magnus Carlson he's
playing for the win G4 he's got to play
for the win and this is a move that
we've all been waiting for and it's
happened G4 Magnus has delayed it but
eventually it's on the board and this
gets absolutely out of control now David
we've got to do a deep dive on the
options that Maxim has here yeah and
whose King is weaker that's the big
question we'll most likely see this Pawn
captured uh the white Bishop will take
back and now white is seriously
threatening to start pushing some pawns
forward if white gets time to blockade
with his Bishop in the center for
example if black plays a slow move if
white gets the time to plant this bishop
then Black's counterpart here this black
Bishop will be dead it's staring at this
pawn and there's no way to fight the
Advance the Avalanche and look at this
Maxi Vash gra such creative play amazing
play right now he doesn't even react he
throws a Pawn off the board he says take
my pawn and look at this Knight to
C5 wow this is crazy he's giving up a
whole Knight now a sacrifice if this
Knight is captured Queen to D5 threatens
Checkmate on G2 using this battery he
actually used in the first game to win
and uh now taking this bishop back next
move this is just another level T of
tactics the night giving itself up on an
empty Square this is another level of
chest that we are seeing Knight C5 a
move that had to be preempted by Maxim
Vash gra as a resource in this position
to go through with it to give up that
deep Pawn in the center opening up his
own Bishop uh this is Maxim really at
his best and uh Magnus has been talking
about his t one Rivals I think today
what we're seeing this is T one Chess at
least for this day Maxim waser lrav is a
tier one rival for Magnus for sure and I
think throughout this tournament he's
proved himself tier one Maxi Vash grav
and Magnus should not take this Knight
do not get tempted it is poisoned I
think this would actually give black the
advantage and uh taking this bishop next
move the threat of Checkmate it would be
too much for Magnus to handle uh too
much of a turn I think he should ignore
this and maybe just capture this Pawn
because he can meet this threat of
checkmate with a block White's Bishop is
able to block the queen and uh this
would be white Advantage so I think
right now Pawn takes Pawn is the key
move and uh will he find it will he play
it that's the big question
even if it means double pawns even if it
means double pawns oh another pawn move
and okay he doesn't go for this uh very
tempting as well to take this Pawn
instead he wants to maybe trade Rooks
first and only then later take on the F5
Square yeah and it's so important that
when the Rooks do get traded Maxim has
to recapture with the bishop and not the
queen because remember the queen needs
to land on that D5 Square to make all
the tactics work for the attack on the
king side Maxim has slowed down because
there is an option there are are
intereses that exist including that
Bishop from B7 in the live position in
the current position to actually jump
over to E4 and hit White's Queen taking
away some of the pressure from that F5
pawn and only then do you start thinking
about maybe even another intereso with
the Knight jumping on to B3 David I'm
attacking your Rook I'm attacking your
Bishop so many options and about five
and a half minutes on the clock to make
a decision yeah I think we need that
popcorn where's the popcorn things are
really leling up right now oh no I'm
just going to sit and watch because uh
Maxim here's a big decision to
make David we need you to to stay with
your analysis board this is just crazy
what's going on and I'm looking at the
clocks as well Magnus is down to two and
a half minutes on his clock and this
must be tense and difficult to play yeah
really hard to navigate as Tanya's
pointed out there's three or four
options for black here alone and every
move for white as well there are several
tempting moves and they'll all lead to
different types of complications okay
Magnus does good for this and Maxim
throws another spanner in the work he
jumps in with his Knight but blunder
okay he's trying to break the connection
between White's Queen I've got so much
popcorn in my mouth I can barely talk
can he's trying to break the connection
between White's queen and the rest of
the position and wow Tanya just Pawn to
F6 just so calm apparently he's winning
for Magnus just push those Pawns in the
center I was actually going to suggest
the second move as well you can just
take on G6 he goes with your idea of
Pawn moving forward because the last
move that just blitzed out he played it
so quickly which was so surprising in a
high responsibility position like this
one it doesn't really attack anything
that night on D3 looks really pretty but
your move Queen to D5 can be stopped
with the bishop jumping onto that F3
there are no checkmates on that diagonal
it just gets challenged immediately uh
did Maxim just rush in with the Knight
rushing onto D3 yeah I think uh it's a
blunder not for kind of tactical means
here it's just a long-term strategic
blunder you've allowed white porns to
live and advance and you have no
counterplay yourself I think he's just
missed something here Tanya I think he
was relying on some tricks and tactics
let's just jump back to show the mistake
from Vash gra we were praising him and
rightly so uh in this position he had
some tempting moves he could have
brought his Bishop to the center as you
mentioned hitting the queen maybe taking
this Pawn next move he could have jumped
the other way with the Black Knight
hitting this bishop at least now white
wouldn't have the luxury of time to push
pawns instead he moved his Knight into
the center but this does nothing it
threatens nothing and these pawns now
are going to prove
decisive I understand nothing to do I
understand him wanting to block the
queen and the pawn putting pressure on
the king side but this just allows a
really strong but and also an extra Pawn
for white and a really strong one on F6
and like you're pointing out uh White's
pawns are coming down the board the
other Pawn joins the party with F4 the
only counterattacking chances that I see
for black is this open diagonal the long
diagonal but that's easily defended by
White's Bishop yeah I don't understand
what he's missed Queen to D five Bishop
blocks and it's game over uh you cannot
give up the black queen right now as
soon as you start retreating White's
pawns will be decisive now any end game
white is winning as well I think he was
just hoping in this position that white
would get uh naive here get greedy and
take this Knight off the board and
suddenly opposite color Bishops black
would be the one striking on the light
squares coming in and big attack but
here we go Maxim V grb has to fight he's
trying to get his Queen into the
position and look the computer just for
a second there showed the winning move
block this diag stop the black queen
coming in continue pushing your pawns go
for the black king it is winning for
Magnus can he finish it off that's the
big
question it looks like he's super close
to doing just that and I think the point
of going ahead with that pawn is not
only to block the queen and Magnus is
thinking about it but if Maxim was to
recapture it it gives white the option
to actually jump in with the bishop onto
an attack Bishop H5 looks like a really
strong move here David you're not only
hitting the Rook but the F Pawn is
moving down the board yeah this would be
a decisive check any porn check now
would end the game and Magnus Retreats
his Queen he's allowing The Black Queen
in this is really risky for Magnus
counterintuitive he wants to use his
Bishop along this diagonal to block kick
her out maybe uh but Queen to H3 would
threaten Checkmate and he would be
forced to trade off Bishops Maxim though
wow he's going all in what why is he not
looking at the white king why is he
playing on the other side of the board
this is really inconsistent he's playing
on the king side then suddenly switching
to the queen side and now Max Magus has
the time to kick away the black queen
this is going to be game over this Pawn
is going to advance then this one is
going to advance yeah he's trying to
destabilize that Bishop in the center
but he doesn't have any time to do that
and the Queen's hit you can move to the
center of the board and now Magnus will
drop back with that Bishop hit the queen
defend the Checkmate in one Maxim has
nothing better than to retreat with the
queen what he's counting on is that you
can't take on B4 cuz the bishop on D4 is
hanging but now the strongest piece on
the board from Maxim vasher is no more
on the board yeah the Bishops have just
been traded and now I'm expecting Magnus
to start going in moving in for the kill
is all to do with these pawns these
three pawns are going to clinch it for
him okay first he improves the queen
very logical but those pawns will start
rolling soon and that will spell the end
of this
game but Magnus down to about a minute
on the clock uh still some things to
play for here that as long as that
Knight stays on D3 you've got Queens on
the board it's maybe not completely over
David you and we know that Maxim plays
for tricks yes and one minute one minute
I think if this were a classical game a
even a rapid game Magnus would Cruise
the victory here but yeah nerves could
still kick in especially when it's queen
of Knight versus queen and Bishop great
combo there m and I have to say m himim
he has shown uh Fearless in this game
right he has played uh just throwing his
pieces in this in this game and it was
perfect play till that moment that he
rushed in with his Knight to that D3
Square where where we see it which thr a
little bit too much
and I think he played it so fast that is
what was surprising to me Ka because he
had about 5 and a half minutes on the
clock at that time Magnus was down to
about 2 and a half a really wild unclear
position uh and I think it was that
moment that it all turned around giving
Magnus the possibility to build this uh
uh these three pawns down the board that
we're seeing right now uh and Maxim is
he thinking about jumping in with the
Rook to the second rank or is he just
regretting some of the decisions of the
past probably a bit of both probably
getting a bit nervous now and he doesn't
go for something active those were the
two options to go active with the black
Rook or to go into a passive post and
wow Magnus has thrown up away a pawn to
get at the black king where is the
finishing touch the black king Now is
really open those two pawns around it as
well thorns in that black king side
feels like checkmat somewhere Tanya but
where is the killer blow Magnus needs to
get his queen or his rook in to check
that black king somehow you you won
those pieces on the G line uh and it's
so tempting to start with a check with
the queen because I don't think that
Black's King can actually go to h8 but
Magnus has a different approach why is
he going into an end game he could have
gone for checkmate now black has some
really dangerous pawns oh the bar goes
down bar goes down there was a threat
white was threaten Pawn to F7 with a
deadly check so black had to take out
the time to block allowing Magnus to
trade something but okay it's only a one
Pawn advantage and wow the evaluation
ball is completely gone uh oh and Magnus
reacts I think he's just lost control I
think he's annoyed at the type of
position he's suddenly got black has a
blockade on the light Square suddenly if
the Rooks are gone it is a draw and it
was so tempting to just give a check and
try and at least think if there's a way
to end the game on the spot but Magnus
going for this end game and Maxim is
back now he's touching the one minute
Mark but it all relies on this uh
counter play with the c Pawn moving
forward Magnus with a big threat he
wants to give a check with the rook and
then push the E Pawn for further up the
board is it time to actually challenge
The Rook David like you said if the
Rooks come off it could very well be the
end of the game yeah I think he would
love to trade Rooks off right now he
can't quite because white would give a
check with his uh Pawn so I think maybe
just enter the center Black's King can
act as a blockada there we go if the
white Rook tries to sneak behind the
Black Knight is actually able to control
some checking squares there we go
there's no way to check the black king
anymore black has a perfect light
squared blockade white only has a d
square bishop and can't stop the march
of the black C Pawn wow and the king and
Knight playing in such Perfect Harmony
defending everything on the center while
The Rook assists a black pawn down the
board it feels like all of Maxim's
pieces are suddenly in the right spot
Magnus looking for a check along the
flank he needs to find a way to start
pushing that E Pawn Yeah but the black
king it shouldn't walk back it shouldn't
Retreat right now because it would walk
into a check therefore it goes forward
and Magnus is banking everything on his
pawns but this is risky Magnus is
playing with fire Suddenly It's a race
who could NV even win this game
definitely yeah it's okay position for
three result and I think what Magnus is
counting on is if mvl pushes that c Pawn
he wants to go Rook to C6 on that c line
let's show this tan that's an amazing
spot a great tactic right now if black
pushes this might backfire if mag if
Vash gra isn't careful The Rook was
would act as a deflection giving itself
up in order for white to make a new
Queen now the black Rook would no longer
cover this square and the evaluation bar
going crazy there but this queen check
notably it comes with check so black has
no time to promote and next move white
can stop the pawn from pushing and okay
he didn't go for this really surprising
it feels like both players are missing
stuff right now uh the white Bishop
drops back the black Rook attacks this
pawn and Maxim now I think he's trying
to play Safety First chess he's just
trying to remove the white pawns if
white steps forward with this one I
think he can Retreat his Knight with a
double attack just about holding and
just by the skin of his teeth saving the
draw and it's so important that white
can go E7 right now because then you
just simply take that F7 pawn and the
Knight also controls the very key
queening Square on E
yeah beautiful flexibility there from
Vash gra but let's get that popcorn back
out will he find that move he has to
retreat his KN he does it he does find
it the only move to draw there I believe
and uh of course these top players they
find the best move time and time again
seconds he's got to make a move he does
he's still keeping his chances alive but
not anymore this is going to end in a
draw
whoa what a game and I think we have we
do have a result we have a result it's a
draw oh wow that was up and down Magnus
about to make a comeback but mvl saves
the game he is still in the lead here in
the Grand Final and that means with a
draw or a win in game four we are going
to the reset it is going to be must win
for Magnus Carlson in game four what
happened here Tanya I mean it looked
like certainty that Magnus would win
this game at some point it really did uh
he played incredible chess and then
Maxim played that and some more eror but
Magnus was in driver's seat for the most
part of it and it looked like this was
going to be his comeback game but some
key resourceful moves by Maxim Sav the
day and now he just needs a draw and I
think the craziness continues but the
good news for maxim is he starts with
the white pieces the next one oh that's
true this was a golden opportunity for
Magnus yeah huge opportunity and a
missed opportunity in the end for Magnus
Carlson but well done to Vash gra for
fighting uh like a lion there to save it
and Magnus the key conceptual mistake
was trading the Queens he had the safer
King keeping the Queens on the board
should have guaranteed a check mate and
it was here where he made the Fateful
decision to take this pawn and as we saw
later after the Queens disappeared black
was able to set up a blockade on the
light squares and save the draw If
instead he had kept the Queens on
actually multiple winning moves here for
example giving a check then surely he
would have clinched the full point the
king moves and suddenly white Rook could
enter the other side of the board
crashing through infiltrating the
seventh Rank and this would be decisive
maybe what Magnus had missed was that
after Rook to G8 looked like a pin there
was the winning move Pawn to E6 a check
deflecting The Black Queen suddenly
another check and Black's defenses
collapse this is very natural play he
would have found it but the clock played
its part wow and the drama continues you
guys game four in the Grand Final is
coming up if Magnus Carlson wins it we
will head to Armageddon if he loses or
MV uh or it is a draw then we are are
going to the Grand Final reset so more
games to come stay with us we'll be
right
[Music]
back it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things have a friend or family member
who loves chess give them a chess.com
membership today and see them take their
game to the next level you can choose a
gold platinum or Diamond membership for
1 month or one year want your gift to
arrive on your friend's birthday or on a
holiday gifts can be scheduled to arrive
up to 90 days in the future all premium
plans include an adree experience
unlimited puzzles and lessons and unlock
all Bots go platinum to add unlimited
game review or Diamond to unlock
insights and Coach explanations give the
gift of Chess today
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the AI Cup in
this tournament we have been very
excited that chess.com is partnering up
with the browser maker Oprah Making just
a chess themed browser it's awesome you
guys and it is something for chess
lovers everywhere it truly puts the game
right at your fingertips and that's
exactly what's going to happen right now
using the Opera browser David is now
going to play bullet chess again someone
you know very well David you have
received a challenge from our main man
in the control room osil oh are you
nervous now I am a bit nervous I must
admit I don't have the best mouse in the
world but we're going to dive into the
uper browser yet again and uh I'm going
to play this bullet game against my good
friend usill who's actually a very
strong player a speed demon so here we
see the Opera browser really slick
really nice and uh the chess.com
shortcut for anyone who wants to play
chess sneakily at work and okay
hopefully he's challenged me I don't see
it right now I might have to jump in and
challenge him where are you ask meh H
and I are eating popcorn okay I'm going
to type in this is going to be everyone
gets as's username now there we go here
we go I'm sending off a challenge
because I'm desperate to play some
bullet and game on my favorite carakan
defense I'm going to take trade off some
pieces
hopefully and I'm G to go with all the
prees hopefully he's not watching has he
ever beaten you David um not yet not yet
there's a first time for everything
though and okay my beloved karukan I'm
going to keep
pushing and
okay o he's coming for my king he's
coming for the black king I'm going to
threaten a sneaky attack now on the A2
Pawn he
blocks I've w a pawn Tanya what do you
think this is getting super tricky I've
never seen David so competitive in one
of these he knows he's playing as he's
ready for this one W David really going
for asal's King here you've seen you saw
the golf you know how competitive I am
I'll never live it down if I lose this
game but I'm trying to get for uh trying
to get to that white king nice move
there by ask kill it makes David pause
really nice move he's going to attack my
queen now I'm going to move it and hope
and now okay I've got a pawn
chain am I going to be boring here and
try to grind it out oh okay let's go
you know me Tanya Queen's off the board
just like Magnus did in that last game
this time I'm a few pawns up though and
okay 27 seconds against 21 he's so quick
ill I'm a bit nervous oh this is going
to be about
flagging has to pre-move he has to pre
moove Bishop be for Rascal a few extra
pawns for David okay pawns are
rolling pawns are
coming uh how flashy can I be here no
that doesn't
work I was going to try something a bit
sneak s okay I'm going to take this
Pawn he sees it as sees the big threat
he sees all the
threats okay I was nearly going to play
Rook to d8 that would have blundered a
whole Rook oh my God the tension he's
coming for me he's coming for me but the
clock
though 12 seconds
with thanks fighing nice nice one okay
good playing there as I wish we had an
image of you in the control room right
now good game good game against
Grandmaster David Howell all right this
is the AI cup we are waiting for game
four in the Grand Final before the
tournament we called up some of the
players and ask them if they are scar
sorry scared of robots taking over the
world are you scared of robots taking
over the world uh like int I think it's
a matter of intuition for everyone like
it's just how you feel like there is
nobody knows but I don't really feel um
the danger uh really not robots taking
over the world doesn't really occupy my
mind I do accept that it may be a
possibility so you know for this sort of
stuff I have very you know pragmatic way
of saying you know it's absolutely out
of my control so whatever happens
happens and if you could program a robot
to do anything in your imagination to do
one thing for you every single day what
would that be well you know I spend so
much time analyzing chess uh it would be
nice if the
if it would be like a good robot I would
UNL chest like that would be nice then I
I could focus on uh playing Blitz you
know and spending time with my family
and uh uh and get all the all the good
Novelties you know right in my my inbox
I don't know work on chest openings
probably the king I mean that's the one
thing I cannot do for for the life of me
bring me my slippers
so bring yachi his slippers all right
it's about to get very dramatic but we
are so much enjoying this final day in
the AI cup and we are enjoying seeing
you guys do the same thing let's take a
look at some of the pictures you have
shared on Twitter using the hasht J
[Music]
chaps
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
you
awesome to see the kids also enjoying
the chess I also loved some of you on
the train home from a long week it's
Friday some of you still at work but
remember weekend is coming and now right
now game four is coming here in the
Grand Final MV is in the lead that means
it's must win now for Magnus Carlson to
take this to Armageddon this is
definitely not the last game of the
Grand Final fin we will either go to
Armageddon or we will go to a grand
final reset so lean back and just buckle
up because this is going to be
interesting Magnus is snacking up
getting his energy levels to the top
it's going to be MBL with the white
pieces he only needs a draw in this one
to go to the reset so what should we
expect I think he will stick to his guns
and continue playing this strategy we
saw in game two of the day he was able
to get a relatively p less draw uh quite
safe play there um just two games ago
and Magus switches it up no more Berlin
defense of course it's the karakhan he
can't afford a burlin defense he goes
for the same opening I think he was
inspired by a bullet game right now
against sill so we're seeing the Caro
again in this one and uh we've seen
Magnus have this approach with the car
in a must-win situation that's right and
actually the players already have had
this exact position against each other
in this tournament in the Armageddon
game two days ago uh Magnus also
employed the karakan it will not have
come as a surprise and they had this
position against each other okay there
Maxim pushed his H Pawn went really
aggressive of course in a situation
where a draw is enough he doesn't need
to do that and okay a pawn push Magnus
playing very much in the style of AI
Alpha zero pushing pawns gaining space
on the flanks computers really endorse
this especially when the center is
blocked interesting play Tanya really
interesting play and uh Magnus just
blitzing out his moves Maxim the first
one to take a think right now Maxim
needs only a draw in this in this game
and that psychologically is such a
battle because when the chances happen
do you keep it safe do you try to keep
it safe because that can backfire
especially against uh against Magnus
Carlson or will he try to take those
opportunities uh and make the position
Brash because a Carrow and this A5 A4
approach by Magnus surely signals that
Magnus wants a long game yeah and I
think it's an inspired Choice by Magnus
no matter what the result eventually
because here at least he keeps piece on
the board and we've said this time and
time again when players are in must win
situations I think this goes for
everyone at home as well if you're
desperate to win and uh don't want to
risk any end games any uh kind of simple
draws or allow your opponent to force
the issue then you've got to pick your
openings wisely but keep pieces on the
board tends to be the key but just a
deep thought here from the corner so
Magnus would he actually prefer the
Armageddon or would he maybe even prefer
the reset another match with two rapid
games I think he'll take the geddon
purely because he knows that worst case
he'll have that reset mhm uh but if he
didn't have the reset I think he'd
prefer more games rather than one one
game shootout H and it was the armagen
that got him the win last time in his
match against uh Maxim so he's
definitely looking for that win uh
there's no question about that he hasn't
given up on this match just yet okay and
that's very clear from his opening
approach because if he was getting ready
for the Grand Final reset he would have
probably just gone ahead with the Berlin
approach but kakan means he's up for a
fight in this one and we're seeing a
very imbalanced position already where
black has got this eternal control over
that Central D5 square but is slightly
behind in development and Maxim should
try and make the most of that lead in
development over the next few moves and
how would you start in trying to achieve
that yeah I was going to say this move
is very tempting uh trying to create
another imbalance and this time Black's
most active piece most valuable piece
right now is the light Square bishop and
he's hunting it down he's going to trade
it off guaranteed now for one of the
white Knights Pawn structure tends to
favor knights in these types of
positions Tanya so I don't think it's
the end of the world for Magnus Carlson
but that light squ Bishop was really
strong uh makes a lot of sense to do
this I think if White had been too slow
just over the last couple of moves let's
jump in and show this uh then Magnus
would have been able to create a bind uh
right now that's not possible because he
has to deal with this threat but if
Maxim for example had been a bit lazy
here and just moved his Bishop then
suddenly the Black Knight is coming into
the center this is a uh just beautiful
Outpost the Knight supported by its
other Knight and black would simply move
the bishop out and Castle instead we see
some developments the Knight did hunt
this bishop uh Magnus forced this uh
issue here by pushing a pawn threatening
now trying to retreat this bishop it was
of course chopped off Maxim defended his
Pawn in the center and Magnus now
continuing to gain space yeah really
thematic stuff he's uh trying to develop
this bishop to a really nice Square
either this one or activate his Rook
even and do you really want to allow
this Pawn to live Maxim says no because
this Pawn might even become a queen
later in the game yeah that's such a big
decision to make right B3 would be the
natural move the natural response but
that pawn on A3 will give black so much
so many chances throughout even in the
end game and Maxim wants to keep that
pressure I think the move that you were
alluding to is still possible develop
that Bishop to B4 really tying down
White's uh Queen side there and also
threatening a uh a trade on B2 next yeah
that would be a really nice move the
most logical reply would be white Queen
for example coming forward and Magnus
would have to evaluate the uh
consequences of this one the one thing
you don't want to do as black is ever
trade because then now you open up lines
while you're undeveloped while the black
king still stuck in the middle and
suddenly threats appear um so Magnus has
to be careful he has to develop I think
this is the most natural move uh it's
the move he wants to play uh but if he
can't make that work maybe he'll just
develop and get his King to safety
before worrying about any concrete
action yeah and even though white has
got the bishop there as black you never
really want to take on three unless
there's a concrete followup to that
option because you end up giving quite a
lot of activity on the F line The Rook
is already lined up F7 becomes a really
tender point in that situation and in
this opposite color Bishop the light squ
Bishop that white has it will have a
clear Target even in some positions
Landing up on H5 or D3 as you're
pointing out so you really have to wait
before you uh capture that Bishop on E3
I do like that Knight on F5 that's
placed Magnus does develop but to
another Square uh he starts with the
move Bishop to E7 and this gives Maxim
some time to respond now yeah some time
to respond one option for example would
be to open up the B file but I don't
think you really want to do this while
the black Rook can pounce and come into
play with gain of time and uh therefore
he plays a really cunning move I was
going to point this out this relies on a
really sneaky trick Maxim he's in top
form just the way he's playing the speed
he's playing because now it he is giving
up a pawn even though he only needs a
draw the idea is now that white can
launch a double attack jumping with the
queen hitting this weak Pawn a vital
Pawn in Black's camp and also hitting
this night a double attack and this
would be decisive this would be a
blunder if Magnus gets greedy and takes
this Pawn it's the move he wants to play
but he cannot get away with it I think
he just has to ignore Bishop takes
Knight as a threat and
Castle but that's fantastic awareness
right there by Maxim because when you
pointed out there's a trick in this
position I automatically started looking
for discovered attacks on that D4 square
but it's actually got this idea that the
king is completely safe there are no
checks possible in this position so
Queen to G4 is the real trick uh setting
up this uh big threat of winning the G7
Pawn just incredible tactics here and
very possible that Magnus actually
missed this move uh we don't tend to
play the same piece twice in the opening
so Bishop D3 a really nice uh a nice
play there by Maxim I don't think Magnus
will be happy about castling and giving
this bishop F5 Bishop takes Knight
option to White yeah for example just uh
to show quickly he he could now just
take for example move his Queen forward
and white has this beautiful Center
actually something we saw Magnus with in
the previous game a very similar Pawn
structure there and white if anyone has
the advantage not good news for Magnus
Carlson in this must-win situation yeah
wow uh looking at this position that we
have out of the opening I think a grand
final reset might be the most likely
outcome
o it's too early to call and of course
anything can happen but I would take
white here with this last move that
Maxim's played threatening to win that
Knight on F5 and if Magnus is forced to
take that Bishop on E3 which he does uh
you simply recapture with the pawn Open
up The Rook the bishop is nicely lined
up the queen and the bishop can become a
battery on this diagonal threatening
mates on 87 it's an opposite color
Bishop how on Earth does Magnus create
his chances in this one David it's going
to be hard for Magnus you can see in his
body language he doesn't look too
optimistic right now he just has to keep
the game going we know his skill
his expertise in the end game I think
it's a distant dream right now winning
this game with black but he just has to
keep the game alive that's all you can
do in must-win situations just hope that
your opponent's nerves kick in
eventually or hope that they try to
force the draw force the issue too soon
yeah right now though white has done
everything right ma Maxim not just
winning on the board uh winning on the
score line he's winning in terms of air
quality it looks so much healthier for
him maybe that's giving him the edge
over Magnus Carson that's why he's in
top form this whole tournament maybe
Maxim but he's just so so professional
right now and he looks calm he looks
composed he looks um yeah he looks ready
for that Grand Final reset he's been
merciless in this match so far and he's
winning on the clock as well amongst
other things uh it's leveling out a
little bit but it's important for him to
try and keep that edge and even use uh
the 17th piece against the world number
one we've seen that be a big factor in
those critical moments who has those
extra seconds to take those decisions uh
uh and I wonder if the last game was
really magnus's big opportunity the
golden opportunity that just ended up
turning to dust it felt like he was so
close to delivering Checkmate he was he
was uh just one or two accurate moves
away from winning that game Magnus
Carson and now we would see a totally
different scenario with both players
going for each other potentially the
Armageddon as well where Magnus actually
has a phenomenal score uh score
historically in Armageddon um I remember
commentating on Norway chest this year
Magnus won seven Armageddon in a row
against world class opposition so I
think that would have been almost
hopeless for FAS gra but with the lead
now he can bully Magnus he can uh kind
of keep the draw in hand and he's
actually maybe even hoping for more with
this last move Tanya this is the idea
that we've been discussing right uh set
up the battery between the bishop and
the Queen and watch out you don't really
have time to jump in with the Knight to
C4 it's a move that you want to make
hitting that pawn on B2 hitting that
pawn on E3 but now Queen D3 is just uh
double trouble for black cuz you're
threatening Checkmate and you lose the
Knight on C4 so regardless of whether
Magnus jumps in with the Knight on not
Maxim is making his intentions clear and
you're right if the draw happens it
happens but he's getting ambitious in
this position he wants to go Queen D3
next provoke some more weaknesses on the
king side eventually think about maybe
doubling up the Rooks on the F line once
the tension on the with the B and the a
pawn are resolved with even a potential
B3 uh move and then uh you're looking at
targeting Black's King yeah looks like
oneway traffic to me I just don't see
what Magnus can really hope for here
sooner or later you mentioned the
weakness he's going to have to create
he's going to have to put a Pawn on G6
uh just to block the uh strength of this
diagonal but then it's really really
loose uh this structure for black white
can bring the queen out this way
threaten all sorts of sacrifices on the
G6 Square white can later throw this
Pawn down the board to try and loosen
things up we see so many ideas here for
white do you see any for black
Tanya it feels like Magnus getting that
a pawn up down the board should be able
to create some counterplay on the queen
side but right now he has to take care
of things on the other side of the board
so while there are ideas that exist uh
with the tension that we see on the left
side of the board Magnus has to be
active on the other part and he does he
starts with the move Bishop to G5 I
think the move that you were pointing
out with the pawn push it will happen
once ma Maxim does threaten that
Checkmate but right now there is a
direct threat of picking up that pawn
queen to D3 play G6 play these are ideas
that we've been looking at and now I
really like this Rook lift that we were
alluding to earlier uh exactly why
you're pointing it out it not only
clears the space for the other white
Rook to join the party but also really
over defends that E3 Square yeah you
have so many tempting moves right now
for white you can uh push this Pawn one
or two squares just to clarify the
tension you can maybe go uh for the
black Bishop in this way pushing some
pawns here later you have a nice Square
for the White Knight Maxim Vash gra he's
in the driver's seat he's done
everything perfectly and uh yeah Magnus
he's on the back foot it's just all gone
wrong for him and imagine poor fed have
watching at home doing the hard work
winning division 2 uh incredible play by
him but he's watching this and he's
thinking Magnus you're letting me down
he's uh yeah really cheering against mvl
right now for that spot in the tour
finals and probably in uh fed's head it
must have been at the start of the day
if I can do my part of the job you know
that should be that should be deal done
because Magnus of course is a big
favorite especially when you have to
beat him twice so right now FV is
definitely feeling a little bit of of
the pressure as well but a big
congratulations to him a fantastic
performance in division 2 but will it be
enough to get him through to Toronto
right now Maxi making sure uh that that
doesn't happen playing excellent chess
David he goes for your idea I like this
move a lot because now you're coming in
with the tempo the H Pawn will not only
go to H4 but also Target that hook that
has been created with the G Pawn moving
forward H4 H5 coming up I think black
has to stop it perhaps with his own H
Pawn moving forward yeah massive threat
winning threat actually on the board
from Vash grav it looks innocuous but
pushing this Pawn forward would end
things for example if black gets greed
and plays on the other flank Pawn to H4
kicking the bishop back and just
continuing to break down uh the blockade
of this what Magnus Carlson he's just
calling the bluff he's just ignoring the
safety of Black's King how can he get
away with this but it's not a bluff
right Pawn to H4 the evaluation Bar says
white is just winning here and it's very
obvious it's very natural the black
Bishop only has one safe Square the
white Pawn push pushes forward for
example you cannot take now you cannot
take this Pawn let's just show that
Checkmate the black king caught uh
really caught embarrassed here and how
else do you defend simply porn takes
Pawn next move looks devastating Magnus
is going to try and hold this somehow
but the only move that comes to my mind
in this position is to try and defend
the G6 Pawn with Queen to E8 but it
looks like such an ugly move in the
position such an ugly move and not just
are you getting attacked on one side of
the board at the right moment white can
even just recap this Pawn what is black
even trying to do on the queen side and
there's a Target here there's a Target
behind it I don't understand in the
computer there we see the engine
suggestions below the board it does
confirm Pawn to H4 the most natural move
that has just been set up uh by Pawn to
G3 it's also consistent it gives an over
plus two Advantage for Vash gra right
now and Maxim has paus and he plays it
he finds the move H4 he doesn't
automatically capture on the queen side
uh we might be going into a grand final
reset with Maxim winning this one as
well wow but is this Magnus also you
know it doesn't matter if he loses or if
it this game is a draw is it just him
Taking Chances especially on this last
move I would say yes uh up until that
point he was playing quite objective
chess he was getting frustrated that
Vash gra was shutting down anything he
tried but this last move it just feels I
mean the fact that he's even thinking
now after kind of basically asking for
white to push the pawn forward it's
bizarre it's very strange it's been just
uncharacteristic chess from Magnus from
the start if we think about game one
which he lost that end game that should
have been so easy for him to hold David
uh so many options uh having that extra
Pawn he loses that one the second one
ends in a peaceful draw and then the
third one where he had this golden
opportunity to actually win and Magnus
Caron doesn't let go of winning
positions he's somebody who's able to
win losing positions as well and that
one gets out of his hand and look at
that he's giving up right now yeah he
was reacting there on the camera briefly
Magnus and the this is desperation this
is not inspired decision right now he's
giving up his Bishop he's trying to get
the black queen in to go for an attack
against White's King but the queen will
be attacking alone White's King will
have some Defenders around it White's
Rook White's Queen they can act as
shields in front of this white king I
don't see it I don't see any
compensation right now it is a bishop
for three pawns sorry but one of those
pawns will drop the black B2 pawn and uh
first I think Maxi Vash will lift up his
Rook or bring his Queen to the defense
yeah you can just stop there is a threat
the only the biggest threat that black
has in this position is to give a
Perpetual which guess what is good
enough for maxim even if there is a
queen to G3 and a queen to H3 repetition
that we see on the board a draw gets
Maxim through so it's not even the end
of the world if he was to allow that but
I like your idea just get your pieces to
defend because the B2 Pawn uh you can
eventually pick that up rook F2 or with
the queen moving forward and but he does
he does the professional thing you
called it there Tanya he's going to
allow a draw we're going to see this
repetition of moves and we will be
headed for that Grand Final reset wow is
that over not yet Magnus gave a check
he's just a piece down though if he
doesn't take the draw Magnus can pretty
much resign and a draw is enough for
white Maxim so professional here Magnus
head and hands he knows there's nothing
to be done because there's no other
piece that can join the party with the
queen nothing else that assists in the
attack and Magnus there K he's getting
ready and look at that he's giving away
another Rook checks to follow there we
go it's a draw and that means we are
heading to a grand final reset Magnus
Carlson loses the match here in the
Grand Final against NBL he is on fire
the Frenchman taking it to a grand final
reset he still has hopes of winning the
AI cup and he still has hopes of going
to the tour finals in Toronto 5 minutes
now you guys before game one in the
Grand Final reset that will be best out
of two rapid games if that is tied
Armageddon will decide the AI cup okay
what do you think about the situation
right now Tanya K I decided at the start
of the day that if Maxim takes the first
set for me he becomes a favorite in this
match and it's not just the score line
it's not just him taking the first step
I'm going to go as far as saying Maxim
has been the better player today does
that mean he is the favorite do you
agree with that David
I'm not sure that he's the favorite I
would still say it's 50/50 because
Magnus does have extra gears and he's
not been himself today Magnus Carson
that is clear he's missed opportunities
he's played really uncharacteristic and
really slow I have a feeling he'll still
go up uh he'll his form will improve but
Maxim he still has enough in the tank as
well it looks like he hasn't had to go
into any effort I think it's just a pure
50/50 anything can happen I'm taking
David up on this one uh David let's have
a bet on this I I think Max's going
going to get the job done today Ka wow
what about you you know I kind of agree
cuz I've been listening to you guys
momentum is a big thing and momentum is
definitely now on Maxim vajra's side he
won the first match now one match to go
to decide the AI cup only a few minutes
until it starts get ready you guys we
will be right
[Music]
back chess is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which recharge after five moves you may
cast your spell whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a 3X3
Square area and the pieces in this area
are temporarily Frozen in place combine
your powers of Chess and sorcery to
defeat your
opponent come see what supercell and
chess.com have cooked up in our new
variant spell chess available now on
chess.com
[Music]
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlson and vishi Arna
this course is generally about examples
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest
level good intuition comes from knowing
a lot of examples from having seen
examples thought about them and perhaps
tried to implement the principles but
under different circumstances having
thought about it having tried to
implement it in a way and having debated
it so that's more or less what I try to
do at this
course basically put puts the foundation
for positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in in many
[Music]
players welcome back everyone it is a
grand final reset Magnus Carlson will
have the white pieces in the first out
of two games to now decide the AI cup
and it's not only about winning the
tournament it's also about going to
Toronto because Vladimir fedoseev has
won division 2 and that means he is the
one going to Toronto to the tour finals
if MV does not win division one he is
rooting for Magnus Carlson to now win
division one in the AI Cup and the the
Grand Final reset will be a best out of
two rapid games we start from scratch
zero points for both players the winner
will be the winner of the tournament if
they are tied after those two rapid
games with 50 15 minutes plus 3 seconds
increment we do head into Armageddon
where there is no increment and uh the
winner in Armageddon will be the winner
of uh the AI cup only 5 minutes is what
the players have had to just reset get
ready zero points so uh what do you
think is happening now with Magnus cson
getting ready with the white
pieces I think for Magnus it's just
about switching things up completely uh
we were talking about this right right
Maxim has not only won the previous game
but in every aspect of it whether it was
the opening the middle game the end game
whether it was tactics or whether it was
defending difficult position in every
aspect it felt like Maxim was doing
something better than Magnus uh but
Magnus with his back against the wall
how many times have we seen him make the
comeback just too many to count so too
soon to write it off but momentum is
definitely on Maxim side he's got to be
feeling confident after the chest that
he's just played he's finding all the
accurate moves he's doing it fast he's
doing everything right uh he just needs
to I think not let the pressure get to
his head right now yeah they have been
Rivals for so many years they are good
friends Maxim and Magnus Carlson both
born in 1990 so focused right now both
of them getting ready for the reset
white pieces for Magnus Carlson what do
you think will happen now David well
Magnus I think he's going to go for it
he doesn't want anything boring he's got
a bit of pred to save now so I think he
will want to get his first win of the
day for him a 5minute break maybe wasn't
enough I think for the two players Max
is the one as you said with momentum he
wants to keep going Magnus needed a bit
more time potentially but it's a repeat
of the Queens Gambit accepted it's a
repeat from game three of the earlier
final still all the same moves that we
discussed earlier that we saw earlier uh
nothing different that's why the players
are playing so quickly up to this point
and Magnus hopes that nothing is
different because this is the one game
where he had a big big chance at wck
three but now we do see a deviation from
that game three of set one uh a
different position so it looks like
Maxim has done some damage control has
done some preparation in the in between
matches yeah wow I'm really surprised
they didn't have that much time between
games and Maxim Vash gra clearly spent
at least a fair portion of that time
looking at his opening notes or maybe
talking to a coach saying what should I
have done this is risky though he has
changed things up the last two three
moves are new compared to to the game we
saw earlier today but this was what
Magnus Carson has prepared and look at
this it's just a crazy position that's
blown open white is a porn up white has
castled Queen side however now white is
two pawns up and Magnus sacrifices his
queen look at the speed they're playing
both players now 17 moves and they both
have more time than they started the
game with this is opening preparation
let's do a quick count black has a queen
white in return has a bishop and three
pawns that's a three-point deficit for
white but White's pieces are active
White's pawns are
advancing wow this is some of the
deepest opening preparation you'll have
ever seen this has probably been saved
up from uh World Championship matches by
Magnus uh this is how seriously he's
taking this is how badly he wants to win
but uh also Queen sacrifices he does
have the flare for the artistic this is
absolutely crazy the players Blitz out
up to this point have more time on the
clock that they start with and Maxim's
the first one to go into a thing tank
and that can be a bit ING with black
when white spawn is on C6 it's all about
peace activity and making sure that
black doesn't get his pieces developed
the coordination going notice how that
last move takes away key squares from
Black Knights to offer any trade
especially that D7 Point next what
Magnus wants to do is get the H1 Rook to
the D1 square and basically just
dominate the position with a pieces but
bishop and three pawns for a queen it
shouldn't be enough it shouldn't be
enough this is isn't the best Queen in
the world this isn't the best Queen
you'll ever see um she's struggling for
air right now uh if she steps forward
then your move on the board Tanya The
Rook would swing across and it's more
about these other pieces um also now if
the queen moves this Pawn might be uh up
for grabs I must say visually I really
love White's position you always get a
bit of a kick as a chess player giving
up material and still having a healthy
position you just have the kind of
pressure released you're a queen down
you can play uh kind of freely here but
then again if objectively uh kind of
things go wrong you will be a queen down
yeah wish I agree with you but Maxim
he's a mathematician he's doing the math
in this position he's got a queen which
is worth nine points uh versus six
points but it's really all about peace
activity here that Rook from8 can't
unfortunately go to that A7 Square to
try to develop because the bishop on E3
controls it look at the way Magnus is
using that extra Bishop to take away key
squares from black he's just not
allowing the Harmony in Maxim position
Rook d8 a massive threat massive threat
that would Fork the queen and the King
if white gets time to play that check so
black has to give some material back how
do you do this I think you have to just
block what else can you do you cannot
Block in this manner because white
actually has another strike this would
win the queen back immediately and
you've won a lot of material in the
process uh so you pretty much you have
to give back a whole piece if you're
Vash de gra you can drop your knight in
the way of White's Rook to block this
deadly check and uh I mean this is just
chaos I think I need 15 hours let alone
15 minutes to work out the consequences
of this one well it looks like Magnus
has worked out all the consequences at
home because he's got still more time
than what he started with and the only
way to defend the threat the one that
you were pointing out is on the board
magnes gets another minor piece so that
does add to that material imbalance in
favor of Magnus and I'm expecting him to
jump in with the Knight to C6 is that a
move that you would consider here
attacking that Rook on E7 it looks super
scary for black and this is a massive
threat Knight takes Rook would be a
fork how do you deal with this if you
move the Rook away then White's other
Rook can come in or maybe maybe there's
an attack against this piece maybe this
bishop just moves and let's do a count
here right now Tanya in the current
position I need some H help with the
counting hit white has two pieces and
two pawns for a queen so added that all
up eight points for white nine points
for black white is ahead The Rook does
indeed move and now I'm expecting the
bishop to drop back I'm not sure which
Square it will use maybe even this one
on the side of the board but either way
this is going to be crazy Magnus Carson
bringing his aame with opening
preparation here this is AI inspired
this opening Choice okay nice this is
the AI cup is this the first game you
want to say that about or or have we
seen that we've seen a few moves a few
ideas inspired but this is I mean no
human would ever dream of going to into
a mess like this unless they were armed
to the teeth with computer preparation
uhuh yeah and David I I'm still thinking
about how we got here and it all happen
so fast I'm just wondering if it's a
good moment to just back up a little
because Magnus Carlson just sacrificed
the queen in the first 15 moves of the
game so if you just do a little bit of
an action replay slow down and actually
take it all in I will slow down if I can
I mean I still need a lot of time to
work this one out um this position I'm
backtracking now to the end of the
opening uh this position we have seen
earlier today and there Maxim Vash gra
played a very slow move he just pushed
his pawn and defended this Pawn chain
eventually he was in big trouble but
held the draw instead this time he
initiated the chaos it was black to
start this whole process sacrificing a
pawn and uh White took up the challenge
black Sid stepped attacking the White
Knight White's Queen stepped forward and
white even castled Queen side and this
was the moment after grabbing a second
Pawn Magnus got his Queen trapped and
you can be forgiven for thinking this is
a blunder the White Queen lacking
squares now but Magnus had calculated
this he gave up this Queen he took a
piece so this is where the material
imbalance started White's Queen dropped
off he took a second piece black
regained some material and uh here we
see white having this material imbalance
very strong Bishop pair big threats on
the board and several pawns marching
forward and uh let's catch up with the
game position this is where the crazy
night sacrifice happened uh this had to
be played to prevent The Rook check on
the back Rank and now this game has
evolved Magnus does drop his Bishop back
and two pieces two pawns for a queen but
white has control and I think Magnus is
really happy with the outcome so maybe
looking away from Mad yarov in the two
matches that these two have now played I
don't think I've heard you guys said say
sacrifices more often than you have
actually with these two playing against
each other there's been a lot of them
that's true yeah I'd agree with you
there was a queen sacrifice that we had
uh for Bishop and three pawns to start
with and black sacrificed the knight uh
it's been been fire on the board is it a
trend it's definitely a trend and these
two especially the first match between
them a couple of days ago when they were
throwing everything at each other I mean
it was the amount of respect they have
the kind of the amount that they love
chess they're just real purists in the
fact that they just want a fight um they
don't care normally about these draws
now that the results are so important or
at least in the last match that we had
earlier today uh where the results were
key there Maxim was maybe playing with
results in mind playing for the draw but
now the safe kind of the hand is off um
the safety net is gone and it's just all
about the win all about the beauty as
well and uh yeah Maxim's been
sacrificing porn since the start of
today but sacrificing a queen is another
level of course yeah but and even after
that for maxim as well he's been
sacrificing pieces back to get the
position under control but this is
anything but control right you pointed
out the material deficit here it's 8
versus 9 mathematically in terms of
points and usually the evaluation bar
would love the extra points but the fact
that it's giving a slight Edge to
magnus's position it means that peace
activity here is strong enough for the
material deficit the one point count
deficit that Magnus has in the material
imbalance currently uh there's a threat
on the board the E6 Pawn is under Fire
and the maxim needs to take care of that
as white the one thing that I really
want to do is sidestep my king from the
sea line uh there are so many pieces
lined up on this sea line there is a
black queen the Knight the bishop and
the king I think the one move that white
has to take time out for would be king
to be one at some point uh and wow Maxim
just ignores the threat of the E6 pawn
and instead brings up the queen to
create his own ideas yeah black does
have a queen after all she's fighting
against two Bishops and two pawns uh but
if she ever gets active we will know the
might of queens and I don't think white
should get tempted to take this Pawn
with his Rook at least because trading
pieces will only help the black queen uh
give her more life give her more
activity and also this deadly pin that
Tanya mentioned uh this will be fatal
taking the pawn with the bishop is maybe
the other tempting move but here black
will give up the piece black will give
up rook for the bishop and uh at the
very end I think this pin again will be
decisive for example black can remove
the defender of this Knight next move
white will lose either one or maybe even
both of these two pieces Magnus
therefore does not get tempted he backs
up his rook and uh this does give Maxim
the time to go back defend this E6 Pawn
that we were trying to take and your
move on the board again Tanya you've got
the crystal ball out your PR in the
future White's King just s side steps
always I always recommend it if you
Castle queenside in any game take
another timeout to shuffle your king to
the corner Maxim actually does the same
he puts the black king in the corner out
of the eyeline of White's Bishop this is
the Calm before the storm in this game
well I mean there's already been one
storm there's going to be a hurricane in
the next few moves uh but yeah it feels
like both players just setting up their
pieces nicely uh just keeping them safe
and it's just about who can make
progress over the next few moves who can
uh start the attacks yeah and well King
B1 was an easy predict you want to Sid
step any ideas of the pin starting from
now on it's going to be really hard to
predict any move in this position uh
because it's so imbalanced and so
Dynamic but it's very important for
Magnus to play energetically because if
he allows the black queen and the Rook
to start combining and the pieces to get
out it could mean a big disaster for
White's King so Magnus has to keep the
tempo going but how does he do that and
he starts with the H Pawn is he eyeing
it advancing all the way up to a six to
open up some diagonals for the dark
squar Bishop we did say this game was
inspired by AI Alpha Zero's favorite
move uh Pawn to H4 just throw this Pawn
as far forward as possible act as a
battering ram create some holes create
some weaknesses around Black's King
black says okay I'll blockade now your
Pawn can St forward but not further than
that and uh very sensible giving the
king some air some breathing space you
mentioned the queen and rook's Tanya the
fact that they cannot move without
getting captured by this white knight is
incredible right now white has a knight
dominating those three pieces
and uh okay maybe at some point black
will be able to give back some material
uh in order to activate the queen but
it's looking impossible right now it's
really kind of sad for Maxi Vash gra
that he has no active piece play he's
just reduced to playing simple porn
moose I'm expecting Magnus to throw more
pawns towards this black king in the
near future and you asked this question
at the start right 5 minutes before the
Grand Final reset what do the players do
I really want to know what did Magnus do
in these five minutes because it feels
like this is a brand new Magnus that
we're seeing today yeah I this opening
Choice it nearly backfired on Maxim Vash
the gra in game uh three I believe of
the match today uh it's a lot of Chess
we've had but I was going to say earlier
I didn't want to sound too harush I was
going to say Jordan van Forest one of
magnus's seconds for the 2020 one world
championship match has played this
several times as black wow and therefore
Magnus will have been aware of it
therefore Magnus will have studied it
and uh know the ins and outs and look at
that twit chat David exactly what you're
saying Magus using leftover prep from
his Nea world championship games yeah
I'm just speculating but it seems very
likely and the fact that Maxim's walking
into that deep dark Forest that clearly
Magnus has uh yeah studied deeply it
shows a lot of Courage but it can also
backfire when you take risks we've seen
it in previous days when you play your
opponent's openings or something that
they know really well you've got to be
ready to be hit by a surprise and
clearly Maxim knew everything up to move
17 18 but since then he's been burning a
lot of time on the clock fash
and his position has not been improving
if anything it's White's position that's
easier to play White has full control
and throwing pawns forward what does
black even do we've said you can't move
pieces without losing material it's a
real dilemma especially with half the
time of his opponent he tries to
activate his Queen in this direction but
this can be shut down firstly the white
pawns can continue marching or the white
knight can Retreat into the center yeah
what Maxim is hoping for is enough time
again to get the pieces into the game so
I think Rook to C8 would be the natural
followup to this uh to this move and
perhaps an eventual sacrifice of
material to neutralize some of the
pressure that we have uh Magnus doesn't
give him the time hits the queen and
defends the F3 Pawn Maxim continues with
the pressure so there's a double attack
in the position Magnus is going for
Maxim's King he doesn't care about the
pawns anymore yeah look at that
centralization we talk about controlling
the center of the board it's like soccer
football where you control the Midfield
you control the game and white pieces in
the middle there that uh that kind of
mass of pieces looks so impressive but
as you say Tanya black is going porn
hunting will he be punished Vash grav on
the camera looks a bit down right now he
really does he it feels as if whoa a
sacrifice from Magnus this time I don't
think this can be taken it's poisoned
but there are tactics in the air I think
Vash gra saw this maybe hence his uh
posture there but let's just explain
this sacrifice you cannot take with a
knight at least uh if you take with a
knight whoops there's a double attack a
fork quite Elementary stuff but next
move the black queen drops off if you
take with a rook then after Rook takes
again it's poisoned you cannot take this
time with the Knight either because yet
again uh this recurring theme of the
fork Magnus trading off his H Pawn which
just dropped on the last turn for
Black's really important E Pawn in the
center looks really logical and now all
sorts of threats against this black
king it's terrifying can you even allow
that Bishop to stay alive that Bishop
lands on D5 I'm hitting your Rook on the
next move look at the two snipers at the
center of the board Bishop lines up on
F5 creating a Kill Zone against Black's
King look at the squares they control
Tanya these two Bishops yeah just
beautiful Bishops and Maxim doesn't
decide to give away some material to
neutralize that Bishop instead jumps in
with the queen to
H2 this is clever at least now the
bishop will hesitate to move because uh
at the very least black could maybe even
chop off this Knight with his rook in
the center now this Rook uh stares at
the Knight the queen stares at at the
night double vision here but what else
to do it looks like you can at the very
least give a check not sure this is
profitable but at least this would cut
out Rook takes Knight in those
variations the black king has to move
and now the white Bishop can step back
to the square you mentioned who do you
prefer here okay he's gone for it
immediately Magnus Carson I was going to
say who do you prefer the might of these
two Bishops uh or the black queen in the
corner and then the maxim just pre moved
because he just put the King on 87
instantly a move that we were looking at
after the check but Maxim plays it
voluntarily and the bar doesn't move
this is crazy maybe Maxine was worried
about some night checks Maybe was
worried about some sacrifices using uh
The Bishop's diagonal here but either
way Mark of Genius these two players
navigating the choppi Seas the choppi
waters you will ever imagine and doing
it so quickly David what is g it s I
mean it's at least you slow down for a
minute that K you were talking about is
this the game with the most number of
sacrifices I think this might have
overtaken the shark game yeah he's
sacrificing his rook in the corner and
then black I think will just simply
recapture and we saw suddenly have to do
a new count it's rook and Bishop and one
pawn two pawns two pawns thank you Tanya
for the queen so actually white would be
one point up here but at least now you
have gotten rid of White's light squ
domination that Bishop maybe is superior
to a rook right now we talk about points
bishop worth three Rook worth five but
actually in this position Bishop looks
much more valuable now there's one main
rule in chess R take Center take center
magnus's pieces they're just so much in
the center why is the bar not more
excited for Magnus well he doesn't have
a queen I guess black does so it's those
two factors white has a bit of material
not enough uh for the queen but the
centralization kind of balances that out
and yeah I mean any other position with
this type of control over the middle of
the board K and white would just be
winning but I think just the black queen
for now holding her own so take Center
and keep her Queen
ideally keeping the queen in general is
a good idea unless you're a genius like
these guys uh unless it's a trade for
the opponent's Queen sacrificing Queens
I think the reason we think it's so
spectacular the reason we're always
amazed is because it happens so rarely
unless these guys are playing and look
at mvl just like stretching just a
normal day at the office just playing
some insane chess here fighting to win
the Grand Final can't believe these guys
so calm so calm and the B drops it sinks
for white after this last move it looks
very logical Magnus now trying to leave
the black king trying to explode the
shelter around it and we see the
computer moves just below the board
there black only has one move but wow
the advantage is growing and now it says
over plus two in Black's favor only if
he finds the move bringing his rook in
the corner to the open C file that would
actually create a devastating threat
maybe Magnus has underestimated the
danger on the white king that might be
uh brewing and of course Maxim finds it
instantly a big check the queen coming
on to C2 is the massive threat now Ma
Magnus has to deal with and he does
shake his head he doesn't have the time
to actually open up Black's King side
because of this new threat the first
threat of the game that Maxim has
created but David we were talking about
this if the queens and The Rook find
their Harmony then magnus's King can be
the one which is in danger suddenly
Queen to C2 check is a killer blow it
would hit the white king and hit the
white Rook for example if white takes
now this would likely end the game black
can happily safely I think take this
rook and white centralized pieces not
enough compensation here and it's not
just that threat Tanya I think what he's
missed maybe Magnus is he doesn't have
time to guard against this check and
stop black from taking this Knight in
the center maybe he should have jumped
out the way with a check earlier because
uh now for example if you drop back your
Bishop to cover this key Square then
Rook takes Knight wins two pieces for
the black rook and here we don't even
need to count black has a queen for just
a rook and a couple of Pawns no more
attack no more danger Magnus might be in
big big trouble right now he for sure
has missed this double attack this
double threat Que to see to killer blow
and it's head in hands for Magnus I
think he realizes it he had done
everything right gotten his opening
preparation this absolutely crazy
position on the board which is exactly
what Magnus was hoping for and then this
last natural move trying to open up your
opponent's king but I think it comes
down to that point that you want to give
that check before get your knight out of
danger and this could prove to be very
costly for Magnus now Maxim down on the
clock but I have a feeling at this
moment it's going to level out yeah one
of my big takeaways from this whole
tournament is that players when they
have their fate in their own hands for
example fed have needed to win the
tournament to have any chance needed to
win division two somehow they rise to
the occasion fed have played his best
chess all week won division two did
everything he needed to do npom Nishi
giri mam jarov they all made it deep
into the tournament because they needed
it to make it to the final and Vash grav
something's inspired him uh this is
another level of Chess from him to be
able to firstly defend that position
position from earlier somehow that black
queen which was paralyzed activating
herself and creating threats it's as if
he's working magic and uh it's all
coming together all on the same day
against the world number one uh this is
just incredible I've been following and
been a maxim fan for a long time and
been watching his games but but this
kind of chest this kind of accuracy this
kind of uh uh just merciless play and
just not only in tactically sharp
position but in strategic battle in
opening battles and the confidence he's
showing I haven't seen this from Maxim
before this has been incredible to watch
it almost feels like the Resurgence like
the French Renaissance all over again
yeah and he is uh well 33 now uh we have
been talking about how he's been
changing up his opening strategy uh
imagine if he had done that played
everything under the sun basically from
when he was a teenager do you think he
could have been maybe a world
championship Challenger in his 20s and
maybe can he be that in the future now
yeah there's still a chance Magnus isn't
playing World Championship matches even
if Magnus was Maxim is showing now he
can hang with him uh when he's at his
best yeah he turns 33 soon and I think
in chess these days this generation
they're still hanging around long enough
it's going to be hard with the new uh
kind of the youngsters the teenagers but
still capable and clearly a Renaissance
I think you can always say I could have
done this I could have improved but
Maxim part of his strengths were his
openings until a certain point when uh
kind of he was just too predictable so
it's it's hard to say but he's doing
everything right right now and that's a
key point he's always been one of the
very best in the world in the world
Elite top 10 for such a long time but it
was his narrow repertoire that kind of
just made it very difficult after a
point to progress to the next level
which for them is of course fighting for
the world championship title M uh I
think he's worked on it the last couple
of years he mentioned it himself during
the pandemic especially tried to change
that up make his openings as versatile
as the rest of his play and we're seeing
these phenomenal results from him I'm
actually really looking forward to
seeing what Maxim and how he performs at
the Grand Su will he make it to the
candidates MH yeah granis is going to be
hard on pretty much all the top players
in the world maybe apart from Magnus
goson will be playing so it's not going
to be easy but people are going to fear
him at least now the way he's been
playing here Fear Factor is huge in open
tournaments and right now he's still
doing everything correct traded off a
set of Rook still in control for black
and this whole scenario it reminds me of
um was it the chessable Masters David
where it was Hikaru Nakamura who came up
from the losers bracket went on to play
Fabiano Carana in the Grand Final took
it to the Grand Final reset and
eventually won the whole thing momentum
maybe there as well the only time this
season we have had a grand final reset
in division one this is the second time
the only time we've seen someone rise
from the losers bracket to win a
tournament yeah yeah and wow okay just
looking below the screen only one move
to keep things alive for Magus Carson
right now it is losing a move his Bishop
just came from the D5 square but he has
to retreat White's light Square Bishop
back to the center uh back to the center
control those squares in the middle is
that natural if you look at this
position as a one-off it is but he
doesn't find it I was going to say the
one thing that will make him not find it
is the fact that his Bishop just came
from that square so it's really hard
psychologically to make uh kind of to
confirm that you've made a mistake to
just Retreat lose two moves and the
reason this is bad is because black
simply picking up an extra pawn and that
forces white to actually come back with
the Knight because now if you go Bishop
to D5 the move that you wanted to make
you end up losing a very key Pawn in the
position so Magnus with that last move I
think what he wanted to do David was to
actually defend that Knight by
retreating it to keep control on the
king side is Knight D4 an option here
yeah it looks very healthy I guess
there's no threat what white has to try
to do is to break through on the H file
this would actually end in Checkmate if
white could safely check but Black's
Queen controls all checking squares and
now Black's Knight will come into the
game and white has lost his
centralization the beautiful
coordination we saw with the pieces in a
little bubble in the middle uh it's
being broken White's light squared
Bishop has moved away needlessly now
this bishop lacking squares it's only
got one safe square and uh the fight
goes on I will say that it's still not
easy but at least Black's Knight can
start activating maybe you go this way
or maybe you go this way into the
position um yeah Magnus he's trying this
Maxi V gra I I'm not trusting the B as
much in a human encounter because it
could easily swing if Magnus coordinates
his pieces against the black king but it
does look like Maxim has survived the
west and we do a quick count now it is a
queen for Just Two Bishops and a pawn
and the more pieces disappear the more
important that material balance will be
I completely agree with your point that
the evalar says that Maxim's completely
winning but it's still a very random
position mistakes can happen especially
when we come down to that one minute
Mark which I think will happen soon as
long as Max seems King is boxed up on
the hline and doesn't have an Escape
Route and there is this threat of The
Rook sliding down with a Checkmate on H1
chances are there because it really ties
down Black's Queen to defend that big
threat on the board uh but how does he
keep the position and the pressure as is
because Maxim is going to try to get out
of that which is why I really like your
suggestion of bringing the Knight
forward and first making sure that that
white Central Bishop gets out of the way
K what you were pointing out the control
over the center has gone for Magnus but
Maxim still has that extra Queen now mhm
yeah and I think that Rook trade Magnus
wanted as many pieces on the board as
possible the fact that one set of Rooks
has disappeared means that checkmating
Black's King is going to be far more
difficult and that's not a good sign for
white I'm expecting Maxim to activate
the Black Knight maybe in two different
directions he's just picking between uh
between those The Black Queen cannot
move she cannot allow a check from
White's Rook on H1 the black Rook
doesn't really want to move necessarily
it looks like it's on a perfect square
uh so process of elimination it's either
the Knight or pawns wow pushes forward
setting a trap such concrete play by
Maxim he's just always going for the
most direct line given the opportunity
and I think that is the kind of approach
that you need when you're playing
against uh Magnus the more I look at
this move the more I like it and it
wasn't even something that came into my
mind to be to be completely honest he
wants to pick up the E4 Pawn with a
check now yeah I was going to say
setting a trap but actually maybe Magnus
has got a bit lucky here he can move his
King safely the white Bishop the white
Dart Square Bishop is poisoned black
cannot take it because The Black Queen
would suddenly lose control over the
corner Square the H1 square and White's
Rook would swing and Checkmate Black's
King so black the queen here is actually
a bit stuck um I think he was trying to
trick Magnus in the process maybe
missing something himself I'm not sure
this exchange this transition is
actually helped black that much WoW uh
really interesting we've been talking
about black king stuck in a mating net
and that might be the one thing that
keeps Magnus alive in this game and this
is a best of two right so it's so
important with the white pieces to at
least find a way to get out of this uh
without a loss for Magnus cuz the next
game he starts with black m yeah
suddenly what do does Maxim play just to
show this variation on the board this
bishop cannot be captured suddenly we
would see Checkmate next move uh the
black queen would have to throw herself
in the way now but this is Checkmate
look how the white Bishop covers all of
the Escape squares for this King and if
you cannot take this bishop what do you
do y move earlier Knight D7 maybe bring
the Knight out I'm not sure which
direction Knight to D7 kicking this
bishop yeah makes a lot of sense the
Bish does have one safe Square he moves
his Rook across he's trying to pin and
win here Maxim also makes a lot of sense
and how does Magnus untangle his pieces
suddenly everything's hanging in midair
can you actually start with the same
threat go Rook D2 and start threatening
a mage from the H2 Square I think he
would love to the problem right now is
Rook D2 I mean this is what he wants to
do you're right Tanya he would love to
give Checkmate this would be winning for
white unfortunately just about covering
the square now the bishop can be
captured Magnus has to arrange this in
the right order not easy to do this yeah
it's hanging by a thread this one could
be decided in the next two or three
moves despite the bar saying it's less
dangerous for white in Practical terms
he's still balancing on the edge of a
knife how do you get the Rook to the H
line I'm just thinking a way David
because that's what's on magnus's radar
as well right now to create that threat
yeah he needs to get his Rook to this
square but it is covered still we need
help let's ask the engine yet again it's
that type of position it's so irrational
Queen for two Bishops and while Magnus
has a very AR path to survival actually
if he doesn't find the best move or
maybe the second best move he is toast
he is doomed and the best move is so
difficult it looks like this bishop is
cutting off the black King's Escape
squares but you have to retreat it to
defend your Rook allowing Queen takes
Bishop because this is so unnatural
because now you can jump in with a fork
and this is not going to happen surely
Tanya uh for example we could see an end
game Rook takes Rook black giving back
the queen but it is only black who can
win here with a rook versus a bishop ah
I think this is actually losing this end
game I don't think Magnus is ever going
to play the best move here the second
one maybe on the board Rook to F1 this
is more likely I agree with you I like
that move because it does set up the
idea of going with that Rook even
further to F5 and then the threat of
getting it to H5 Rook F1 definitely
feels like the more human approach but
Magnus is really good with finding
retreating moves so I think he will find
that move Bishop to B3 the First Choice
by the engines but that answering end
game that we just saw I think it'll be
the evaluation of that end game that'll
make him not want to he finds that move
Magnus okay he plays Rook to F1 so yeah
the second recommended the move there
minimizing the damage and black still
cannot go and take the dart Square
Bishop this would end in Checkmate if
black takes twice on the Square the
White Knight stands on as well Rook
takes and then the queen takes also this
Checkmate Black's King is caught in a
box in a mating net uh so the black
queen still frozen in the center I like
this move from Magnus I think in
Practical terms it still asks some big
questions and uh as tan pointed out
trying to get over to that H file uh if
any check is the end of the game Rook F
five is a big threat The Rook lift
trying to get the Rook to that H line uh
Black's got to try to fight against that
you have to fight against that check
mating idea and it is coming for you
David do you see a way for maxim to keep
up the pressure and Maxim goes in with
the queen so his idea is that after if
you do go up with The Rook to F5 how is
he fighting check right I think he has
to push a pawn Black's G Pawn can cover
some squares but the evaluation bar
doesn't approve and I don't like it
either it feels unnatural I think Maxim
is stunned to panic because of the clock
the queen was centralized we talked
about centralization a lot this game but
Queen's in the middle of the board
control everything uh that Queen was
hitting pieces it was controlling
squares from afar uh I think Maxim is
actually losing a bit of control by
playing this move yes it's a one move
threat but the white Rook wanted to move
anyway and okay it's one minute each I
don't even know who the favorite is
anymore I think this one could still go
in all three directions it felt like it
was a two result game once Maxim got his
pieces coordinated but Magnus is back
into it and he does threaten a Checkmate
in one on the board Rook H5 a big threat
Maxim he will uh play the move G6 if you
take on G4 I think the material
imbalance just works out in White's
favor in this end game you end up with
two pieces for a rook and that's a happy
happy trade for white yeah so what's he
even thinking about Maxim under one
minute now he has to play this move
otherwise he's losing what think he has
to prevent this Checkmate idea of The
Rook swinging across okay he does play
it eventually Magnus will most likely
shift his Rook up one square and he's
getting active at least he's going to
maybe take this pawn and go around but
now it gets really random yeah both
players under a minute and the position
is absolutely wild one bad move one
inaccuracy from either of these two
players and it could be game over I
think yeah I think we will see a blunder
to end this it just feels like that type
of position and to toally understandable
forgivable in any uh for any human to go
astray it's just so weird this position
I mean it's just like their games from
two days ago irrational crazy what other
adjectives can I find for beautiful
beautiful genius yeah okay he takes a
porn Maxim greed he hopes is good here
attacking White's Knight as well in the
center I like that because if white was
to take that A6 Pawn I think Maxim would
be happy to give up The Rook for the two
pieces and Magnus still keeping the
pressure on the king brings back the
Knight Maxim as well with the tempo
attacking that Knight not allowing white
any checks on the board and wow look at
that white only has one move otherwise
the advantage grows to plus six for
black and that move is never ever going
to be played I can guarantee it Magnus
is not going to drop his Knight back to
a square it can be captured I think Vash
grab is going to win this one wow Knight
D2 that makes no sense never going to be
played it literally hangs the knight in
one which means that Maxim is very close
to taking this one if Knight D2 is the
best move in this position to me it
looks like white is busted yeah White's
pieces just cannot deliver the killer
blow cannot deliver a check therefore
one of them will fall they have no
coordination this is where you need a
queen or you need some pawns to hold
things together seconds for Magnus look
at him he's so frustrated right now he's
looking for something that doesn't exist
he drops his Bishop back this is
desperation this bishop is hanging does
black just simply capture it I think you
can take this piece and then you pick up
the Knight watch out there was a check
could he have take he probably couldn't
have cuz Black's Queen was coming in
with a check and it would be checkm on
white Magnus doesn't have time to
capture on f8 because of Queen C4 check
yeah black has to move the Queen White
is actually threatening checkmate with a
rook slide into the corner but black has
the move he does give the check and it's
actually we mentioned earlier the first
one to deliver a deadly check will win
this game but David the good news for
white is that the bishop can slide back
all the way to B2 to guard any checks on
the second rank here it's all about the
material it's Queen for Bishop and
Knight and yes white can block the
Checkmate prevent the Checkmate but
Black's king is not getting trapped
anymore it's actually an attacking piece
I think he can even just give up his
Queen for that Knight you can pick up
the rook and the Knight by sacrificing
your queen Maxim he may or may not go
for that but it feels like that should
be enough as well with the gonn marching
down the board he goes for it Maxim Vash
graph and Magnus is on his last legs now
that black Gorn is going to become a new
Queen nothing to do about it Bishop
clearly inferior to the black rook and
Maxim just has to be slightly careful 14
seconds
just I like this move beautiful
centralization shoulders off White's
King and there's nothing that can stop
the G Pawn from queening Maxim is
winning this one go back with the Rook
defend the queen he might yes he does it
he does it White's Pawn stopped Black's
Pawn about to become a new Queen Maxim
takes the lead Magnus Carlson throws
himself back loses another game to this
fantastic man Maxim vajra wins another
game he takes the lead in The Grand
Final reset he is now one game away from
winning the AI cup making just a massive
performance here at the Frenchman he is
on fire today just amazing this was so
reminiscent of the games in their first
match it was absolutely wild from the
start Magnus got the kind of position
that he was hoping for the material
imbalance and it looked like it was
going to be magnus's game but again
Maxim so resourceful uh just incredible
stuff an absolute roller coaster and wow
Maxim's doing today what I think few
could have ever imagined or believed in
yeah incredible stuff they now have five
minutes now less than five minutes for
that final rapid game to decide the
Grand Final if Maxim wins or it's a draw
he will win the AI cup Magnus has to win
that game to take it to a final
Armageddon so four minutes now until
that game so let's dive into this
incredible game that we just saw David
yeah what a battle what a game from
literally move one from start to finish
it was crazy first opening preparation
both players coming well armed and
eventually ending in that queen versus
pieces imbalance and it was here that
Magnus made the final mistake the final
blunder that allowed black to win he
retreated his Knight but suddenly
realizing after the black Rook enters
that this Knight has no good squares to
use and black eventually converted a
material advantage If instead Magnus had
brought his Knight the other way the
other direction to attack the black Rook
we might have seen the game go on
suddenly white Rook able slide back and
if anyone's King is in more danger it
might even be blacks a level position
all three results possible and this
would have been a dramatic end to the
game instead it was Vash grav who took
the win is it Maxim on fire today is it
Magnus not at his best or is it both
both it feels like Magnus got out of bed
on the wrong side or something slightly
off not just not quite sharp not quite
quick as uh he usually is but Maxim I
mean we should not take anything at all
away from him he's been just on fire
from move one today I agree with David
Magnus even when he's not at his best
he's still the best player in the world
so you really have to get your aame on
and take the opportunity when you get it
and that's what Maxim has done from the
start of the day he takes the first set
and he takes the lead in the second one
as well against the well many might say
the goat um Magnus Carlson and it's uh
it's just incredible to watch it and he
needs only a draw now Kaa to make it to
Toronto with the white pieces with the
white pieces and what should we expect
now from Maxim I think more of the same
exactly what he did in the final game of
the first match uh before the reset I
think he'll just play one E4 he'll sit
he'll try and Bully Magnus with this
with the idea of a draw how frustrated
you think Magnus is right now with the
way the day has gone because he's so
critical of himself and always so
emotional about these uh these games and
this result what do you think is going
on in his mind right now frustration uh
Magnus is great at bouncing back he's
probably better than anyone else in
history and it does take two players to
make a great match so I still feel he
has something up his sleeve he will try
and mix it up um I think he's going to
play better in this last game than he
has in the last couple but it's still
uphill struggle winning with black you
can never guarantee it yeah can you guys
believe it this is uh the final rapid
game in the regular portion of the
Champions chess tour 2023 coming up only
the tour finals left not only will this
game maybe decide the winner of the
tournament if we don't have an
Armageddon it's also going to decide who
goes to Toronto if it is a win or a draw
for MV he is going to Toronto he will
grab that final ticket fedos seev
watching this now he must be feeling
quite nervous as well rooting for Magnus
Carlson I think the only man more
frustrated than Magnus Carlson right now
in the Chess World is FV watching that
game thinking it could have gone either
way it was 50/50 for so long and uh to
see Maxim take it he's going to be
hoping he's going to be nervous but I
think for chess fans across the world
including fedos this is such an
incredible match to see play out and uh
to see Maxim perform at this level to
see the kind of fights that we're
getting by both these players these
insane positions I think fos yes he's
rooting for Magnus but he's also really
enjoying the chess that we've got on the
board yeah and Maxim mentioned to us in
the interview yesterday that well uh
chess is popular in France he said maybe
not as popular as in Norway do you think
there's and please share with us if you
are in France and rooting for ML right
now I mean the French fans must be going
crazy over this there are a lot of
French fans the federation's growing
it's been a game on the up for a long
time they've got so many young Grand
Masters coming through clearly Maxim was
one of The Inspirations for that he's
been the top player of this uh
generation um yeah World force and only
going to grow and I think for so many
years so many of us in the Chess World
actually expected Maxim to challenge
Magnus for the world championship title
mhm but it's difficult the candidates
are so tough and it's uh never happened
although I think it was 2021 when Maxim
was leading it halfway through uh from
the first half of the candidates and it
felt like he was such a favorite but he
hasn't really gotten the job done and uh
again just incredible to see him play at
this level that he's performing in this
entire tournament the first match
between them really set the tone it sent
out the signal that it's not going to be
easy and yeah it's been just amazing to
watch this happen he's playing the chess
of his life Maxim vaj he is one rapid
game away from winning the AI cup
luckily we made a big bowl of popcorn
this is the last of it I'm just keeping
it here with me you guys have to analyze
you have to take us through the
marvelous chess coming up right now it's
game two in the Grand Final reset and
MV he has been oh look at that Magnus
Carlson is still frustrated this is live
of Magnus that is an angry Magnus gu wow
and I mean he needs to put this behind
him now he is playing another game I've
not seen him like this because the guy
never loses and he's lost twice today
yeah and this frustration bringing this
into a must-win game for him yeah a
second time today it's a must-win game
with black and that shows how much it
means to Magnus he wins everything and
uh we take it for granted that he's kind
of just cruising through but it's the
passion it's determination is how much
he wants to win and yeah still beating
himself up he has to forget because the
game's starting now and I think for
anyone thinking that he's not motivated
to win this one cuz he he's already
through to Toronto what we just saw on
the screen it just shows how much this
means to him mhm and here we go the
final rapid game in the AI Cup mvl draw
or win he wins the AI cup Magnus has to
win to take daragon take us through it
good news for Magnus Carlson and for all
the fans at home it's an open Sicilian
that means it's going to be exciting
guaranteed no matter what very few Force
drawing lines in this one uh a lot of
pieces going to remain on the board for
a long time the pawn structure is going
to be different Magnus here playing the
KH variation I believe uh pushing his
Pawn forward to A6 not deciding yet
where to bring the Black Knights out to
and Maxim Vash gra I'm surprised he went
for this opening I've got to admit
probably a Rosal Lio keeping things more
claw the CLA Sicilian was something that
we'd be expecting but Maxim he's been
showing that he wants to play
objectively where he feels is his best
chance and he goes for an open cillan
which will give magnus's chances but
looking at magnus's camera it feels like
he's not only battling the board but
also his own mind right now yeah and
Maxim needs to try and strike while
Magnus is still uh composing himself
while he's still a bit distracted with
the earlier games the earlier play now
black is going for a hedgehog formation
something I know you love uh Tanya white
here has what we call the maroxy bind
white has pawns on the E4 squares C4
squares trying to clamp down preventing
any pawn breaks but black is rock solid
black is really really flexible and I
know Magnus quite likes these positions
as well we've seen him play these
positions in the Champions Jester with
some great results and again it's all
about flexibility of plans for black ha
so you keep white kind of guessing of
where you're really headed the first
question is where does Magnus developed
the Bishop from f8 Bishop to E7 is the
normal course where you place it in
front of the king the Deep pawn moves
one step forward then you decide where
you want to develop your queen side
Knight and Magnus makes the first well
it's not the most popular approach in
this position uh the slightly less
played Bishop to D6 It lines up with the
queen with the direct threat against the
H Pawn and the reason that this move
isn't played as often is because you
want to push that D Pawn to the square
that the bishop has just taken to
complete your development of the Queens
side pieces yeah it feels like Magnus is
trying to surprise Maxim take him out of
any potential preparation here uh as you
say not playing the most common first
move but there is a threat uh to take
White's Pawn on H2 with a check and
Maxim has to react he's giving him
decisions again that's something you
need to do when you want to win you keep
piece on the board you give your
opponent three or four choices every
move and um something you've said
throughout this uh this tournament Tanya
every kind of game is decided by
incremental mistakes and you just have
to hope that giving your opponent
decision after decision after decision
will uh slowly turn things in your favor
and that's the thing that works for
Magnus really well because he's the
player who can make maximum number of
accurate best moves move after move uh
and very often for his opponents they
just collapse after some point and in
this one U Magnus again doing that
approach where he gives decisions
provoking Maxim to push pawns on the
king side which later on can become some
sort of a target for black he does use
the pin the bishop goes to the C5 Square
to pin up the Knight U Maxim continuing
with development to stop that a lot of
uh forcing moves being played here by
both players a lot of forcing moves and
the big question is who it really favors
it feels like Magnus has lost a bit of
time magnus's dark Square Bishop has
moved twice and it will get traded off
so it might even move for a third time
in the next few turns and Maxi meanwhile
has gained a lot of space with the white
pawns talk about central control like we
have been doing white has beautiful
control over the center here still
roughly in the balance but I think I
would take white here Tanya and uh for
Magnus Carlson that's not a great sign
he's still very cramped lacking porn
breaks lacking any potential attackers
against the white
king yes and he needs to decide where to
place his own King as well you want to
go towards the king side Castle towards
the king side but that could also mean
uh a certain attacks that you have to
watch out for once the White Queen lands
on the king side there are two parts to
do this in in these kind of positions
the White Queen can go from F3 and then
uh go over to the other side of the
board Maxim chooses the other one he
starts with queen to D2 instead uh David
connecting the two Rooks it just feels
like whites managed to get the harmony
within the pieces and that D6 Pawn the D
line that you're highlighting right now
is a long-term point of contention wow
yeah I was expecting the white Rook to
land there he uses another Square
hinting that he might want to propel
some pawns forward later on Maxim's
Rooks uh look really nice here
supporting these far Advanced pawns and
watch out for a pawn storm in the center
as black what does black even do you're
the uh Queen of the Hedgehog I'm
form a lot of pressure right now to
predict magnus's and Maxim's next move
but I'm going to try now usually what
black really wants is to force white to
take on C5 because that helps you with
your structure and the first move that I
would be thinking about here is actually
making that happen with the knight from
F6 jumping on to G4 I'm glad to see the
Valar not react to that my idea is that
if you take on C5 there are two very uh
uh tempting ways to capture it but I I
think I think I would I would want to
take it with the B Pawn and the reason
for that is that I want to stop your E
Pawn moving up the board to E5 control
that I've improved my Center improved my
chances of a attack along the B line and
I would be the one who's happier with
this trade than white so night G4 would
be on my radar in this position yeah I
love it Tanya uh just always looking up
for Pawn structure go for it you called
it that is uh the stamp of approval from
the world the biggest stamp of approval
and this position on the board okay he
takes with a deep on I'm surprised as
well especially in positions where you
need to win kind of imbalancing the porn
structure here kind of having the
central porn mass for black looks really
nice and healthy instead it's a slightly
more symmetrical Pawn structure but he's
banking maybe on the open file it looks
very tempting for white to step forward
in the center uh kind of creating nice
squares nice inroads into the black camp
but uh black Rooks will centralize and
at least some open file some activity
for Magnus uh I think he would love as
well uh just to occupy this Square later
on with the piece the question is what
happens if white kicks you back I'm not
even going to answer that because I'm
going to pass that question to Magnus
I'm not sure whether the Knight goes
back in this direction or even maybe
this direction just because I'm scared
of getting hit kicked around the board
but uh yeah that's the question for him
right now he's created some imbalance
and that's step one in a must-win
situation yeah that's the problem I got
one move right but not the second one uh
but Magnus here I think he's doing what
needs to be done to create his chances
he's opened up the D line as your
pointing out and it looks like Black's
rook and queen will be the one that's
closer to getting to that open file uh
very good point there made by you that
after white does kick out that knight
from G4 you probably do want to get it
to the edge of the board it's not the
general advice in chess but here it's
all about making sure that you don't
lose out on tempos and allowing white to
push those Central pawns with Tempo
would be very dangerous that would just
be asking for trouble because once E5
happens the white knight from C3 also
lands on e4 it's not only an attacking
move towards the kide David but it gives
a really strong hold on that D6 Square
yeah this is a big hole in the black
position this Square because you have no
Dart Square Bishop you have no pawns
that can control it so it's an outpost
for white Knights black needs to fight
against this maneuver so that's what I'm
expecting from Vash the gra I'm
surprised he's pausing uh either Pawn to
E5 or first a kickback on the Knight one
of those two moves would be the most
logical and uh black would have to react
but Magnus Carson do you think he's got
it out of his system yet no no I've been
looking at his camera he looks
frustrated he looks uh not too happy
with himself I don't think it's out of
his system yeah that's and I'm not an
expert but I'm just looking at him I
think on the plus side for Magnus is
maybe he's so angry right now that he's
playing quickly uh the adrenaline's
pumping he's really kind of forced
himself to um to wake up speed up yeah
and also for maxim he's so close now to
just a huge tournament victory for him
in his career at this point in his life
how hard is it to just sit there and
like focus on the next move next move
next move and not be like ooh if I win
this I'm going to post this on Instagram
and you know that's what I think about
when I'm playing
tournament but you're you're absolutely
right I don't I don't think that even
Maxim thought about getting this far
when the tournament started uh it's his
one shot to make it he has to go all the
way through and then most probably beat
Magnus Carlson who will make it through
to the finals these are thoughts that
probably didn't even cross his mind and
here he is he's done it in the Grand
Final and looking close to do it in the
Grand Final reset it's uh it's a sign of
a champion that he doesn't let it get to
his head right now and he's focusing on
the moves and so far Kaya he's doing
he's making all the right ones on the
board so I think he's not thinking about
the
Instagram
yet are you guys thinking about it what
will you post after this I'll post
something with you guys the ladies in
ladies in red yes full disclosure David
was playing that song uh in the studio
before we went live it was very nice
yeah yeah we we've had a really nice
Friday pizza party popcorn and first of
all amazing chess incredible chess I
mean it takes two to tango this has been
an incredible match uh throughout the
week when they first played a couple of
days ago and today uh both have
contributed equally I think for Magnus
of frustration is not only about what
happened in the last game but what's
been happening throughout the day uh in
match one as well it was the most non-
Magnus chest that I have seen now in
each of the games even in the ones where
he had the advantage and the ones where
he got into trouble usually with M I
think was it Alexander alakan who said
for whom it was said you have to beat
him in the opening in the middle game
and the end game I mean it's true of any
top player these days it's true but I
feel like for Magnus you have to beat
him in all these three on every single
move uh but today Magnus has been off
for for
from the very start and even when he
wins matches he's so critical of his
shape he's so um uh you know he always
talks about the quality of his Play Over
the score line that the day ended with
and I think there's a lot of frustration
with the chess that he played today
starting from uh round one yeah starting
from game one when Magnus could have
actually forced a draw instead losing in
an end game really unlike him and uh
from then things have spiraled that
being said the more I look at this
position the more Maxim Vash gra was
thinking uh the more optimistic I would
be feeling as black because White had no
obvious moves there and the one thing
the last thing you can allow is Black's
Knight on the edge of the board coming
back into the center and uh Maxim Vash
gra now he's ready to take that Knight
if it ever lands on the F5 Square he's
putting his Rooks back in the center
kind of Rec correcting their position
sometimes you have to admit you've put a
piece on the wrong square and you have
to improve it take the time out to do so
and I like his last move but it cost him
a bit of time cost him about 2 3 minutes
and yeah as Magnus I would be a bit more
optimistic now at least he's not going
to get checkmated I don't think white
has the ammunition for that um the space
issue here isn't so drastic for black
and it's a lot to do with that D4 Square
as well which doesn't really allow
White's knight from C2 to jump into
activity so ideas like from Knight to C2
to E3 to going over to the king side uh
and getting rid of a key defender on the
king side is not going to happen because
black has this jump with the Knight to
D4 uh these kind of positions David I
agree with you that black has got
reasons to feel like the opening is gone
his way right now you've developed all
your pieces the night from 86 is the
only problem piece in the position for
black but the other good news is that
white doesn't have at least for me the
idea of G4 G5
is it's a bit much because you really
open up this A8 H1 diagonal giving a
long-term longterm play to what Black's
Queen and Bishop that can line up to
deliver checkmate but with not G4 G5 can
you really take advantage of Black's
Knight at the edge of the board probably
not I mean this Knight will try and jump
in later it cannot now just to show uh
it will get eliminated and it's not just
the fact that it's traded off ruining
the black pawn structure it's more that
white creates cares out and outpost for
his own Knight hitting the queen maybe
even picking up a Pawn on the next move
uh so black can't jump in yet with the
Knight but I'm wondering Tanya uh you
mentioned one move if the white knight
jumps away how does ma Maxim react okay
he's played it on the board Knight takes
Knight Magnus is going for it now he's
trying to change the pawn structure he's
got a pass Pawn on D4 and he's also
corrected the position of this Knight
the poor Knight on the edge he's
bringing it in there's a threat of a KN
Fork hitting the two white Rooks
therefore one of the Rooks moose shifts
up maybe Maxim is going for checkmate
after all maybe he's trying to shift the
Rook to go for this weak spot uh the
kind of the Achilles heal in Black's
position the H7 square but black does
have a beautiful Knight about to jump in
Suddenly It's yeah it's like a wave it's
kind of crash cring against the Rocks
but uh that's good for Magnus it doesn't
mean it the position is dry anymore it
means there's life and Knight E3 on the
radar wow what do we think here the
position has completely changed in the
last few moves and there's a big threat
that white has the one that you pointed
out just two moves right Rook H3 Queen
H5 and then you're threatening a deadly
mate on H7 uh you never want to really
make a move like H6 to defend that David
because it will invite a lot of tactics
eventually if the white knight jumps
onto F6 and I think that's the reason
why Max Magnus has decided to actually
trade the bishop for the Knight on e4
because now it's just so much easier to
guard the king side you'll always have
the option to go G6 or H6 at the right
moment uh to stop any attack on this
diagonal as you're pointing out but for
Magnus it is all about the D Pawn giving
him the E3 square and a long-term passer
also play along the sea line the C4 Pawn
is a weakness that white needs to watch
out for which is what doesn't allow
white to trade the the light squ Bishop
with the Knight on F5 that's right and
he's thinking right now Vash de gra
maybe he'll take with the bishop uh but
then the Black Knight will move it won't
allow itself to get traded and suddenly
yeah it is black with the better pieces
suddenly especially this night it's what
did you call it yesterday a kraken a
kraken that's Peter Sidler that is a
kraken right there a kraken yeah this is
a monstrous night with a lot of power
and Magnus he's turning the screw now
it's more strategic it's a slower type
of position no chaos like the previous
game uh the previous two games even and
uh yeah Magnus this is where he really
thrives it's as if the anger somehow is
driving him and it's calmed him down
he's going back to basics this is Magnus
as he kind of uh just as he cruises just
simple strategic position yeah it's like
that Beast right a wounded Beast is even
more dangerous because uh wounded Kraken
yeah this one would be a big big Kraken
a mythical creature which is
extraordinary power if that Knight does
get to the E3 square but for Magnus k we
were talking about you know what's his
mindset he's feeling the frustration and
we saw all those emotions right at the
start of the game but it really feels
like he has used that to actually fuel
himself for this game and he's the one
who is in uh driver's seat right now
with the black pieces creating all these
chances and this is I think one of the
qualities out of the many that separates
him from the
rest yeah both of them have really high
ceilings I think out of the players just
below Magnus gson Vash gra is one of
those who has this ceiling when he's on
form I mean he can play like this uh but
sometimes less consistent and it's nice
to see him being uh yeah just putting
things together just being in the zone
constantly this game however the clock
times it's normally Magnus who's been
lower throughout the day for the first
time really he's been kind of upping the
pace upping the speed and it's Vash gra
who's maybe it's the nerves maybe it's
the kind of momentous occasion getting
to him I was just going to say that do
you think that's the reason this whole
matth situation is getting to him right
now what he's sck sacrific to Bishop
he's going for checkmate Checkmate but
it doesn't work but why is he sacrificed
this the black king hasn't escaped
square and Magnus immediately blunders
back apparently is there a forc draw
because white is a piece down he's
threatening Rook to F6 David yeah he's
threatening to give a nasty check with
the white Rook suddenly this game is
sprung to life out of nowhere out of the
blue and maybe Vash grab his well
according to the bar at least holding
with this Counterattack while Magnus
thinks in this position can we just do a
quick replay of the last three moves cuz
uh beep hit the fan yeah something went
down here it was all about a sacrifice
before it's too late this Rook was
attacked nice way of putting that Tanya
he gave up this bishop and it shouldn't
work after a check actually it was in
this position Magnus with 9 minutes on
the clock could have sealed the win if
he just pushed his Pawn forward one
square rather than two the difference
being that in this position white does
not have the time to bring his Rook up
the board because now black uh I was
going to say can take this Pawn but no
that isn't the computer move apparently
this is very different after the Black
Knight takes this Rook I think we'll see
something very similar in the game let's
try and investigate the difference in
the current game position Black's Knight
can actually take another piece but
suddenly the White Queen dropped back
with a check and look there's nowhere to
go it's a draw King to E7 and its
Checkmate if black goes back it's a draw
and that's enough of asra a repetition
of the position this is the threat Queen
to G6 this would force a draw and Ma
Maxim would win the tournament
how does he defend against this Magnus
Carlson this is why actually he needed
the pawn back on F6 go that is
incredible that's incredible and this is
what just makes makes T so hard right
you've got these two pawn moves to fight
against the maid and that is the
difference between a win and a draw and
in this case it's the difference between
a championship right now F6 would have
won Magnus the game but the one that he
chose the decision that he made it looks
like his best option would now just be
to to take the rook and go into a
repetition yeah just to show this again
it's literally a coin toss it's heads or
tails you have to move this Pawn one
square or two uh to stop your king
getting checkmated you need to give it
some breathing space Max Magnus
immediately pushed his Pawn forward to
F5 but the detail would have been here
uh just to show it once again now Knight
takes Rook is possible because after the
White Queen drops back with a check it's
no longer possible to play Queen takes
E6 Checkmate there's a pawn in the way
on F6 and uh now for example after Quint
born black could block with his rook and
black would have an extra Rook extra
Knight and win the game now Magnus
facing this devastating tournament
ending threat of Queen to G6 and there's
nothing to do there's nothing to do
because Queen G6 is a massive threat uh
threatening Checkmate or a repetition
there and uh you said it's a coin toss
between two moves but at this level it's
got to be just calculation right had
Magnus just slowed down he would have
definitely seen this Magnus in this
position he played F5 instantly did not
even pause and uh yeah with something's
up today but with more time on his clock
with 9 minutes he should have been able
to find Pawn to F6 it's not obvious we
do have the uh evaluation bar here so we
did see it swing immediately we saw the
truth but um Magnus he could have
calculated it as you say Tanya and now
suddenly I think he was just looking at
this threat but maybe forgetting with
the tournament situation A draw is
enough for white going to G6 devastating
and is it too late now David is there
anywh for black to actually keep the
game going I don't see it it's really
really risky to keep the game going the
problem is you can't really run with the
King either if you try starting to run
with your king after a check maybe this
is the best bet but I was going to say a
check here and look how this white Rook
plays A Part suddenly if the king
continues its Journey then Rook takes
pawn and the black king in huge trouble
yes you've got an extra Knight but white
has three pawns maybe four pawns soon
and an ongoing attack maybe this is the
best bet this I think this is going to
happen Magnus has slowed down he's
calculating a way to not end the game
immediately and it feels like the king
run is the only way even if it means an
objectively worse end game you're up a
piece for four pawns you still fight it
out there are still chances there still
some chances the one thing he cannot do
let's repeat it Knight takes Rook Being
Greedy would not work out Queen check
would force a repetition of moves and
let's go back to Magnus Caron four
minutes
now it is the kind of position K you
could have 30 minutes on the clock and
it doesn't matter because you have to
make a decision that you're not going to
be happy with is it a blunder Magnus
Carlson has blundered Queen takes C4
but why is this a blunder we have to
work it out White's going to give a
check look at Maxim frowning as well
he's like are you sure check to go back
to E8 you can't go to E7 because of
Queen G is this game over black is
getting checkmated look at Magnus
Carlson he knows it even a rook trade
will not save black here Rook takes Rook
is met by the white porn in the center
recapturing and black has no checks
black has no counterplay it's going to
be Checkmate Maxim's going to win the AI
Cup oh my god do you think Magnus is GNA
play this out or will he just resign
look at that
oh he's distraught Magnus
Carson massive frustration he is about
to lose the Grand Final Magnus
Carlson and look at Maxim he knows he's
done it ka yeah that is tension leaving
Maxim's body right now he can relax
because he's done the hard work
Checkmate is guaranteed there's nothing
to do black cannot defend this position
will we see Magnus hit the resign button
I think so we might see a Checkmate on
the board there liter no way to fight
white is threatening to play Rook takes
Rook a trade of Rooks would allow the
white ewn to join the join the battle
and maybe even become a new Queen yeah
and MV is starting to let the emotions
come to him he is starting to realize he
is the winner Maxim vajra the Frenchman
he wins the AI cup he banks the ticket
to Toronto he is going to the tour
finals he does the impossible he beats
Magnus Carlson in two matches on fire
what an incredible
performance and he must be so happy and
how happy are you for unbelievable I
mean what a performance by Maxim vasher
lra Magnus Carlson the strongest player
in the world his chess is out of this
world but today Maxim was the one it was
his day K beat Magnus twice on the same
day in a match play format I I don't
think anyone would have bet against
Magnus today this has been incredible
and a big congratulations to Maxim the
only path to Toronto and he grabs that
ticket describe to us David what you
think about what you've seen from mvl
not only today but in this tournament
yeah I'm pleased for him back to his
best he looks happy he looks in the zone
in top form uh just incredible chess as
well thank you for entertaining us Maxim
uh I mean well play to Magnus as we as I
mentioned earlier takes two to tango and
uh it was actually this position that
Magnus uh did did let things slip Maxim
went all in it was a bit of a gamble it
turned out that this move is objectively
incorrect but Maxim he had the courage
and Fortune favored him here sacrifice
of the bishop the White Queen coming in
threatening a nasty Checkmate but now
Magnus could have clinched Victory and a
comeback with Pawn to F6 as we showed
earlier he went with the pawn to the
wrong square and we saw the white Rook
come in the reason he resigned after
this check and a capture is because
Checkmate is unavoidable if Rook takes
Rook for example the white p replaces
The Rook threat of Checkmate on E7 if
black guards that with a knight then
white makes a second Queen a check a
check and this would have been the end
Magnus resigned Maxim takes the
tournament he wins the AI cup he is
ready for Toronto Maxim
vajra massive congratulations on this
win yeah thank you I mean it was a very
exhausting week I think it shows I can
imagine and please take us into your
head and your heart right right now how
are
you um mostly exhausted actually so like
really um sometimes when you put so much
energy into something like there's
no uh I mean I realize I won but I will
uh realize it better in a few few hours
I think like right now I this was again
like such an intense weekend such an
intense two matches also
today and Incredibly winning the AI cup
but also on the final day banking the
final ticket to Toronto you are ready
now for the tour finals what does that
mean to
you uh no it means a lot um I really
didn't expect uh to qualify somehow and
to win this but um I mean I played
incredibly Shar this week today I feel
like I played a bit worse actually but
Magnus as well I think
uh uh we both were were quite tired and
um like I don't know about the quality
of the M but at least I was missing a
lot of ideas for Magnus and Magnus was
also missing a lot of ideas for me like
that was not happening two days ago but
Magnus always shows to be the king of
making combat it is supposed to be
impossible to beat him in two matches
what is the main reason you were able to
do that
today I think just um uh well first of
all this first match I think I was quite
dominated throughout uh but I got this
lucky break in game one uh where he over
pushed and then gave up this Pawn on F2
thinking probably that he was forcing a
draw but
but actually wasn't and um and then the
next three games um like no actually the
last game I got it under control but the
the next two games game two and three I
think I was
um uh quite
like on the verge of being much worth at
least and completely lost actually in
game three and then the second match
again like um so this time I recked very
briefly this uh this line to know what
to do um but then I forgot actually the
the final move of my preparation with
king
h8 um so I knew like it was kind of
trouble but then Magnus didn't take my
work uh problem is that Rook C returns
Queen C2 and then I don't know I was
feeling like I was close to winning
actually uh
there was so much counterplay for him so
many tactic tactical ideas I didn't know
what to do and then I ended up winning
that
game uh and then the last game I feel
like I messed up
but then I decided uh I should go for
this P sacrifice not suffer CU I didn't
feel I would have the energy to defend
another bad
position and it turned out great like I
after six I was considering King E8 as
his main option to play for a
win uh I don't know um like but I saw
that Queen C4 was not working and that
basically I thought he had to play King
E8 if you wanted to to keep the
fight and uh Maxim congratulations how
much confidence does this give you for
future challenges future tournaments in
the next few
months I mean like it's definitely a
great feeling to have play this well and
uh to have bitten Magnus twice in a day
of course it's good even if I don't
think we saw the best version of Magnus
today far from it uh but still it is
obviously an achievement
itself and yeah I'm looking forward of
course to to next tournaments uh of
course mostly I have my eyes on gun swis
now uh which will be in a month
hopefully I can play as well and then uh
then I think I have some
chances Maxim huge congratulations and
yeah thank you so much for entertaining
us with your amazing chess today and my
question is I think a little bit more
out of personal curiosity that I have
cuz I think there's so much to learn
from uh from what we saw today and I
want to ask you coming into this match
today having to play Magnus and you know
you have to beat him twice to make it to
Toronto what was your mindset going into
this Mar and how were you assessing
where your best chances
are oh I was just taking it one game at
a time and of course again I got this
lucky break in game one of course if I
don't win it uh uh to actually take the
lead against Magnus is uh quite
difficult and but some this happened
because um yeah he he over pressed and
lost this game initially being a Pon up
um and then I was taking it one game at
the time and you know not trying to to
push my leg too much not trying to be
too passive either because of course
that's not a good strategy against
Magnus but um yeah
somehow this mix of solidity and uh uh
finding practical resources to to get
counter player I mean this obviously is
one of of the things I'm very good at at
least I consider myself to be a good at
and uh I did manage this uh today um
there's something I I feel I didn't
manage to too well today like my
calculation was a bit shaky
but over it's kind of number uh I was
feeling tired already from the start of
the day and uh short it got
worse fatigue can definitely be a factor
and like you're saying it's been a long
week for you uh Maxim when you won that
first set and going into this Grand
Final reset having done this first big
task of taking down Magnus in the first
match uh how were you thinking about
your chances at that point and then this
crazy sacrifice at the end were you able
to keep your cool or what thoughts of
Toronto already in your
head uh you mean Bishop H7 like I don't
know like but I thought it's my best
chance
and I couldn't find a win for him after
after Rook H6 I thought maybe King E8 I
was calculating some lines it was really
completely out of
control
um so then I again I thought also it
might disrupt the course of the game
because uh at that moment he had uh too
much flow going for him like uh all his
moves were were coming coming in easy
and I thought um that's not what I want
especially I'm done three minutes or
four minutes and I just can apply
pressure here and there and play forever
so now this uh was a practical decision
of course uh if it closes by for then I
look very stupid but
uh but yeah it worked out very well in
the end yeah definitely did and
yesterday Maxim you mentioned some
friends that have been very important uh
to you uh during some difficult years
now I have to tell you it's Friday we've
enjoyed some popcorn here today who will
you now uh call who will you celebrate
this big victory
with who knows cuz I'm actually uh I
actually have a flight tomorrow I have
another tournament coming in so I mean
there's not going to be any big
celebration tonight maybe tomorrow with
my team in European Club Cup oh uh we'll
see all right I'll be that too Max
celebrate I want to join in
now fantastic oh that sounds like a lot
of fun Maxim just huge congratulations
on your massive uh performance uh I
think we and very many people out there
are super happy for you and uh yeah just
enjoy this
victory yeah thank you thank you for
joining us the winner Maxim vaj he takes
the AI cup beating Magnus Carlson in two
matches incredible stuff and not only
that he takes that final ticket to
Toronto he is the eighth player going to
the tour finals wow incredible uh stuff
uh from Maxim let's take a look uh at
the stats from the Grand Final uh reset
so Magnus Carlson coming from the
winners bracket meant Maxim had to win
two matches today and that's exactly
what uh he did again playing extremely
accurate uh David yeah that's right he
said that Magnus maybe not at his best
but you still need to perform incredibly
High 92% accuracy average even in such
crazy Wild Games is impressive and I
want to mention the only blunder the one
blunder we see from vas de gra there was
actually the move that clinched uh the
tournament Bishop takes H7 it was a
sacrifice that paid off it didn't
objectively work but it uh really reaped
practical rewards there well played Maxi
yeah all right let's uh sum up this
tournament we started out with the
quarterfinals eight players Magnus
Carlson started out with beating Hikaru
Nakamura Maxim he uh knocked his fellow
Frenchman Ali raaa down to the losers
bracket and on day two Maxim he won the
winner semi-finals against chak madaro
but in the Winner's final that was an
incredible match with Magnus Carlson
playing some fantastic chess Maxim still
lost that match in Armageddon and was
knocked down to the losers final where
he played Yana Pachi yesterday winning
that in a great fashion he made it
through to the Grand Final but everyone
said well it's going to be impossible to
beat Magnus Carlson in two matches but
he did Maxim and here he is the winner
of the AI cup and uh yeah incredible
stuff from Maxim bash lra we also have
to take a look at the results from the
other divisions in the AI Cup this is
division two and we have been following
fedel very closely because we knew if he
won division 2 he did have chances of
going to Toronto he did win division 2
but it is Maxim taking that final ticket
ticket winning division one in division
three we also had a grand final reset
there with Sam Sean beating Ralph
mamadov in both matches as well the
young American winning his third
division 3 is this a player you think
David that we might see more in division
2 and one maybe next season definitely
Sam seian he's I'm going to call him Mr
final because he made so many finals in
division 3 he also made Final in
division two in one of the events he
seemed to go far seemed to go deep every
time and maybe division one next time
you see this beautiful
Skyline which Skyline is this you guys
Toronto it's Toronto and these eight
players are going to Toronto for the
tour finals in December this lineup with
Magnus CWS and hear Nakamura Abdu saturo
Carana Wesley so we have lovic we have
aluja and now we also have MBL your
reaction to that lineup it's beautiful
you got world number one world number
two world number three world number five
all the top level the elite the CR Del
CR of Chess in Toronto fighting it out
and uh I think Maxim a very welld
deserving spot if the guy beats Magnus
twice on a day he has to be in Toronto
yeah this is uh the tour standings a few
of these players making it through from
winning events a few of them making it
through from the tourist standings and
who's going to be your favorite uh in
this lineup David oh it's hard to look
past Magnus Carson or Hikaru Nakamura
but I'll signal some of the young guys
as the dark horses Alara fua uh or n
back I'm toor I'm going to just love
watching all of them though yeah it's
going to be uh fantastic happening in
December but now we are joined by H
Magnus Carlson after a long day a long
tournament Magnus how are you feeling
right
now um I'm disappointed um obviously um
you know I was hoping to do quite a bit
better today but um you know Maxim was
uh was strong and
I um I failed at the critical moment so
that's um I think a fair outcome we're
very used to seeing you make uh
comebacks if you do occasionally lose a
game everyone says you are the best in
the world I'm making those comebacks why
were you not able to do that
today no as I said I messed up at the
critical moments today I wouldn't say
that I felt particularly bad coming in
like I
felt um probably a bit better actually
than I had the last couple of days that
I that I played and um I think he didn't
yeah as I said he didn't play perfectly
but um he played in his his style um
complicated the game which is also
generally I was fine with um and um
yeah at the critical moments in
especially in the first Tyre game he um
he yeah he was better but um um yeah I'm
I'm a bit annoyed especially at the
first Tyre game that I um that I missed
something very simple there I could have
at some point I could have taken his
Rook um instead of pushing a pawn and
that was just based on a very simple
oversight I just didn't see that he
could play Rook C8 and threaten Queen C2
I was calculating other things like if
I'd seen that I would have taken the
rook and would have had um a very very
safe position and I think presumably
good winning chances
so uh you know
things often go my way I didn't
today the but yeah I think the margins
for we fine and it's um yeah as I said I
think it's a it's a fair outcome he was
um he was better today so this is the AI
cup and I've had a feeling that in your
matches here with Maxim we've seen more
sacrifices than I've been used to I
think in one game today there was also
some uh opening things that sort of
resembled some AI maybe some prep you
had from the nepo match has AI play the
played a big part in your matches with
Maxim and maybe other matches as well
yeah as I as I talked about earlier uh
like Peter uses neural nets all the time
I think all the all the best players in
the seconds do so
uh yeah I mean it's it's always a Pity
to um to use some good opening
preparation like you saw that maim
played quickly so I don't think the
queen cycline was was new to him and it
it is like it's not given as bad at all
by by by engines so um it was to be be
expected it's always a Pity especially
when I got such a good position later
to uh to sort of waste that
um idea yeah and uh yeah Magnus so Maxim
vajra he not only beats the best player
in the world today in two matches he
wins the the tournament he qualifies for
the tour finals do you have some words
about his performance after he's been
through some difficult
years yeah I mean it's hard to find the
more deserving qualifier for the the
final reading I
mean it's um yeah it's it's it's amazing
I think he was very very strong in the
speed just Championship as well
and um yeah uh over over um two and a
half matches that we played now he was
um he was better so um it's it's good to
see it's good to see Maxim doing well
like there was never any real reason for
him to um you know all of a sudden be
falling off so um I think this is the
level that he's always been been capable
of playing it and yeah happy to see him
back nice and uh Magnus what's next for
you and how much are you looking forward
to those tour finals in
December yeah I'm traveling to Albania
tomorrow for the European Club cup and
from there right to Qatar for the Qatar
master so not a lot of uh not a lot of
rest um but yeah I'm looking forward to
I have a lot of events not only those
first of St finals a couple of others
coming up before um
before the end of the year so it's going
to be yeah it's going to be exciting
very nice we heard rumors uh MBL wants
to uh celebrate and have a party
tomorrow when you guys uh arrive the
same destination I don't know if you
will attend that as well
Magnus no I
mean I have won a couple of events now
in a
row uh so I mean this this year on the
tour like I've won most of my matches I
lost a couple of really close ones I
think that's that's normal um and I'm
not going to sit here and be extremely
disappointed by losing in the Grand
Final against such such a field I always
want to win um but
um yeah he was he was very strong and I
fa that the critical moment so uh this
I'm definitely not not
heartbroken by by this for this loss
glad to hear that Magus thank you for uh
joining us we look forward so much to
seeing you in the tour finals you will
be the one to beat there the two time
Champions chest T
Champion yeah thank you thank you for H
joining us a few months until that
happens that's going to be in uh
December you guys mentioned Magnus as
the favorite the one to beat um it's a
long time until tour finals but uh but
yeah what what do you expect already now
Tanya you have to beat the best to be
the best right and uh I think it's very
hard to bet against Magnus in that tour
final just the year that he's had he's
won three events of the Champions
Chester the World Cup winner uh he's
just won every single event that he's
played this year and this one as well
making it to the finals Magnus a huge
favorite but I think the FI that we have
with Hikaru Nakamura with Fabby with ML
and all the others it's going to be it's
going to be a fight it's going to be a
big fight and I'm really excited about
it I'm really looking forward to that
one eight amazing players going to
Toronto you can also uh head to Toronto
if you place a bid for the nft trophy
for the AI cup owning the AI generated
trophy of uh CCT event number six the AI
cup comes with a ticket to the 2023 tour
finals in Toronto in December and if you
head to Chester
champs. you can place your bid which
then comes with that uh very nice ticket
that was it for the AI cup we have a
champion his name is Maxim Vash lra such
a deserved champion and he banks his
ticket to Toronto David you are
traveling tomorrow as well going to
enter that uh mvl party I guess yeah
that's the only reason uh definitely not
for any tournaments or anything but uh
that'll be fun a lot of chess still for
the rest of the year a lot to look
forward to yeah oh and we have another
winner we actually have to uh announce
because we had a competition today on
Instagram uh we wanted you guys to share
your pictures following the chess today
and we have uh radoslav saying watching
the AI cup
from Champions chess Tour on a London
bus getting home on this Friday evening
after a long week enjoy your weekend
people I love that and uh you will now
receive
this air things wave mini thank you
everyone for sharing your pictures and
spending your Friday here with us oh I
also enjoyed so much spending my Friday
here with you guys a it's been awesome
guys this is uh it's been such a great
tournament Thank God It's Friday and
what chess we had just an amazing way to
end yeah it's been a fantastic season so
far and the best is still ahead in
December yes can't wait can't wait tour
finals coming up in December in Toronto
everyone thank you so so much for
watching this week for watching today we
will be back with the tour finals in
December have a great weekend and a
Friday everyone but bye for
now oh my gosh oh he's up a second P
Magnus is just going all in I think he's
lost his head here a bit and that's it
Magnus resigns we are heading to a grand
final Reon NV he is on fire the
Frenchman wo what oh my my gosh I love
it David Maxim vaj wins another game he
takes the lead there's no checks black
is no counter play he's going to be
checkm Maxim vaj the Frenchman he wins
the AI
[Music]
cup
he
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
h
he
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
he